SUB COMMITTEE ONE WILL COME TO
ORDER- AND LET ME GO THROUGH OUR
RULES IN RESPONSE TO THE CODE
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES. WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS ENDED
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS THE
SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING IN THE CAPITOL TODAY-
AND SENATORS MAN ANIL CHOI BOGUE
WILL BE PRESENT IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM. BY THOSE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
FOR A REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE
MUTE YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS
THIS WILL GREATLY AIDED
ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. BYPASS THAT EVERY TIME
YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED TO CHU
USED TO RAISE THE HAND FEATURE
IN THE PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK. UP POP
UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE.
PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE YOU
BEGIN SPEAKING. R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOUR DONE. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE THAT YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN THE HEARING
ROOM TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING. I'M A REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE
IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND IT IS DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN RIGHT NOW I CAN SEE
THIS. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS. 877-226-8163 R. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN TWO TWO SIX ONE SIX THREE
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS.
736-283-3736 TWO EIGHT THREE
THREE. FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCE ISTOM
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
INDOOR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT ARE
YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY
MODERATOR- TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
PRESS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WHITE. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOUR
WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LONG
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
ON MUTED AND YOU'LL BE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE R. AS WELL HERE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY
AND AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO
GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM
YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS NEEDED
- HI- I DID IN TODAY'S HEARING
WE HAVE EIGHT DISCUSSION ITEMS.
FOR THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THIS IS THE SIXTH OF
TEN HEARINGS THAT WE WERE HAVING
IN A FIVE WEEK PERIOD. ON EVERY
DIFFERENT ASPECT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED EDUCATION
BUDGET. WE WILL DISCUSS MANY OF
THOSE BUDGET PROPOSALS ON
ENROLLMENT APPORTIONMENT STUDENT
SUPPORT SERVICES AND END TO OUR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AMONG OTHER
TOPICS. WE WILL MOVE ARE ALSO
INTO AN UPDATE FOR THE HIGHER
EDUCATION STUDENT HOUSING
PROGRAM. THIS IS GOING TO BE A
LONG HEARING WE HAVE TO BE OUT
OF THIS ROOM AT NOON. AND WE
HAVE EIGHT MEDIA ITEMS AND SO I
WANT TO ANNOUNCE TO THOSE OF YOU
THAT ARE LISTENING AT HOME. THAT
WHEN WE GET TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
IF WE ARE REALLY RUNNING LATE
ENOUGH AGAINST THAT TIME.
THERE'S A CHANCE THAT WE WILL
JUST ASK YOU TO DO YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION. AND WHAT YOUR
POSITION IS JUST FOR AND AGAINST
OR- ANY PARTICULAR ITEM OR LINE
ITEM. AND IF WE HAVE TIME WILL
PROBABLY TAKE ANYBODY AND LIMIT
THEM TO IT A MINUTE AS LONG AS
WE HAVE TIME. SO OUR THAT IS OUR
PROCESS OR WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO ITEM NUMBER ONE WHICH IS
ISSUE NUMBER ONE ON ENROLLMENT.
AND OUR PANEL IS DAN HOW'RE
HANDWORK FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE PAUL STEEN HOUSE AND
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. AND DOCTOR WAS IT NUMBER
OF LISTS THAT NOT CORRECT FROM
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND- ARE I
REALLY APPRECIATE ALL PANELISTS
ON EIGHT PANELS BUT TODAY. IF
YOU'VE PROVIDED SOMETHING IN
WRITING WE DO NOT HAVE TIME FOR
YOU TO GO OVER THE WHOLE THING
MORALLY WE REALLY NEED AS BEST
AS POSSIBLE TO KEEP THIS HEARING
MOVING. SO WE'LL TAKE THOSE
SPEAKERS IN THE ORDER I
INTRODUCED THEM AND WALL WILL
BEGIN WITH DAN FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WELCOME TO
THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU CHAIR
DAN HANNAH REQUIREMENT OF
FINANCE AND I WILL TRY TO KEEP
MY COMMENTS- FOR EACH OF THESE
PANELS FREE- HOWEVER I WOULD
LIKE TO QUICKLY START- BY
TOUCHING ON THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES MULTI YEAR
ROADMAP. THE ROADMAP BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE FOCUSES ON
EQUITY AND STUDENT SUCCESS-
BUILDING UPON THE SYSTEM'S
VISION FOR SUCCESS THE ROAD MAP
ESTABLISH A SHARED EXPECTATIONS
AND AMBITIOUS GOALS. BESTING
AVAILABLE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT RESOURCES FOR THE COLLEGES
TO SUPPORT THESE EFFORTS. IN
EXPANDING CHANCES OF ITS
CAPACITY TO BETTER SUPPORT
COLLEGES MEANS GOALS. IN
PARTICULAR THE MULTI YEAR
ROADMAP FOCUSES ON GOALS RELATED
TO INTER SEGMENTAL COLLABORATION
FOR TIMELY TRANSFER. REDUCING
TIME 2 DEGREES CLOSING EQUITY
GAPS AND IMPROVING ALIGNMENT
WITH K. TWELVE AND WORKFORCE
NEEDS. I NOT TURNED ON ROLAND.
THE CONTINUES TO DECLINE
ENROLLMENT THE COLLEGE SYSTEM IS
A POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT THREAT
TO THE FACE FUNDING FOR
DISTRICTS TO EIGHT ADDRESSING
THIS ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION ONETIME PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND IS
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FOR ENROLLMENT OUTREACH
AND STUDENT RETENTION EFFORTS
BUILDING ON A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
MILLION PROVIDED LAST YEAR.
THESE FUNDS WILL BE AVAILABLE
FOR SIMILAR USES AT THE AFTER
MENTIONED FUNDS PROVIDED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET.
FURTHER TO MEET THE DIVERSE
LEARNING MENTALITY DEMANDS OF
THE STATE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS. THE BUDGET INCLUDES AN
EXPECTATION THAT DISTRICTS
PROVIDE AT LEAST 50% IN PERSON
EDUCATION. FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE ACADEMIC YEAR
PROVIDED THAT APPROACH IS
CONSISTENT WITH PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDELINES IN PLACE AT THE TIE.
AND STUDENT DEMAND. THIS
EXPECTATION IS DESIGNED TO
PROVIDE STUDENTS WITH
EDUCATIONAL OPTIONS TO MEET
THEIR NEEDS. AND ENCOURAGE
GREATER HOMELESS. WITHOUT HAVING
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE ABOUT THE SERVICE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- WILL MOVE TO THE
LA- GOOD MORNING. LAYARD I'M
POLICY HOUSING WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
COUPLE THINGS TO NOTE ON THIS
ISSUE THERE'S ACTUALLY A-
THERE'S ALSO PROPOSAL BY THE
ADMINISTRATION TO PROVIDE ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ON
GOING FOR ENROLLMENT GROWTH. NOW
MATE MAYBE A BIT SURPRISING TO
HEAR- PROPOSAL BY ENROLLMENT
GROWTH FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BECAUSE
CONSISTENT WITH NATIONWIDE
TRENDS FOR TWO YEAR COLLEGES THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
HAVE EXPERIENCED SIGNIFICANT
ENROLLMENT DECLINES BETWEEN. TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWENTY ONE. BUT
BASED ON SOME PRELIMINARY DATA
THAT THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE HAS
RECEIVED THERE APPEARED TO BE
SOME DISTRICTS THAT MAY BE
STARTING TO SEE ENROLLMENT
GROWTH. IN THE CURRENT YEAR SO
THIS COULD MEAN SOME LEVEL OF
GROWTH FUNDING IS WARRANTED FOR
THE BUDGET YEAR WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE USE UPDATED ROMAN
INFORMATION THAT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IS BUSY
WORKING ON NOW TO HELP MAKE A
DECISION ON ROMAN GROWTH FOR
THE- FOR THE SPRING. NOW THE
PROPOSAL FOR A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME FOR
RETENTION AND ROMAN STRATEGIES.
THAT ONE MIGHT BE A LITTLE
TRICKIER FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
LIST TO ADDRESS AS AN APARTMENT
OF FINANCE MENTIONED THE- TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET PROVIDED A
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE SAME PURPOSE. NOW
COLLEGES WERE NOT REQUIRED TO
REPORT ON HOW MUCH THEY HAVE
LEFT OF THAT MONEY.OR WHETHER
THE FUNDS THEY SPENT TO DATE
HAVE SHOWN. SUCCESS IN IN
BRINGING BACK STUDENTS ARE
BRINGING BACK MORE STUDENTS THAN
OTHERWISE MIGHT HAVE BEEN
ENROLLED IN THE COLLEGE'S SO
IT'S GONNA BE HARDER FOR THE
LEGISLATURE. TO ASSESS WHETHER
ANOTHER ROUND OF FUNDING FOR
THAT PURPOSE IS- PROMISING OR
NOT- IN ADDITION THERE ARE%
SURVEYS AND RESEARCHES SUGGEST
THE MAJOR REASONS WHY. ADULTS
ARE NOT COMING TO THE COLLEGES
RIGHT NOW AS WE NEED TO WORK ON
A FULL TIME BASIS GIVEN THEIR
FINANCIAL SITUATION OR NEED TO
CARE FOR OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS
DURING THIS TIME. SO IF THAT'S
THE CASE IT'S UNCLEAR WHETHER
ADDITIONAL MONEY FOR ADVERTISING
OR PHONE BANKS ARE EITHER OUT OF
REACH OUR WILL BE AFFECTED BUT
THE LEGISLATURE COULD PROVIDE
THE MONEY. ANOTHER OPTION IS TO
PROVIDE THE MONEY TO GET IT-
MAKE IT MORE FLEXIBLE SO THAT
COLLEGES MIGHT BE ABLE TO USE IT
FOR OUR RECRUITMENT NOT REACH
BUT ALSO USE IT FOR OTHER
PURPOSES SUCH AS- MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR STUDENTS. OR TO
HELP WITH COVERED MITIGATION-
SERVICES ARE SCREENING AND
TESTING AND CLEAN AND THAT SORT
OF THING SO ANOTHER OPTION IS TO
SERVE AND MAYBE HAVE A COVERT
TYPE BLOCK GRANT. THAT COULD BE
USED FOR MORE THAN JUST OUR.
REGION ENROLLMENT PURPOSES.
TRACKING MY- TO HALF AGAIN
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I'LL MOVE ON TO THE- COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
MORNING CENTER LAYERED IN
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE MANY
MISSILES THAT NEVER AT SECULAR
SCENES ARE INSTITUTIONAL SUPPORT
AND SUCCESS THAT THE TEAMSTERS
OFFICE WE ARE PROUD OF TODAY'S
COLLEGE POPULATION IT LOOKS LIKE
AN REPRESENTS CALIFORNIA IN FACT
64% OF ME COLLEGE ENROLLEES OUR
STUDENTS OF COLOR. AND MORE THAN
40% ARE TWENTY FIVE AND OLDER IN
THE LAST YEAR THE CALIFORNIA ME
COLLEGE IS A PLACE GREATER FOCUS
ON OUTREACH TO POSTER NATIONAL
STUDENTS THIS FALL THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE VISITED
EIGHT COLLEGES TO LISTENING HERE
DIRECTLY FROM STUDENTS ABOUT
THEIR NEEDS. INSTANCE REITERATED
THEIR NEED TO BALANCESCHOOL AND
WORK OVER 60% OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS WORK I SOLD
PROVIDERS OR FOR NECESSITY THEY
REITERATED THAT MANY OF THEM
HAVE DEPENDENT CHILDREN OR
GENERATION STUDENTS AND OLDER.
THESE POPULATIONS ACROSS A RANGE
OF ENGINE INDICATORS ARE
EXPERIENCING A FAR GREATER
HEALTH AND ECONOMIC IMPACTS
AROUND THE PANDEMIC AND THE
BEACH CHOOSING IN CLAIMING THIS
PART OF THE GREAT RENEGOTIATION
PHENOMENA. TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
WHAT IS HAPPENING TO OUR
STUDENTS WE CONTINUE TO COLLECT
INFORMATION ON CURRENT INSTEON
CURRENT ENROLLMENT AND STUDENT
BARRIERS TO ENROLLMENT AND
PERSISTENCE I WE WILL BE
SUPPORTING VARIOUS A MOMENT
SURVEYS. NATIONAL WORK IT'LL
ALSO COLLECT QUALITATIVE AND
QUANTITATIVE DATA INCLUDING
FOCUS GROUPS ADDITIONAL WORK
LIES AHEAD IN BRINGING AND
STUDENTS THAT MAY HAVE STOPPED
OUT DURING THE CAN DOWN MAKE OR-
HAVE BARRIERS TO ROLLING A
GREATER INTENSITY. COLLEGES HAVE
RESPONDED WITH MANY STRATEGIES
WHICH ARE HIGHLIGHTED- IN YOUR-
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS WE THINK- AND
DATED THE STAFF FOR INCLUDING
THAT IN THERE. THE CHANCES
OFFICE WILL HAVE A MORE COMPLETE
PICTURE ON ENROLLMENT WHEN
REMAINING DISTRICTS TO MAKE
THEIR DATA WILL BE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE UPDATES TO MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE. THE PROPOSAL
HUNDRED FIFTY A MILLION WILL BE
ESSENTIAL TO ENABLE TO STRATEGY
. ARE THOSE THAT WITH. WE
ANTICIPATE NEED. GROW THREE. AS
WE SHARED BY L. A. L. NEED YOU
KNOW SOME COLLEGES DISTRICT HAVE
FUND GROWTH. WE ALL. BELIEVE
THAT THERE PROPOSED ROADMAP FOR
CALIFORNIA WE COLLEGES THAT'S A
BOLD STRATEGY AND THE VISION FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND HIGHER
EDUCATION. YOU'LL NOTICE THAT
THIS FRAMEWORK BUILDS UPON THE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS VISION FOR
SUCCESS RATES GREATER ATTENTION
AROUND DATA SHARING AND CROSS
SYSTEM COLLABORATION WHICH IS
CRITICAL DURING THIS TIME. SO WE
ARE GLAD TO SUPPORT THIS AND-
APPRECIATE ITS ALIGNMENT. AND
REEVE RE FOCUS ON THE VISION FOR
SUCCESS CORRECT IT'S COMPLEX
THAT CRITICAL IN WE HOWEVER MANY
ASPECTS STATE LEADERS REMAIN
STATE STEADFASTNESS PARTNERS SO
THAT WE DON'T LOSE MOMENTUM.
THANK. YOU AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. END THE WAY OUR AGENDA HAS
BEEN STRUCTURED. ISSUE ONE
BLEEDS INTO ISSUE TOO WHICH
BLEEDS INTO ISSUE THREE AND SO
EVEN THOUGH IN A FEW MINUTES
WE'LL GET TO ISSUE TWO AND
THREE. I WANT TO ASK SOME
OVERVIEW QUESTIONS THAT MAY WELL
BE THINGS THAT YOU TOUCH ON A
LITTLE MORE IN THE NEXT ITEMS
BUT I THINK THEY ALL FIT
TOGETHER AND WE SHOULD TALK
ABOUT THEM IS ONE. AND THE FIRST
ONE AND MAYBE. IT SHOULD START
WITH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES- THE
NEW REFERENCE THE VISION FOR
SUCCESS AND WE HAVE IN OUR
GENDER PACKET THE DIFFERENT
GOALS THAT WERE PART OF THAT
AND- PERCENT STEP WERE REACHED
AGAINST THE GOALS AND SOME WERE
GOOD SOME DIDN'T QUITE GET
THERE. AND IT IS UNCLEAR IN SOME
WAYS WHAT THE EFFECT OF THE
PANDEMIC IS WHERE OTHERWISE
THERE MIGHT HAVE BEEN PROGRESS
TOWARD THE GOALS. AND SO ARE YOU
JUST A AN OVERVIEW QUESTION IS
THE VISION FOR SUCCESS IN YOUR
MIND SORT OF COMPLETED AS A
PROGRAM AND ARE YOU MOVING ON.
TO THE ROAD MAP IS THAT THE WAY
WE SHOULD LOOK AT THIS. THANK
YOU SENATOR LAYERED- INJURE OUR
WORK WE CONTINUE TO ALIGN OUR
EFFORTS AROUND THE VISION FOR
SUCCESS AND YOU SEE THE ROADMAP
IS COMPLEMENTARY WHAT THE ROAD
MAP PROVIDES IS ADDED MOMENTUM
TO THE WORK- THAT IS INDICATED
IN THE VISION FOR SUCCESS. EVERY
MADE THE CHANGES OFFICE PROVIDES
A STATE OF THE SYSTEM REPORT
WHERE WE SHARE WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS AND PARTNERS WHERE
WE ARE IN RESPECT TO THAT THE
FIRST TIME THAT AS A SYSTEM
WE'VE BEEN DOCUMENTING AND
TRACKING. OUR WORKER GOALS ANY
GAINS WE THINK THAT THIS IS-
CONTINUES TO BE IMPORTANT ALSO
NOTE THAT COLLEGES UNDER
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN OH NINE
WHICH WAS ESTABLISHED IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT ALSO HAVE LOCAL
VISION GOALS THAT ARE ALIGNED
WITH THE VISION FOR SUCCESS. SO
WE DO THINK THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
TO. KEEP THIS FOCUSED AS IT
ALIGNS EFFORTS AROUND
COMPLETION. TIME 2 DEGREES
UNITED TEAM AND ALL THINGS THAT
ARE OFTEN HIGHLIGHTED THE MAP BY-MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE AS
PRIORITIES THEN LET ME. STICK
WITH THAT FOR A MINUTE. BECAUSE
I'M GATHERING A RATHER. QUESTION
SO- GAP. THAT YOU WILL TAKE THE
GOALS THAT ARE IN THE VISION
SUCCESS KEEP THEM AS GOALS AND
STILL MEASURE AGAINST THEM EVEN
THOUGH IT WAS ORIGINALLY STE
ESTABLISHED AS A FIVE YEAR TIME
HORIZON IS THAT CORRECT. CORRECT
WE SOMETHING TO THE RIGHT
DIRECTION TO BE MOVING IN THE
RIGHT FOCUS AREAS AND ON A
PERCENTAGE THAT YOU HAVE.
ACHIEVED IN THE FIVE YEARS. HOW
DID THOSE ALIGNED WITH WHAT
YOU'RE GOAL WAS FOR ACHIEVEMENT
IN THOSE PERCENTAGES IN THOSE
FIVE YEARS. WE'VE SEEN SOME-
STALL- AS A RESULT OF THE
PANDEMIC AND SOME OF THE
COMPLICATIONS OF THE LAST FEW
YEARS BUT WE DO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT COLLEGES HAVE TO
KNOW THE COLLEGES HAVE MADE-TREMENDOUS GAINS PARTICULARLY IN
AREAS AROUND- UNITS UNITED TEAM
MEANT AND THE INTENSITY OF
ENROLLMENT. OKAY AND THEN LET'S
MOVE TO THE ROAD MAP BUT- I HAVE
A COPY BUT IT IT WASN'T IN OUR
AGENDA PACKET N. R. SHOULD MAKE-
MAYBE I SHOULD ASK THIS IS A
FORM OF A QUESTION FIRST BUT I
THINK IT'S JUST A CLARIFICATION
FOR OUR LISTENING AUDIENCE-
WE'VE ALREADY HAD OUR HEARINGS
ON UC AND CSU. AND IN EACH OF
THOSE THERE WAS A COMPACT AND
GROWTH WAS CONTINGENT ON THE
COMPACT. AND- AND THEY WERE
DISTINCTLY TIED TOGETHER. THIS
IS DIFFERENT BECAUSE I BELIEVE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE FUNDED BY
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT AND
IT'S NOT THE GENERAL FUND AND A
DIRECT APPROPRIATION THE WAY IT
IS WITH UC AND CSU. SO IS THE-
AND MAYBE FINANCE CAN START ON
THIS IT IS THE IDEA HERE THAT
THIS IS A ROAD MAP RATHER THAN A
COMPACT BECAUSE WE HAVE PROP
NINETY EIGHT AND- THEN A
DECENTRALIZED SYSTEM AND- THAT
THE MONEY THAT IS FUNDED FOR
GROWTH HAS TO COME FROM PROP
NINETY EIGHT SO IT'S A ROAD MAP.
AND THEN WITH AVAILABLE PROP
NINETY EIGHT FUNDS IS THAT
CORRECT. I I'D SAY YES DINNER
FROM THE FINANCE THAT YES I'D
SAY THAT'S LARGELY CORRECTED
THAT- THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
FUNDED UNDERNEATH THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE AND SO WE HAVE TO WORK
WITHIN THOSE AVAILABLE RESOURCES
WHEN CONSIDERING- ONGOING
FUNDING TOWARDS THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT
FOR THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES THERE
IS THE- STATUTORY COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT THAT IT'S GONNA
PLIED. TO THE STUDENT CENTERED
FUNDING FORMULA- SO THERE IS
SOME EXPECTATION OF CONTINUED
ONGOING FUNDING. AND THEN- LET
ME ASK AND MAYBE THEIR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM AND THEN FINANCE
OR DALY- CAN CHIME IN IF THEY
WANT. UP ON THE ROAD MAP. FROM
THE A THE REPRESENTATIVE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SAYS IT'S
COMPLIMENTARY TO THE VISION FOR
SUCCESS SO WHERE'S THE OVERLAP
AND WIRES NOT THE OVERLAP WHERE
DOES THE ROAD MAP GO FURTHER
THAN WHAT IS. IN THE GOALS FOR
THE VISION OF SIX FOR SUCCESS.
HAVE YOU TO ADDRESS THAT FIRST
SENATOR LAYERED ONE ALL CALL
ATTENTION TO IS AROUND THE GOAL
4 DEGREES COMPLETION THE VISION
FOR SUCCESS HAS GOAL OF A 20%
INCREASE BY TWENTY TWENTY TO.
THEIR VISION AND THE ROADMAP
CALLS FOR A SIMILAR GOAL WITH AN
EXTENDED TIMELINE WE THINK THAT
IT'S STILL IMPORTANT TO CONTINUE
TOWARDS THAT GOAL- AND THEN
ADDED TIMELINE RECOGNIZES THE
COMPLEXITIES STUDENTS IN
COLLEGES HAVE FACED OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS. AND THEN MAYBE.
I SHOULD FIND. SO DO YOU BELIEVE
THAT- PROGRESS ON TH ROADMAP IS
SOMETHING THAT IS CONTINGENT ON
FUTURE RECOMMENDATIONS WITH
REGARD TO THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
IN THE BUDGET. AND AS NOTED MY
COLLEAGUE AT THAT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE- WE REALLY
DO VIEW THE DIMINISH A RELIGIOUS
VIEW OF THE ROAD MAP IS BEING
COMPLIMENTARY AND BUILDING ON
THE VISION FOR SUCCESS- I THINK
IN IN LARGE PART THE
ADMINISTRATION FEELS THAT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE MOVING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION. WITH THE
VISION FOR SUCCESS IN THIS IS
REALLY DESIGNED TO SORT OF BUILD
ON THAT PROGRESS AND SO I THINK
THERE THERE ARE- DIFFERENT
DIRECTIONS SUCH AS THINGS LIKE
CONCOURSE NUMBERING IN AND- THAT
THE COMMISSION WANTS TO CONTINUE
PUSHING ON ONE HERE. LET ME
INTERRUPT FOR SECOND AND THE
ALEJO'S IN LINE BUT LET ME
FINISH THIS LINE OF QUESTIONING.
WHAT I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND IS
THE UC AND CSU. COMPAQ'S MAKE.
CAN GROWTH FUND. CONTINGENT ON
MEETING. A WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
THOSE CONTACTS AND I AM TRYING
TO STE ASK. IF THERE'S A SIMILAR
PRINCIPLE AT PLAY HERE. THAT
YOU'VE DONE A ROAD MAP YOU'VE
LAID OUT THIS VERSION OF WHAT IS
A COMPACT FOR THE OTHER TWO. IF
THEY DON'T MAKE PROGRESS DOES
THAT AFFECT WHAT YOU DO IN THE
FUTURE HAVE YOU LINKED TO THE TO
THE WAY THEY ARE LINKED IN UC
AND CSU. REST OF MY- OF MY
BODY'S AYE I WOULD NOTE THAT
THE- AGAIN AS AS YOU PREVIOUSLY
REFERENCED THE COMMUNICATORS ARE
FUNDED UNDERNEATH THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE SO THERE IS THAT-
LEVEL OF EXPECTED FUNDING-
INCLUDED WITHIN THE CONTACT IS
THIS SORT OF- EXPECTATION THAT
AS AS- THE COMMUNICORP IS
CONTINUE WORKING TOWARD THESE
GOALS THE ADMINISTRATION WILL
CONTINUE TO MAKE. SURE TARGETED
INVESTMENTS TO HELP COLLEGES
MEET THE VISION FOR SIX FOR THE
MULTIROOM APPLES. AND THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ALSO PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE-
CHANCES OFFICE STATE OPERATIONS
SUPPORT. TO HELP THE CHANCES
OFFICER IT'S DISTRICTS WITH MANY
MUSICALS AND I NOTICED DALY-
TOOK HIS HAND DOWN. TO NO LONGER
WANT TO MAKE A STATEMENT. NO I
DO I JUST TO ASK TO THAT.
BURDENS GRILL THAT'S CORRECT
THAT YOUR PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT WHICH IS IN THE STATE
CONSTITUTION. IS NOT CONTINGENT
ON. THE COLLEGE'S MEETING
SPECIFIC TARGETS. ALTHOUGH THE
LEGISLATURE HAS SOME FLEXIBILITY
WITHIN PROP NINETY EIGHT YOU
COULD DECIDE TO. MAKE SOME
FUNDING LINKED TO CERTAIN
OUTCOMES AND THEN ANY MONEY
THAT'S NOT EARNED COULD GO TO K.
TWELVE OR SOME OTHER PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT PURPOSE. THE SECOND
THING I JUST WANTED TO MENTION
IS THAT. BAD THE GOALS THERE ARE
NUMBER OF GOALS IN THE VISION
FOR SUCCESS. THAT THE CALL A DA
. AND WHAT'S IN THE PROPOSED
ROAD MAP SO THERE IS OVERLAP
THERE ARE IN SOME CASES THE ROAD
MAP GOES BEYOND THE VISIONS FOR
SUCCESS FOR EXAMPLE. THERE IS A-
CALL IN THE ROAD MAP FOR
INTERSEGMENT ALL COLLABORATION.
FOR THE COLLEGES TO WORK WITH
THE UNIVERSITIES FOR EXAMPLE TO
ESTABLISH A COMMON INTEGRATED
ADMISSIONS PLATFORM AND THERE
ARE THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
OTHERS- GOALS THAT ARE IN THE
ROAD MAP THERE ARE NOT IN THE
VISION FOR SUCCESS. I JUST SO I
JUST WANT TO MAKE THAT POINT.
CLEAR OKAY. N. APPRECIATE THAT
AND- LET ME MAKE THE SAME
COMMENT HERE THAT I MADE IN THE
UC CSU HEARINGS AND THAT IS. I
KNOW THIS IS A LITTLE DIFFERENT
BECAUSE WE HAVE PROP NINETY
EIGHT EIGHT AND THEIR DIFFERENT
THINGS THAT APPROPRIATE FROM
THAT IN A WAY THAT. AREN'T AS
DISCRETIONARY IS THE GENERAL
FUND APPROPRIATION AND CSU AND
UC. ARE BROAD THE COMMENT I MADE
IN THOSE HEARINGS IS THE
GOVERNOR AND THE INSTITUTION MAY
HAVE AGREED ABOUT WE HAVE THE
CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY TO
APPROPRIATE TO MAKE IT HAPPEN
AND THERE SHOULDN'T BE AN
AUTOMATIC ASSUMPTION. THAT THIS
AGREEMENT IS MADE AND COMPLETELY
DONE BECAUSE THE LEGISLATURE
NEEDS TO BE INVOLVED AND I THINK
WE WILL WANT TO. LOOK AT THIS
AGREEMENT OVER TIME. ARE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE FULLY UNDERSTAND IT
AND WHEN WE COME BACK FOR THE
MAY REVISE. UP HA IF WE HAVE ANY
CONCERNS WE WILL EXPRESS THEM AT
THAT TIME BUT I JUST WANNA.
THANK KNOWLEDGE THAT WHILE WE
MIGHT NOT HAVE HAD A SEAT AT THE
TABLE WITH THE NEGOTIATIONS WE
HAVE A SEAT AT THE TABLE SO.
JUST SO THE THAT THAT THAT IS
UNDERSTOOD AND AN A AYE WHAT THE
OTHER BRANCHES NO. DATA IF I
READ IN THE NEWSPAPER THAT
THEY'RE NOW SAYING IT IS A DONE
DEAL WENT AHEAD AND THAT IT'S
ALL OVER I WILL HAVE A COMMENT
SO- JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT
STATEMENT IS MADE. AND THEN. TO
GO- THE A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
RIGHT. TALK ABOUT- WHEN THE
ENROLLMENT GROWTH NUMBERS ARE
GOING TO BE AVAILABLE AND- BORN
ROMAN NUMBERS AND- I KNOW YOUR
DEADLINE FOR THE INDIVIDUAL
COLLEGES TO REPORTERS PASSED
WHEN DO YOU EXPECT TO HAVE ALL
OF THEM REPORT AND YOU HAVE
THOSE NUMBERS FOR PUBLIC REVIEW
. INTERLAYER DARING CAN DESERVE
JULIE TO FINALIZE THE NUMBERS BY
THE END OF THIS MONTH SO THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE TO INFORM.
LEGISLATIVE CONVERSATIONS AN
EXTERNAL REVIEW. IF WE DON'T
HAVE ALL THE DATA FROM ALL
DISTRICTS WE WILL NOTE THAT AS
EXEMPTIONS- AND CLARIFY THAT
WITH MY COMMITTEE CONSULTANCY
LA- DEPARTMENT FINANCE AND STATE
LEADERS- SIMILAR TO THAT MAN TO
HAVE AN EXEMPTION FOR NOT
TURNING AND THE DATE. DID YOU
JUST OFFICE DOES NOT HAVE A AND
THE AUTHORITY TO FORCE DISTRICTS
TO SUBMIT THEIR DATA AND SO
WE'VE REACHED OUT TO ALL THE
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE OUTSTANDING
DATA WE'RE HOPING THAT THEY WILL
COMPLY- AND THEN. IF WE HAVE ANY
LATE WE WILL. I KNOW THAT- WHEN
YOU SEE THAT ANALYSIS WHAT DOES
WHAT DOES IT CAMPUS AND I'M I
RECALL. IN ONE OF OUR OFFLINE
CONVERSATIONS THAT AT THAT TIME
THERE WERE TWENTY CAMPUSES THAT
HADN'T REPORTED DATA OUT OF
HOWEVER MANY IT IS OVER A
HUNDRED. IS THAT A IS THAT STILL
THE NUMBER THAT HAVEN'T REPORTED
. WE HAVE ABOUT TEN OUTSTANDING
AT THE MOMENT AND SO WE'RE
HOPEFUL THAT- THROUGH FURTHER
OUTREACH WILL BE ABLE TO GET
THAT INFORMATION BY THE END OF
THIS MONTH AND WHEN YOU SAY
THERE COULD BE AN EXEMPTION TO
SOMEBODY BENEFIT IN SOME STRANGE
WAY BY NOT REPORTING THAT DATA.
NOT NOT OUR UNDERSTANDING OF THE
BENEFITS- AND SHOCKED- WHEN THEY
DON'T SUBMIT THE DATA FROM THE
TEAMSTERS OFFICE COULD NOT
SUBMIT ON THEIR BEHALF I'VE HAD
THE NATIONALDATA REPORTING SITE
AS WELL. OKAY L. A. O. AS HIS
HAND. THE COMMITTEE MIGHT WANT
TO GET CLARIFICATION ON THE
CONSEQUENCES OF DISTRICTS NOT
REPORTING A MOMENT BECAUSE
DISTRICTS REPORT ENROLLMENT TO
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE SO THAT
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE CAN
DETERMINE HOW MUCH APPORTIONMENT
MONEY HOW MUCH GENERAL PURPOSE
MONEY THAT DISTRICT IS ENTITLED
TO SO IF THE DISTRICTS NOT
REPORTING THAT INFORMATION. I'LL
LET THE LEGISLATURE COMMITTEE
MIGHT TO UNDERSTAND HOW CAN THE
GASES OFFICE THEN KNOW HOW MUCH
TO GIVE THE DISTRICT IN FUNDING
. AND WHETHER MAYBE MONEY SHOULD
BE WITHHELD WON'T PROBLEM LET ME
TELL ME YOU KNOW THAT
INFORMATION LET ME JUST GO AHEAD
AND PUT THAT QUESTION TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT'S WHAT I
WAS TRYING TO ASK IN A MORE. UP
MANNER AND I THINK HE WAS JUST
CLEAR SO. HOW WOULD YOU RESPOND
TO THAT. YOU THINK THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE- CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT HOW WE HOLD ON DISTRICTS
ACCOUNTABLE TO ENROLLMENT
REPORTING ESPECIALLY IN TIMES
LIKE THIS HAPPY TO ENGAGE IN
CONVERSATIONS OF WHAT THAT COULD
LOOK LIKE- THAT ONE NOW THAT WAS
AN OP TO CENSOR SAYS SO- GIVEN
WHAT THE L. A. O. SAID THAT
THERE SHOULD BE CONSEQUENCES.
WAS THAT A VERY VAGUE.
SUGGESTION THAT THERE MIGHT BE
CONSEQUENCES. I MEAN THAT'S THE
QUESTION IS SOMEBODY DOESN'T
REPORT AND YOU'RE OBLIGATED TO
RELEASE MONEY TO THEM. HOW IS
THAT CONNECTED. I WANTED
PROVIDED CLARIFICATION TO
SOMETHING THAT THE L. A. O.
SAID- WE HAVE TWO DISTINCT TYPES
OF RECORDING ONE THAT IS
UTILIZED FOR OUR FINANCIAL
SYSTEMS THE OTHER IS THAT THAT
IS USED FOR- HEAD COUNT LIKE THE
KIND THAT YOU HAVE. IN YOUR
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS ALL REPORTING
FOR FINANCIAL ELEMENTS HAS BEEN
SUBMITTED WE DO HAVE THOSE WHAT
WE WHAT IS UNDER QUESTION RIGHT
NOW IS ANY DATA THAT HELPS US
UNDERSTAND WHAT SO ARE LOST IN
HEAD COUNT- THE MOMENTUM IN
WHICH STUDENTS WHAT TYPE OF
STUDENTS ARE NOT RETURNING OR
STOPPING OUT- ALL OF THAT IS
ALSO IMPORTANT. BECAUSE IT HELPS
US UNDERSTAND THE PROFILE OF WHO
ARE COLLEGES ARE SERVING AND
THEIR WORKLOAD. OKAY THAT WASN'T
CLEAR FROM YOUR EARLIER ANSWER.
AND NOW WE ARE. GET SOMEWHERE.
OF THEN LET ME ASK ANOTHER
QUESTION- BECAUSE THERE HAS BEEN
A SYSTEM AND I CAN'T REMEMBER I
HAD IT WRITTEN DOWN I. CAN'T PUT
MY HANDS ON IT FOR HOW YOU OF
SORT OF HAD A ROLLING THING ON
ENROLLMENT DURING THE PANDEMIC
OR EQUIVALENT OF A HOLD HARMLESS
ON ROMAN HAS A FUNNY NAME YOU
WOULDN'T NORMALLY ASSOCIATE WITH
THE SUBJECT BUT THAT EXPIRES ON
JUNE THIRTIETH AS I UNDERSTAND.
WHAT ARE THE PLANS FOR THE YEAR
STARTING JULY FIRST ON-
ENROLLMENT AND HOW IT'S TIED TO
THINGS. SENATOR LAYERED YOU WERE
REFERRING TO EMERGENCY CONDITION
ALLOWANCES EASIER TITLE AND NOT
OUR TITLE- FIVE PROVISIONS. THAT
THE CANCER HAS A THIRTY TWO- AND
STATE THEY'RE TYPICALLY USED
WHEN THERE ARE FIRE EMERGENCIES
EARTHQUAKE AND OTHER SUCH DURING
THE PANDEMIC MADE THOSE
AVAILABLE- FOR DOES IT NEEDED TO
PREVENT ANY AMOUNT OF FINANCIAL
LOSSES. AS A RESULT OF HEALTH
CONCERNS- OUR GOAL- AND URGENCY
FOR HAVING FINAL M. I. S. DATA
SUBMITTED IS SO THAT WE CAN MAKE
THAT ANALYSIS OUR HOPE IS TO
HAVE. THAT ANALYSIS AND A
DECISION ON EMERGENCY CONDITION
ALLOWANCES BY MARCH BUT IF YOU
DO NOT DO ANOTHER YEAR OF
EMERGENCY CONDITIONS ALLOWANCE.
IT'S SORT OF KICKS IN THE
ENROLLMENT CLIFF FOR WHAT HAS
BEEN DECLINING ENROLLMENT TO THE
PANDEMIC. OR OTHER THINGS IS
THAT CORRECT. WE THE WAY THAT ON
A FUNDING IS STRUCTURE AND THEN
AND BASS T. START RICHARD UNIT.
THEY HAVE A THREE YEAR AVERAGE
SO IT'S REALLY A STEP DOWN- THAT
THEY EMERGENCY CONDITIONS THAT
THEY'VE HAD FOR THE PAST FEW
YEARS. TO ROLL INTO THAT THREE
YEAR AVERAGE TWO EIGHT IF THEY
DO NOT GET EXTENDED WOULD ONLY A
FACT ABOUT A THIRD OF THEIR
AFTER E. S. AND WE WILL HAVE.
COMPLETE ANALYSIS BY NEXT MONTH
. OKAY AND THEN THAT LEADS TO.
OF A VERSION OF THAT QUESTION
WHICH IS UNDER EVEN THE ROLLING
THREE IN MANY WAYS THERE'S A
CLIFF AT THE END OF BECAUSE IT'S
ROLLING IN THERE BENNETT DROPS-
IS THERE SOME EXPECTATION THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE A TIME WHEN
- IF IN ROMA DOESN'T COME BACK
THAT OTHER COLLEGES ARE GOING TO
BE HIT. WITH A BIG PROBLEM
BECAUSE OF FOR A DECLINING IN
ROME. COLLEGES THAT DON'T
RESTORE BELIEVE THEIR
INVOLVEMENT THAT ALSO MEANS THAT
THEY'RE SERVING FEWER STUDENTS-
AND THEREFORE- EXTENDED
PROTECTIONS MEANS THAT WE'RE
FINDING- TAXPAYER RESOURCES FOR
STUDENTS THAT ARE NOT BEING
SERVED. SO THAT THOSE ARE THE
TYPES OF- CONVERSATIONS WE WANT
TO HAVE WITH THE LEGISLATURE THE
ELIAN HELLO. AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE- ON HOW DO WE
CONTINUE TO STRUCTURE AND
SENTENCED TO SERVE ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS- AND SERVE THEM WHILE
DURING THIS TIME. AND JUST
BEFORE I GO TO THE ALEJO WES IS
HAND UP. OF LET ME. SAY THAT
WHEN WE HAD OUR K. THROUGH
TWELVE. HEARING ON ENROLLMENT.
PROP NINETY EIGHT FUNDING. THERE
BEEN A WHOLE HARMLESS. AND THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSED HOLDING
HARMLESS ANOTHER YEAR. AND WHILE
ALL THE DISTRICTS- CHEERING
ABOUT THE FACT THAT THEY'RE HELD
HARMLESS THIS YEAR IT MEANS THAT
THERE WILL BE A CLIFF AT THE END
OF THAT AND THE QUESTION WAS.
WHICH IS WHAT I WAS TRYING TO
ASK HERE. IS WHETHER WE SHOULD
START TO THINK ABOUT ADDRESSING
THAT CLIFF NOW I'M- IF THERE'S A
HOLD HARMLESS IN A ROLLING THING
EVERYBODY WILL LOVE IT AND WE
SHOULD DO IT BUT. SHINN'S NOW
ABOUT HOW WE'RE GOING TO CUSHION
THAT RATHER THAN CHEST. COMING
UP ON IT AND HAVE EVERYBODY SAY
WHAT NOBODY SAW THIS COMING
THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO DRIVE
ACT. YEAH I BELIEVE THAT YOU'RE
HIGHLIGHTING A REALLY IMPORTANT
POINT ONE POINT TWO IS SOMETHING
THAT IS IN YOUR COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THAT- IDENTIFIES OF
THEIR OPTIONS FOR. CONSIDERING
DEALING WITH THIS- RATHER THAN
JUST SPENDING ON GROWTH THAT MAY
NOT BE THERE AT COLLEGES. RATHER
SHIFTING THE CONVERSATION TO THE
OVERALL COST OF OPERATIONS OF.
EDUCATING STUDENTS THERE ARE FEW
OPTIONS SUCH AS- INCREASING
RATES UP SUCH AS THE BASIC-
ALLOCATION- THAT- CAN BE
CONSIDERED A COULD BE PART OF
THE CONVERSATION THAT YOU'RE
REFERENCING CENTER LAYER. OKAY
WHAT THE L. A. O. HAS HIS HAND
UP AND BEFORE AFTER HE'S DONE.
UNLESS THAT RAISES ANOTHER
QUESTION OR COMMENT BEFORE GO TO
SENATOR MAN I'M JUST GOING TO
ASK IF FINANCES ANY COMMENTS ON
THIS WHOLE DISCUSSION SINCE THEY
HAVEN'T COMMENTED ON WIRELESS
WITH GOING BACK AND FORTH. SO
LET ME GO TO THE L. A. L. YOU'RE
JUST TO CLARIFY SOMETHING. IN
THE CURRENT YEAR. THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF DISTRICTS THAT ARE
GETTING THEIR FUNDING BASED ON
THREE YEARS OF PRE PANDEMIC
ENROLLMENTS SO THAT THAT WAS
MERGING SEA CONDITIONS ALLOWANCE
OF THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS
APPROVED IS ALLOWING THESE
DISTRICTS OR IS IT ABOUT FORTY
OF THEM ARE THERE ARE GETTING-
FUNDED BASED ON THREE YEARS OF A
PRE PANDEMIC NUMBERS. NOW THOSE
DISTRICTS OF. STAND TO LOSE
ENROLLMENT FUNDING BEGINNING IN
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR IF
THEY'RE ENROLLMENT DOES NOT
REBOUND OVER THE NEXT YEAR SO
AND IF THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS
DOES NOT EXTEND THE EMERGENCY
CONDITIONS ALLOWANCE. FOR
ANOTHER YEAR SO THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT- THE LEGISLATURE OF COURSE
WANT TO LOOK AT- WENT ON-
WHETHER IT ANTS DISTRICTS TO
BEGIN ADJUSTING THEIR BUDGETS
NOW IN RESPONSE TO CURRENT
ENROLLMENT CONDITIONS. OR
WHETHER YOU KNOW THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WANTS TO SIGNAL TO
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE THAT IT
WISHES TO SEE EMERGENCY
CONDITIONS ALLOWANCE EXTENDED
FOR ANOTHER YEAR BECAUSE YOU'RE
RIGHT- CARE LAYERED- YOU
DISTRICTS WILL START TO SEE A
REDUCTION IN THEIR FUNDING THAT
THEY GENERATE THROUGH THE
STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULA. IF THOSE MOMENTS DON'T
COME BACK AND THE EMERGENCY
CONDITIONS ALLOWANCE IS NOT
EXTENDED THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT I
WAS- TRYING TO. TO GET AT AND
THE THING ABOUT IT IS THAT I
REALLY DON'T WANT TO MAKE CUTS
TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES THIS YEAR.
AND THEY DON'T WANT BROAD I WANT
EVERYBODY TO BE AWARE THAT THIS
IS A COMING ISSUE AND IF THERE
IS A WAY WE NEED WE NEED TO
START TO THINK ABOUT- DEALING
WITH THAT. AND I HAVE BEEN
RESISTING IN THIS ITEM ASKING
ABOUT THE STUDENT CENTERED
FUNDING FORMULA BECAUSE WE'RE
GETTING TO THE ADDED ANOTHER
ITEM BUT I REALLY UNDERSTAND
THAT IT'S TOTALLY RELATED. TO
ALL THIS IS ONE. MORE MASS
FINANCE DO YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS
THAT THE US TO MAKE ON THIS
DISCUSSION. AND- HAPPY COMMENT-
I THINK AS AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
CHANCE UPS THERE ARE SEVERAL
PROTECTIONS CURRENTLY BUILT INTO
THE STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULA NOT TO NOT TO JUMP AHEAD
AND YOUR MORNING INSTEAD- SUCH
AS THE THREE YEAR ROLLING
AVERAGE AND THE HOLD HARMLESS
WHICH IS STILL IN PLACE FOR
DISTRICTS- AND SORT OF THE ONE
YEAR OLD THOMAS FOR DISTRICTS OF
THAT THERE ARE VARIOUS
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE BUILT IN
PLACE FOR DISTRICTS TO ENSURE
THAT THERE IS NOT. SORT OF A
STEEP DROP IN FUNDING- WE ALSO
THINK IT'S A BIT SPECULATE AT
THIS POINT TO PROJECT WHAT
FUNDING OR WHAT IN WOMAN IS
GOING TO LOOK LIKE FOR TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE WITH SO MANY
CHANGING CONDITIONS RELATED TO
THE CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC- AN
ANSWER THE SITUATION FACED BY
OUR OUR STATE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS SO I THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE CONTINUING
TO MONITOR AND WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONS WITH. OUR
PARTNERS AT THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE ANY AUDIO AND OF COURSE
THE LEGISLATURE- AS WE MOVE
FORWARD THANK YOU BECAUSE WE'RE
GOING TO WANT TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION AND- BEFORE GO TO
SENATOR. MAN FOR QUESTION LET ME
JUST. I. MY HAVE SAID IT.
SENATE ROAD CHOI BO GOING. AND
TO. ANOTHER HERE. SO IF HE
DOESN'T HAVE A QUESTION SHE
MIGHT GIVE IT TO YOU LATER. AS
SHE IS WORKING HARD AND ANOTHER
COMMITTEE SENATOR MEANT. THANK
YOU CAN AMERICANS- SO I THINK
CHAIR LAYERED COVERED A LOT OF
GROUND OBVIOUSLY I DID HAVE A
QUESTION AND THEN I COMMENT. MY
QUESTION RELATES TO A LOT OF
THE- DIALOGUE THAT YOU HAD- JUST
NOW. AROUND ENROLLMENT AND THE
CAUSES OF IT- YEAH I APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT WE'RE GOING TO GET
THE NEW ENROLLMENT NUMBERS AT
THE END OF THIS MONTH- WE HAD A
DISCUSSION WITH CSU WHICH I
THINK IS. DIFFERENT BUT HAS SOME
SIMILAR ASPECTS TO IT IS THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- IT WAS THE THINGS I
FIND INTERESTING ABOUT
ENROLLMENT RIGHT NOW IS THAT
YOU'VE GOT MULTIPLE POTENTIAL
CAUSES OF IT RIGHT- CERTAINLY
COBIT NINETEEN BOTH TE HEALTH
RELATED ASPECTS. AS WELL AS- THE
REMOTE INSTRUCTION ARE PROBABLY
FAXING HUGE FACTORS IN DECLINE
ENROLLMENT WE'VE SEEN IT SEE
ISSUES AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES-
AT THE SAME TIME THERE THERE MAY
BE OTHER FACTORS CONTRIBUTING
THAT IN AND CERTAINLY- YEAH I
ASSUME THIS IS THE SAME FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM CSU'S
TOLD ME. IN IN RESPONSE TO A
QUESTION I HAD AT THEIR HEARING.
THAT WHEN WE HAVE A STRONG
ECONOMY WITH HIGH WAGES AND LOTS
OF JOBS WHAT WE TEND TO SEE IS-
A LOT OF PEOPLE DECLINING TO GO
TO COLLEGE- INSTEAD TAKING THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO GO TO JOIN THE
WORKFORCE FOR SOME PERIOD OF
TIME- AND GIVEN THE HIGH WAGES
WE'RE SEEING NOW I WOULD IMAGINE
THAT IS ALSO A CAUSE OF THE
DECLINE IN ENROLLMENT- AND THEN
THERE'S ALSO THIS POTENTIAL
STRUCTURAL FACTORS. HOW DO WE
HAVE A CHANGING WORKFORCE TO
HAVE CHANGING DEMOGRAPHIC
TRENDS. THAT ARE CAUSING FEWER
PEOPLE TO MAYBE WANT TO GO TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. AND SO MY
QUESTION IS THIS- MAY MAYBE
SMARTLY START AND MAKE THIS A
TWO PARTER FOR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND ALEJO- DO YOU THINK
IT WOULD BE HELPFUL IF WE HAD
SOME KIND OF DATA. ON WHY
STUDENTS ARE NOT GOING TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE OR WHY THEY'RE
CHOOSING TO GO TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. AS WE KIND OF COME UP
WITH THE NUMBERS. AS WE THINK
ABOUT BUDGET ALLOCATIONS NOT
JUST THIS YEAR BUT OVER THE NEXT
FEW YEARS. OUR AND IN ROMAN
TARGETS. WELL I CAN ANSWER FIRST
IF THAT'S HELPFUL- I'D SAY-
CENTER TO YOUR QUESTION- AND
ALSO TO THE POINT YOU MADE YES.
THE CAUSE OF THIS ARE
POTENTIALLY. MYRIAD AND THERE
ARE DEFINITELY- A LOT OF
POTENTIAL REASONS WHY COMMUNITY
WIDE ENROLLMENT HAS BEEN
DECLINING. OVER THE PAST TWO
YEARS. I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT WE
ARE SEEING THESE ENROLLMENT
TRENDS NATIONWIDE SO THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING. AS WELL THAT SPECIFIC
TO CALIFORNIA OR TO OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM BUT- IS
ALREADY SOMETHING ARCING ACROSS
THE SYSTEM- I THINK I THINK OF
COURSE IT IS. IS ABSOLUTELY
HELPFUL IN HELPING US TO TAKE
CONSIDERED POTENTIAL DECISIONS
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO. HAVE CONVERSATIONS-
AS WE AS WE MOVE TOWARDS THE
MAYOR VISION AND INTO THE NEXT
TWO BUDGET YEARS. I'M RELATED TO
ENROLLMENT AND WHAT. OUR
STUDENTS ARE. HANDLING THIS BUT-
YEAH AND AGAIN IT IT. OUR
EXPECTATION IS THAT THERE ARE
GOING TO BE PRETTY- DIFFERENT
REASONS FOR VERY DIVERSE STUDENT
POPULATION SURE BUT BUT NOT
UNDERSTANDING THOSE REASONS I
GUESS WOULD BE. VERY HELPFUL IN
DETERMINING WHAT ENROLLMENT
TARGETS BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT. THAT THERE SOME OF THESE-
pBE MORE PERMANENT STRUCTURAL I
GUESS THAT THAT'S A REALLY WHAT
I'M GETTING AT. I L. A- DO YOU
HAVE ANY THOUGHTS HERE. YEAH WE
WOULD AGREE- HAVING BETTER IN.
ABOUT THE REASONS WOULD BE-
USEFUL FOR THE LEGISLATURE OF
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IS DONE
SOME WORK IN THIS AREA YEAH IN
THE FALL THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE- SURVEYED ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED. RESPECTIVE STUDENTS OR
ADULTS WHO OTHERWISE MIGHT HAVE
GONE TO COLLEGE AND WHAT THEY
HEARD BACK WAS THAT THEY NEED TO
WORK FULL TIME WAS SEEN AS IS
ONE OF THE MAJOR BARRIER THE
MAJOR BARRIER FOR ENROLLING IN
THAT COMMUNITY COLLEGES AS YOU
MENTIONED SENATOR MAN. AS A AS A
POSSIBILITY SO THAT'S- THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT- SOME DATA POINT
THAT THAT WE HAVE YEAH AND ALSO-
STUDENTS ARE PROSPECTIVE
STUDENTS THAT HAVE FAMILY
OBLIGATIONS THEY NEED TO STAY IN
WITH A CHANCE CAL CARES BECOME
DIFFICULT THERE'S OTHER ISSUES
SO THAT'S ABSOLUTELY- TRUE BUT
HAVING HAVING EVEN MORE
INFORMATION BETTER INFORMATION
OR DISTRICT LEVEL INFORMATION
WHICH WOULD ACTUALLY BE MORE
USEFUL THAN THAN WHAT WE HAVE
NOW. AND OF COURSE HERE MA'AM IS
NEVER AND I WANT TO GO TO YOU
AND ASK THAT YOU KNOW MAYBE YOU
CAN ELABORATE ON THE SURVEY THAT
MR SEEN HOUSING WAS REFERRING TO
AND DO YOU HAVE PLANS TO TRY TO
DIG DEEPER BECAUSE TO ME THIS.
YEAH YOU KNOW BEFORE WE YOU KNOW
DECIDE WHAT WE'RE BASICALLY
SHOOTING BLIND HERE AND IF WE
HAVE MORE DATA I SUSPECT I'LL BE
INCREDIBLY HELPFUL AS WE
DETERMINE WHAT'S APPROPRIATE YOU
KNOW MAYBE WE WILL SEE AN IRONIC
LAUGH MAYBE THAT'S JUST ON
AVOIDABLE MAYBE CALL AT THE IN
THE CALL BUT WE'RE NOT GONNA SEE
IS BIG A DIFFERENCE WE THOUGHT.
AYE I SITTING HERE I HAVE NO
SENSE OF WHAT IN ROOM IT'S GONNA
LOOK LIKE R. N. AND I WOULD
ASSUME YOU GUYS IN A BETTER
POSITION SO I GUESS THE QUESTION
HERE IS HAVE YOU DONE ANY YOU
CAN YOU CAN YOU ELABORATE A ANY
RESEARCH THAT YOU'VE DONE. AND
DO YOU HAVE PLANS TO DO ANY
FURTHER DEEPER. RESEARCH AND IF
NOT WHY NOT. YOU SEE MAN. OF ONE
OF. AND THE- SEARCH. THAT THE L.
A. L. SO WE DID- SURVEYED
RESPECT STUDENTS WE ALSO HAVE
PART. WHERE THEIR RESEARCH PLANE
GROUP TO UNDER. WHAT'S WHAT WE
ARE HEARING FROM STUDENTS IS
THAT. THEY ARE SEEKING IN ASKING
FOR GREATER FLEXIBILITY IN OUR
COURSES AND HYBRID. MUCH OF THIS
AGAIN RELATED TO THE NEED TO
WORK FOR NECESSITY AND WITH 61%
OF OUR STUDENTS AGAIN. WORKING A
SOLE PROVIDERS- AND FOR THEIR
FAMILIES. AND SO. DYNAMIC OF-
BEING ABLE TO. RE ENTER THE
WORKFORCE AND HIGHER WAGE
SPECIALLY FOR THOSE THAT MAY
HAVE LOST INCOME. DURING THE
PANDEMIC IS VERY APPEALING
ESPECIALLY FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS. WE ARE SEEING SOME
ENROLLMENT GAINS IN SOME AREAS
OF STATE ALL HIGHLIGHT ON THE-
H. SANTIAGO IS HAD- WHENEVER
DISTRICTS IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. HAS HAD SOME GAMES. THE LOOK
THE SECOND PIECE OF YOUR OF WHAT
DO WE OTHER. WE DO HAVE
CONTINUED TO SERVE FOLLOWINGS
CENSUS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
ALSO RELEASING GRANT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR US TO RESEARCH
THIS PHENOMENON THAT'S HAPPENING
NATIONWIDE WE WILL BE PARTNERING
WITH TO- RESEARCH ENTITIES. TO
HELP US BRING CAPACITY TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THIS ISSUE I'M SO WE
ARE VERY INTERESTED ON WE WANT
TO BRING BACK STUDENTS BUT WE
ALSO WANT TO ENSURE THAT OUR
COLLEGES ARE NOT LOSING
RESOURCES AS A RESULT OF THESE
DECLINES YEAH- AND SO I GUESS
I'LL CHANGE MY SECOND COMMENT.
THE CRITICAL QUESTION- SO. I'M
IT IS FROM IS NEVER ABOUT YOUR
THOUGHTS ON AND THE PROPER BLAND
GOING FORWARD. ONLINE HYBRID AND
IN PERSON. AND SO I JUST HAPPEN
TO HAVE THE EXPERIENCE RIGHT NOW
MY BABYSITTER IS LOOKING TO
ENROLL IN COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CLASSES. ARE AND SHE WAS NOT
ABLE TO FIND ANY IN PERSON I
THINK SHE FOUND ONE IN PERSON
CLASS NEARBY- AND SHE DOESN'T
WANT TO DO ONLINE AND SO SHE'S.
YOU KNOW REFRAINING FROM AND
ROLLING RIGHT NOW- BUT AT THE
SAME TIME YOU MENTION THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT AND PRESUMABLY
ONLINE AND HYBRID PROVIDE MORE
THAT SO. WHAT DO YOU THINK THE
RIGHT BLEND IS SORT OF WHAT I'M
AND OBVIOUSLY THIS IS GONNA BE
DIFFERENT DISTRICT BY DISTRICT
BASIS BUT- MOVING FORWARD. HOW
MUCH ONLINE VERSUS IN PERSON
VERSUS HYBRID YOU ANTICIPATE IT
WILL BE THE RIGHT MIX FOR YOUR-
DIFFERENT COLLEGES GOING FOR. I
BELIEVE YOU'RE RIGHT. HIGHLY THE
RATE MAKE IS REALLY GOING TO BE
DIFFERENT- FOR INDIVIDUAL
DISTRICTS BUT IT ALSO WILL BE
DIFFERENT. DEPENDING ON- THAT
PROGRAM OF STUDY. MANY OF OUR-
VAST MAJORITY OF OUR CAREER
EDUCATION PROGRAMS ARE FULLY IN
PERSON RIGHT NOW. THE RIGHT NEXT
FOR THOSE- GIVEN THE ON HANDS ON
. INSTRUCTION IS PROVIDED REALLY
IS IN THAT IN PERSON- AS PART OF
ON SOME OF THESE ANALYSIS WE
HEARD THAT- AROUND 27% OF
STUDENTS PREFERRED- FULLY
ONLINE. OTHERS WANTED A BLANK
TODAY WHAT WHAT WE'VE HEARD ALSO
WAS A BIG ONE IN PERSON STUDENTS
SUPPORTS WHICH COLLEGES ARE-
INCREASINGLY OFFERING- AND
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE WHETHER IT'S
COUNSELING- FOOD BANKS ARE SO
WOULD REALLY WHAT WE'RE SEEING
IS JUST A DYNAMIC SHIFT IN HOW
STUDENTS. WANT THEIR EDUCATION
IT'S GOING TO BE CRITICAL FOR
COLLEGES TO CONTINUALLY- SURVEY
BOCA'S SCRIPT OR STUDENTS SO
THAT THEY CAN ADOPT- HE WILL
NEED TO BE FLEXIBLE. AND SUPPORT
THEM DURING THESE TIMES. THANK
YOU AND I WOULD ASSESS MYSELF
WITH THE COMMENTS OF GERMAN
LAYERED AYE AYE AYE. I STILL AM
NOT CLEAR ON ON WHAT THE RIGHT
ENROLLMENT STRATEGY IS AND I
KNOW WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT THIS
IF. OUR SKIFF OR WHATEVER HAVE
YOU PRONOUNCE THAT SOON- BUT- I
IF YOU KNOW I DO FEEL LIKE WERE
ADDED TO REFER TO MY EARLIER
COMMENT WHAT WORK WE'RE SHOOTING
DARTS. WE DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT
DIRECTION WE'RE SUPPOSED TO
THROW THEM IN AT THIS POINT
BECAUSE- THERE'S JUST SUCH A-
I'M A MIX A MYRIAD OF FACTORS AS
WE SAID. ON WHAT COULD BE
CAUSING THIS AND ROMAN DECLINE
IS VERY HARD FOR ME SITTING
HERE. TO FIGURE OUT. WHAT THE
RIGHT ENROLLMENT STRATEGIES ARE
GONNA BE GOING FORWARD BECAUSE
IT IT DOES STRIKE ME THAT THAT
WE MAY BE SEEING. A DECLINE OVER
THE LONG RUN IN ENROLLMENT IN
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
THAT'S SOMETHING WE MAY HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT ADDRESSING. AND
IDEALLY PROACTIVELY RATHER THAN
RETROACTIVELY BUT- MAYBE I'M
WRONG BUT I THINK IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL HERE. THANK YOU CENTER
BERMAN. AN OF THAT COMPLETES OUR
DISCUSSION OF ISSUE ONE AND
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO ISSUE
NUMBER TWO WHICH WE HAVE TALKED
IN PART ABOUT ALREADY SO- IT'S
THE PORTION MEN'S INCREASE ARM
AND THE PANELS EXACTLY THE SAME
AS ISSUE ONE AND SO WHAT- LET'S
GO IN THE SAME ORDER AND LET'S-
BEGIN WITH DAN HOW'RE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF. HANAUER OF THE
DEPART OF FINDING. AT DINNER TO
PREVENT A FINANCE THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES THE STATUTORY
STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT OF
FIVE POINT 33% WHICH TRANSLATES
TO FOUR HUNDRED NINE POINT FOUR
MILLION ONGOING PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND.
FURTHER THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES FUNDING FOR POINT 5%
ENROLLMENT GROWTH COMING TO
TWENTY FOUR POINT NINE MILLION-
THIS IS REALLY MORE OF A
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT AND
PROVIDES FUNDING WHICH CAN BE
USED BY DISTRICTS THAT HAPPEN TO
BE GROWING AND ANY UNUSED GROWTH
FUNDING IS POTENTIALLY BE ABLE
TO COVER INCREASES TO A
DISTRICTS SUPPLEMENTAL OR
SUCCESS ALLOCATIONS. WITHOUT A
MAP YOU TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE ABOUT THE SUBSTANCE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW WILL
MOVE TO THE LA- THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN WHERE'D- YES DODD-
COMMITTEE JUST TALKED ABOUT THE
ENROLLMENT GROWTH ISSUE THE LAST
DAM IN IN IN THE GENDER ISSUE
ONE SO I'LL FOCUS ON THE COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT PROPOSAL AS
YOUR AGENDA NOTES THE COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT RATE FOR
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE IS LIKELY
TO BE HIGHER. THAN WHAT THE
GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING- THE FIVE
POINT 33% OUR OFFICE ESTIMATES
THAT THE CALL RATE IS GOING TO
BE MORE LIKE SIX POINT 2% OF FOR
NEXT YEAR I WHICH WOULD COST
ABOUT SIXTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
MORE THAN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
IS PROPOSING. THAT DISTRICTS ARE
FACING A NUMBER OF COST
PRESSURES IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE FIRST YOU HAVE EMPLOYEES
THEIR OWN COST OF LIVING HAS
GONE UP SO THERE IS PRESSURE ON
DISTRICTS PROVIDE SALARY
INCREASES FOR EMPLOYEES
DISTRICTS ALSO HAVE. REQUIRED
CONTRIBUTIONS TO CALPERS AND CAL
STARS AND THAT AMOUNT IS GOING
TO GO UP IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE BY ABOUT A HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN TOTAL AND
DISTRICTS ARE ALSO FACING COST
PRESSURES- RELATED TO THE COMING
EXPIRATION OF THE FEDERAL RELIEF
FUNDS THAT DISTRICTS ARE ALSO
REALIZING SOME SAVINGS AND THE
CURRENT YEAR BECAUSE THEY DON'T
NEED AS MANY PART IME FACULTY I
DO TO LOWER. COURSE DEMANDS AND
IF THAT TREND CONTINUES NEXT
YEAR DISTRICTS WILL CONTINUE TO
SEE SAVINGS BUT THAT SAVINGS
LIKELY WILL NOT BE ENOUGH TO
OFFSET THE UPWARD PRESSURE ON
THE TOTAL COMPENSATION COSTS FOR
TWO TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE THAT
I JUST MENTIONED SO WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE MAKE A DECISION
ON A COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT
RATE ONCE A LEGISLATURE GETS
UPDATED DATA FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. WHICH IS USED TO
CALCULATE THE COLA RATE AND SO
LEGISLATURE GET THAT BY APRIL
AND IN TIME TO MAKE A DECISION
BY. MAY ON WHAT THAT REFRACT RAY
IT WILL BE- LOOKING IS WELL AS
WHAT NINETY EIGHT NET NEW GEAR
LOW LIKE A REVENUE EXPECTATIONS
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AN HOUR
MOVE TO THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. DETERMINE
LAYERED I JUST WANT TO REITERATE
SOME OF HE POINTS SHARED BY MY
COLLEAGUE AT THE ALLEY-
DISTRICTS ARE FACING INCREASING
COST PRESSURES SUCH AS THOSE OF
PENSION COSTS OF OPERATING- AND-
DOES NEEDED TO ADDRESS
INFLATIONARY COSTS. ALSO
HIGHLIGHT ON A RECENT ECONOMIC
IMPACT REPORT THAT WE RELEASED
THAT SHOWS THAT FOR EVERY DOLLAR
SPENT ON EDUCATING STUDENTS WHO
ATTEND COMMITTEE COLLEGES THE
PUBLIC'S RECEIVES TWO POINT TWO
DOLLARS AND TEN CENTS IN RETURN-
AND WE HAVE AN ECONOMIC IMPACT-
OF ONE HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY I SHARE
THESE JUST TO HIGHLIGHT. THAT
CONTINUED INVESTMENT IN
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IS A WORTHY
ONE AND WE PROVIDE IN OUR
CENTRAL CONTRIBUTORS TO
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY AND WITH THAT
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU OUR WORK ME ASK OF. A
MAKE A COMMENT NASCO QUESTION OF
FINANCE AND THAT IS I WAS GOING
TO ASK IS A QUESTION. A NEW
ISSUE WE DO THINK THE FIVE POINT
33% THAT'S. THE RECOMMENDED COLA
- HOW IT TRACKS WITH COSTA NEXT
. THAT ARE MORE AND YOU ADDRESS
THAT INTERCOM SO. GIVEN THE L.
A. O.'S COMMENT ABOUT- PROBABLY
THE- THE TRUING UP OF ACTUAL
REVENUES OUT OF IN THE SPRING
WOULD PROBABLY TO A HIGHER COLA
I WAS JUST GONNA S. FINANCE TO
EXPECT YOU TO DO THAT TRUING UP
AND IT COME TO US WITH AN UP TO
DATE NUMBER IN MAY. I'VE BEEN IN
OUR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
YESTERDAY TYPICALLY BE WE-
REVISIT THE COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT WHEN IT COMES TO
THEIR MAY REVISION- AND
TYPICALLY REVISED THAT NUMBER
BASED ON ON ON THE UPDATED
STATUTORY COLLECTOR SAYING. KAY
AND THEN THE OTHER QUESTION I
HAVE FOR YOU- AND IT MAY BE
TRICKY FOR YOU- ED THAT IS- WHEN
THE GOVERNOR ANNOUNCED THE
SURPLUS. BOB IN NOVEMBER WERE
RIVER WAS- HE SAID THAT- OF BY
DOWN AND CAL. CALPERS AND CAL
STIRS WAS GOING TO BE IS NUMBER
ONE PRIORITY AND THEN IT'S NOT
IN THE BUDGET ANYWHERE. IN SO I
WAS JUST GONNA ASK YOU IS. IS A
ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL DISTRICTS.
ARE ON CALPERS AND CAL STIRS
SOMETHING THAT'S ON THE TABLE.
ARE HEADING TOWARD MASS. AND AS
YOU KNOW THERE THERE IS THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES NOT
CONTAIN A SPECIFIC PROPOSAL THE
PROPOSAL RELATED TO CALPERS
MCALISTER'S- IN TERMS OF WHAT
CONVERSATIONS ARE ONGOING AND
I'D HAVE TO DEFER TO MY
COLLEAGUE THAT FINANCE TO COVER
THOSE ISSUES MORE SPECIFICALLY.
TO ONE OKAY OUR CONVERSATIONS
ARE ON GOING IS THE EUPHEMISM
WE'VE BEEN GETTING SO I
APPRECIATE THAT BUT IT'S- WE
HOPE THERE'S AN ONGOING
CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT. US
SENATOR MEN DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS ON THE SIDE OF. OUR HE
DOES NOT- SO THANK THAT PANEL.
WHO IS NOW GOING TO RETURNED IN
THE EXACT SAME FORM. OF FOR
ISSUE NUMBER THREE THE STUDENT
CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA- WHICH
THE ACRONYM FOR WHICH IS SKIFT
WHICH PEOPLE USE DURING THIS SO
FOR THOSE OF YOU FOLLOWING AT
HOME THAT MEANS STUDENT CENTERED
FUNDING FORMULA- OUR PANELISTS
MISSED. OUR OVERVIEW VIEW
HEARING OF ONE K. TO TWELVE
FUNDING WHERE THERE WAS A
WARRANT ACRONYMS IN THIS HEARING
AND- FROM. AND A- CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION PLOY HE
BROKE THE RECORD BY HAVING FOR
UNDEFINED ACRONYMS IN ONE
SENTENCE AND SO- JUST CAUTION
YOU TO BE CAREFUL BECAUSE I
MIGHT INTERRUPT AND ASK YOU TO.
TO DEFINE AN ACRONYM IF YOU VEER
OFF THE TRACKS IT IN THAT
DIRECTION. SO LET'S BEGIN THE
DISCUSSION ON THE STUDENT
CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA- AND
WE'LL GO ON THE SAME ORDER WITH
THE SAME PEOPLE START WITH DAN
HANNAH WERE FROM. THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. IN THERE ARE IF I
AND WILL TRY THE WARY OF MY- YOU
- DOES I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
ADMIN. ONGOING CAN TO THIS
CENTER FUNDING FORMULA OR SCIFI
. EVEN THOUGH THE VOLATILE
PHYSICAL CONDITIONS POSED BY THE
LAST FEW YEARS THE FORMULA HAS
PROVED RESILIENT IN A STABLE
SOURCE OF FUNDING FOR THE
COLLEGES- DIMINISHES. FOCUSED ON
MOVING TOWARDS FULL
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE FUNDING
FORMULA. AS SUCH THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSED A GRADUAL PHASE
OUT OF THE HOLD HARMLESS
PROVISION OF THE STUDENT
CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA.
EXISTING HOLD HARMLESS ROVISION
IS SLATED TO EXPIRE AFTER TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE.
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES TO
CREATE A FUNDING FLOOR USING
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
FUNDING LEVELS. ALLOWING FUNDING
RATES TO CONTINUE TO INCREASE BY
THE STATUTORY COST OF LVING
ADJUSTMENT. BUT REMOVING THE
APPLICATION OF THAT COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT TO THE HOLD
HARMLESS PROVISION BEGINNING IN
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX.
OBJECTIVELY THIS APPROACH ALLOWS
DISTRICTS TO TRANSITION TO THE
CORE FUNDING FORMULA OVER TIME.
WHILE PREVENTING PHYSICAL
DECLINES BETWEEN TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE AND TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX. THE
PAGES OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
ALSO SIGNAL INTEREST IN THE
ADMINISTRATION TO INCLUDE FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS. WITHIN THE
SUPPLEMENTAL ALLOCATION OF THE
STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULA. IN LINE WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION MADE BY THE
STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE. ONCE A
RELIABLE AND STABLE DATA SOURCE
IS AVAILABLE. WITH THAT I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE ABOUT THESE
PROPOSALS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
WILL MOVE TO THE LA AREA. STILL
IN ISSUE ONE. WE ARE THIS THIS
COMMITTEE HEARD THE DISCUSSION
ABOUT. ABOUT FORTY DISTRICTS
THAT ARE KIND OF PROPPED UP WITH
THEIR FUNDING DURING THE
PANDEMIC BECAUSE OF EMERGENCY
CONDITIONS ALLOWANCE WELL
THERE'S ANOTHER GROUP OF
DISTRICTS ABOUT TWENTY DISTRICTS
THAT RECEIVE FUNDING UNDER A
HOLD HARMLESS PROVISION IN THIS
IS A PROVISION THAT WAS ENACTED
WHEN THE STATE MOVED TO THE NEW
FUNDING FORMULA IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND THAT MONEY
IS WAS WAS INTENDED FOR THOSE
DISTRICTS THAT. GOTTEN THE WOULD
HAVE GENERATED LESS UNDER THE
NEW FORMULA FORMULA IN THE OLD
FUNDING FORMULA SO DISTRICTS
LIKE REAL COLLEGE WHICH CHAIR
GERMAN LEARN I KNOW YOU KNOW- A
GREAT DEAL ABOUT SO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL HERE IS
INTENDED TO PREVENT- MANY
DISTRICTS THOSE HOLD HARMLESS
DISTRICTS FROM HITTING A FISCAL
CLIFF IN A FEW YEARS WHEN THE
STATE'S CURRENT HOLD HARMLESS
PROVISION IS SCHEDULED TO END.
AND DISTRICTS ARE FUNDED BASED
ON WHAT THEY GENERATE THROUGH
THE STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULA SO INSTEAD OF HAVING TO
SIGNIFICANTLY CUT THEIR BUDGETS
BY TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX UNDER
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OF THOSE
DISTRICTS APPORTIONMENT FUNDING
AMOUNT WOULD BE CAPPED AT THEIR
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE LEVEL.
NOW BECAUSE UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THE WHOLE TOM HARMLESS
FUNNY LEVEL WOULD NOT RECEIVE
ANY SUBSEQUENT COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENTS BUT THE RATES UNDER
THE STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULA WOULD RECEIVE COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENTS THE INTENSE
BY THE GOVERNOR IS THAT OVER
TIME THIS STUDENT CENTERED
FUNDING FORMULA WOULD GENERATE
MORE MONEY FOR THOSE DISTRICTS
THE SO CALLED HOLD HARMLESS
DISTRICTS SUCH SAID EVENTUALLY.
THERE ARE- THEY WOULD BE RISK
MORE MONEY UNDER AS THAT THEM
HOLD HARMLESS AMOUNT AND THEY
WOULD BE ON THE FORMULA FINALLY
SO TO SPEAK. SO WE THINK THE
GOVERNOR'S GOAL OF PREVENTING A
FISCAL CLIFF IS LAUDABLE. AT THE
SAME TIME BEING A DISTRICT THAT
RECEIVES HOLD HARMLESS FUNDING
MEANS THAT THEY'RE RECEIVING
MONEY FROM THE STATE REGARDLESS
OF HOW MANY STUDENTS THEY SERVE
THE TYPE OF STUDENTS THEY SERVE.
OR THE OUTCOME OF THOSE STUDENTS
AS SUCH. BEING FUNDED ON HOLD
HARMLESS GETTING MONEY. NO
MATTER WHAT BASED ON MONEY THAT
THEY GOT IN THE IN THE PRIOR
FORMULA. IT DOES CREATE POOR
INCENTIVES FOR DISTRICTS AND THE
STATE REALLY SHOULD STRIVE TO
GET DISTRICTS OFF HOLD HARMLESS
AND FUNDED BY THE FORMULA. AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE. ONE WAY TO DO
THAT IS TO INCREASE THE VALUE OF
THE CURRENT OF PORTION OF
FUNDING FORMULA. YOU COULD DO
THAT BY INCREASING THE BASE
PROVIDING MORE FUNDING FOR THE
BASIN THIS NUMBER MENTIONED
THAT. EARLIER YOU COULD INCREASE
IT BEYOND THE COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENTS THAT WAS SO WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED THE GOVERNOR'S SCHOOL
HARMLESS PROPOSAL THE ONE THAT.
MISTER HOWARD JUST MENTIONED BUT
NO FURTHER BY BEGINNING TO
EXPLORE THE POSSIBILITY OF
RAISING BASE RATES FOR THE
STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULA. THE LEGISLATURE COULD
SET A TARGET LEVEL OF BASE
FUNDING THAT WOULD LIKE TO SEE
GIVEN. EXPECTED GROWTH IN THE
PROPOSITION. NINETY EIGHT.
GUARANTEE AN END OF A MULTI YOU
PLAN FOR DO YOU REACH THOSE OF
FUNDING TARGETS. NOW AND A
HUNDRED HIGHER BASE ALSO HAS THE
ADVANTAGE OF HELPING DISTRICTS
ADDRESS THEIR OPERATING COSTS
WHICH OF. THE SUN COMMITTEE-
HEARD AND THE PRIOR ITS AGENDA
ITEM. SO ONE OTHER NO ALL
MENTION US IN THE AGENDA- WE DO
AGREE WITH THE GOVERNOR THAT
ADDING A FIRST GENERATION
METRIC. TO THE FOR A STUDENT
CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA HAS
MERIT ONCE THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE DOES START TO RECEIVE
MORE CONSISTENT RELIABLE DATA
FROM COLLEGES SO IT'S SOMETHING
A MOVE TOWARD- IN THE NEXT FEW
YEARS. BOB EARLIER- THIS
COMMITTEE TALKED ABOUT THE
EMERGENCY CONDITIONS ALLOW IT SO
WE ARE JUST RECOMMENDED ARE
ANALYSIS THE LEGISLATURE GREAT
GAIN CLARITY ABOUT WHAT EXACTLY
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IS GOING
TO USE WHAT CRITERIA IS GONNA
USE IN DETERMINING WHETHER TO
EXTEND THE EMERGENCY CONDITIONS
ALLOWANCE. FOR ANOTHER YEAR OR
SOMETHING YOU YOU HEARD A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT- PREVIOUSLY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CHAU WILL MOVE TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
LAYERED THE GOVERNOR AGAIN
HIGHLIGHTS ITS COMMITMENT FOR
THE STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULA PROPOSES MINIMUM FUNDING
LEVEL FOR ALL DISTRICTS. THEY
DON'T. HAVE THAT DROP THAT- HOST
SPECIFIED PREVIOUSLY. ASSUMED
CENTER FUNDING FORMULA IS A KEY
PART OF SOLUTIONS TO AN
EQUITABLE RECOVERY. AS YOU KNOW
PRIOR TO THE SCF FAST. DISTRICTS
WORK FUNDED ALMOST ENTIRELY BY
ENROLLMENT AND WHAT WE'VE
LEARNED IS THAT THAT APPROACH
TO. IT DOESN'T WORK TO ADVANCE
THE STUDENTS FULL EDUCATIONAL
JOURNEY BEYOND THEIR INITIAL
ENROLLMENT. AND IT WOULD NOT
WORK FOR DISTRICTS IN THE MIST
OF DEMOGRAPHIC SHIFTS ACROSS THE
STATE AND THEY WOULD HAVE SEEN
ENROLLMENT DECLINES AND AS A
RESULT- UNDIES AND ROMINGER
DECLINED AGAIN WERE EXPERIENCED
EVEN BEFORE THE PANDEMIC. AS A
RESULT WOULD HAVE LOST MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS. EVEN BEFORE. THE
IMPLIED CLASS THIS INCIDENT
FORMING FUNDING FORMULA
RECOGNIZES THAT COLLEGES- TO
WORK ENCOMPASSES MORE. AND THAT
THEIR EFFORTS AROUND CRITICAL
ACADEMIC AND STUDENT SUPPORTS
ARE IMPORTANT. AS WE SUPPORT.
PULLED CENTRAL FOUR TWENTY IS A
CLIFF DISTRICT. THIS CHANGE. TO
CALL WITH THE STATE. AS WORKED
REGAIN CAL. FURTHER THE DRIVING
OF SCF MATURE. EQUITY AND SIX
ARE MORE RELEVANT THAN EVER AND
REMIND US THAT OUR STUDENTS
NIECE NEEDS COME FIRST. EARLY
INDICATORS- SHOW THAT UNDER THE
SCF FIVE STATEWIDE SUCCEEDED
REFER CAN'T TRANSFER COMPLETIONS
I LOW INCOME STUDENTS HAVE IT
INCREASED BY ROUGHLY THIRTY FIVE
PERCENT. THERE'S BEEN A 69%
INCREASE IN COMPLETIONS OR
TRANSFER LEVEL ENGLISH AND MATH
IN THE FIRST YEAR AND FOR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS THEY'VE SEEN
EVEN LARGER GAINS WITH. 89%
INCREASE FOR PELL GRANT
RECIPIENTS AND 90% INCREASES FOR
PROMISE GRANT RECIPIENTS.
STATEWIDE INCREASES AND REGIONAL
LIVING WAGE FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS ARE NEARLY TWENTY
PERCENT. SO AGAIN WE BELIEVE
THAT WE ARE FOCUSING ON THE
RIGHT- AREAS THAT ARE COLLEGES
ARE WORKING HARD TO KEEP.
STUDENTS NEED THAT BEFORE. THANK
YOU HAVE A CHANCE. THANK YOU ARE
WE'RE GONNA TO QUESTIONS THE END
OF. THE L. A. O. ANSWERED MY
FIRST QUESTION WHICH WAS HOW
MANY COLLEGE DISTRICTS ARE IN
HOLD HARMLESS. AND- DANCER WHO
WAS TWENTY ARE THERE ARE SOME
LARGE DISTRICTS THAT ARE IN
THERE I'VE HEARD ANECDOTALLY
ABOUT A FEW. DOES ANYBODY KNOW
THE ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION.
SENATOR LAYERED LAWCENTER AT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE THERE ARE-
SOME LARGER DISTRICTS WHICH
INTEREST OFFICE HAS PRODUCED A
DASHBOARD WHICH SHOWS REAL TIME
DATA AND WORK ON DISTRICTS ARE
I'M HAPPY TO SHARE THAT- WE
PROVIDED A LINK- DURING THE PRE
HEARING AROUND. THIS
INFORMATION- THAT SHOWS THAT
STORY COULD YOU TELL US MAYBE
TWO OR THREE LARGE DISTRICTS NOW
WITHOUT US HAVING TO GO TO THE
DASHBOARD WERE INTENSELY THAT'S
LISTENING IN- WE SHOW SIX OF SAN
- WE SHOW- SHOULD WELL LAST
PROCEED S. AS TWO EXAMPLES. OKAY
THANK AND LOS ANGELES IS NOT IN
THERE. LOS ANGELES IS IN THERE
IT IS IN THEIR- COURT OKAY
BECAUSE THAT'S A FAIRLY LARGE
DISTRICT I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE. OF THE LA- HAS HIS HAND.
YES SORRY I RECALL SAN DIEGO ME
BECAUSE DISTRICT IS A HOLD
HARMLESS DISTRICTS. LOS ANGELES
. WE'LL HAVE TO SEE WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE TO SEE WHEN THE
CHANCE OFFICE RELEASES- ARE
UPDATED INFORMATION ON FUNDING
FOR THE CURRENT YEAR I DID
NOTICE THAT- LOS ANGELES WAS
UNDER A HOLD HARMLESS AS OF JUNE
OF LAST YEAR BUT IT'S POSSIBLE
THAT THAT CHANGED- SO JUST JUST
WANT TO MENTION THAT THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT. LEGISLATURE
WON'T KNOW FOR ANOTHER COUPLE
WEEKS I DID JUST WANT TO MENTION
AS WELL BACK TO- YOU TEND TO SEE
A ONE TENDS TO SEE MORE HOLD
HARMLESS DISTRICTS AND COASTAL
AREAS OF THE STATE THE BAY AREA
AREAS OF THE STATE THAT HAVE
EWER STUDENTS ARE DEFINED AS
LOW INCOME DEFINED AS LOW INCOME
BY THAT STUDENT CENTERED FORM
FUNDING FORMULA AND STATUTES AND
SO. EVERY COLLEGES IN EXAMPLE
ONE THE SANTA CRUZ AREA SO
COASTAL CALIFORNIA BEARING I
THINK YOU'D SEE HAS A
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF THOSE
HARMS DISCUSS ANY YES AND WHAT I
WAS TRYING TO GET AT ALSO IS
THAT WALLETS TWENTY DISTRICTS IN
UNDER 20% OF THE TOTAL DISTRICTS
IT WAS MY SUSPICION IT'S A MUCH
HIGHER NUMBER OF THE TOTAL
STUDENT BODY. OF THE STATE
BECAUSE OF THE LARGE DISTRICTS
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS I WAS
DRIVING. AND UNFORTUNATELY. A
MOST OF THE COMMUNITY KERR TO IN
MY DISTRICT IN COURT HARMLESS
AND I AM INTIMATE FAMILIAR WITH
THEIR VIEWS ON THE MATTER AND- I
SUSPECT WOULD. WHEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SAID IN
THE OPENING STATEMENT THAT THE
FORMULA REMAINS RESILIENT THEY
HAVE A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
DEFINITION OF WHAT RESILIENCE
MEANS IN RELATION TO THE
FORMULA. SO THE- V. A. N. IT'S
INTERESTING BECAUSE THE
DISTRICTS YOU MENTIONED ARE THE
ONES WHERE THERE'S A- A RATHER
HIGHER STANDARD OF LIVING AND I
KNOW EVEN THE SENATE OFFERS A- A
PAY DIFFERENTIAL. FOLLOWED TO
POISON HARDTO FIT IN HIGH
INCOME AREAS WHERE IT'S HARD TO
FIND HOUSING. IN THAT THERE WAS
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE WAS CHARGED
WITH WALKING AT. WAS WHETHER OR
NOT. FROM THERE SHOULD BE
ADJUSTMENTS FOR DIFFERENCES IN
REGIONAL COST OF LIVING AND I
NOTICED THERE'S NO
RECOMMENDATION HERE ABOUT THAT.
WHY IS THAT THE CASE AND I DON'T
KNOW WHO CAN TAKE THAT QUESTION
. MAYBE THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. DINNERWARE
AND IT'S- IT IS OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE I DID NOT- LAND DATA
AND SCHOOL RECOMMENDATION AROUND
THE REGIONAL COST OF LIVING
ISSUE AND SO NOTHING WAS PUT
FORWARD SHE THE ADMINISTRATION
OF THE LEGISLATURE- THAT
SPECIFIED HOW ARE THAT COULD BE
CONSIDERED- THERE WERE HOWEVER
RECOMMENDATIONS AROUND A FIRST
GENERATION- WHICH COULD HELP
MIDDLEMAN ASK ABOUT THE FIRST
GENERATION UNLESS YOU'RE DRAWING
A CONCLUSION. IN RELATION TO MY
QUESTION. HI MY JUST THE
CONCLUDE- WOULD BE THAT ONE
OPTION AGAIN IS TO CONSIDER
FIRST GENERATION BECAUSE THAT
COULD ALSO BECOME THIS-
INDIVIDUALS IN SOME OF THOSE
DISTRICTS THAT YOU HIGHLIGHTED
I'M GOING TO ASK ABOUT THAT IN A
MOMENT BUT- THE- OHIO. IS RATHER
FLIGHTY WITH HIS RAISED HANDS IT
WAS UP IN ITS DOWN SO I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU HAD ANYTHING THAT
YOU WANTED TO ADD TO THAT. IT'S
NOT YOU WELL YEAH I JUST TO MAKE
THE POINT DONE. IN VERY WHAT IS
THAT NUMBER IT SAID IS THAT THE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE. LOOKED AT
THE- THE- IDEA OF. MAKING
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE SCF AFTER
REFLECT HIGHER COST OF LIVING-
AREAS OF THE STATE AND
ULTIMATELY DID NOT. AGREE AND
DID NOT HAVE A RECOMMENDATION SO
THAT WAS NOT SOMETHING THAT THEY
HAD. RECOMMENDED FOR- ME JUST
MAKE A COMMENT I THINK THAT'S
UNFORTUNATE AND WE SHOULD NOT
LET GO OF THE ISSUE. BECAUSE
WE'VE GOT THE SITUATION. WHERE
THE HOLD HARMLESS AGREEMENT IS
CUTTING SUBSTANTIALLY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS IN HIGH INCOME AREAS.
AND SO THEY GET A DOUBLE WHAMMY.
ARE THEY CAN'T HIRE PEOPLE
BECAUSE OF THE HIGH INTEREST AND
THEY'RE GOING TO BE CUT
SUBSTANTIALLY SO. SOMEBODY NEEDS
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AND-
BECAUSE THEY DEADLOCKED IS NOT
AN ADEQUATE RESPONSE WHEN WE GO
OUT TO THESE DISTRICTS AND SAY
WE'RE NOT ADDRESSING THE. ISSUE
SO I HOPE THAT SOMEHOW. ASSEMBLY
CAN FIGURE OUT A WAY FOR US TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE THEN ON THE
RECOMMENDATION. ON THE METRIC OF
THE FIRST GENERATION- A STUDENT
WHICH IS IN HERE. ARM ON THE
POLICY LEVEL OF COURSE IT MAKES
TOTAL SENSE BUT I CAN'T TELL
ANYWHERE IN HERE WHAT THE IMPACT
IS TO INDIVIDUAL DISTRICTS DO WE
KNOW IF IT'S ADDED WHAT THAT
DOES TO INDIVIDUAL. DISTRICTS ON
THE FORMULA. I WOULD START WITH
THE OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE BUT WE CAN
GO ANYWHERE ON THIS. THE NEW
LAYERED- CURRENTLY THERE. THE
DEFINITION FOR FIRST GENERATION
THAT WAS RECOMMENDED BY THE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE WAS NOT ONE
THAT- COMMUNITY COLLEGES
REPORTED WERE COLLECTED THAT
CHANGE WAS MADE TWO YEARS AGO
AND SO WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO
COLLECT THAT INFORMATION TO HAVE
CONSISTENCY. ANY METRICS TIED TO
FUNDINGGENERALLY HAVE MULTI
YEARS THAT WE CAN REFERENCE HER
ALSO AUDITED NUMBERS SO THAT WE
CAN PROVIDE ACCOUNTABILITY
NEITHER OF THOSE ELEMENTS EXIST
RIGHT NOW WE DON'T HAVE
CONSISTENT DATA AND THEREFORE-
WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THAT
IMPACT WOULD BE ON INDIVIDUAL
DISTRICTS BROUGHT ME JUST SAY
THAT'S A MATTER OF GREAT CONCERN
BECAUSE WE'RE SITTING HERE
FIDDLING WITH THE IMPACTS OF THE
LAST FORMULA. WHICH HAD STRONG
IMPACTS ON DIFFERENT DISTRICTS
AND NOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
CHANGE IN THE FORMULA WITH NO
IDEA HOW IT IMPACTS THE
DISTRICT'S EVEN ON A POLICY
LEVEL WE ALL THINK THA MAKES
GREAT SENSE AS A METRIC AND SO I
THINK. I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A
COMFORT LEVEL THAT WE'RE NOT
GONNA HAVE A GROUP OF ANGRY
DISTRICTS COMING BACK TO US NEXT
YEAR BECAUSE THEY ALL SAY WE
DIDN'T SEE THIS COMING SO-
THERE'S GOTTA BE A WAY TO FIGURE
THAT OUT AND I THINK. IT IN
GEERAL ON THIS AND YES I
REPRESENTS. A LOT OF DISTRICTS
THAT ARE. THAT ARE SUBJECT TO
THE HOLD HARMLESS AND I THINK
THERE'S THESE LARGER ISSUES SAN
JUAN AND I APOLOGIZE FOR
TELLING- THIS STORY OVER AND
OVER AGAIN HOME BUT IT RELATES
IN SOME WAYS IT TO THE THERE'S
ALL THE SENATE ONCE AGAIN THIS
IS TIED TO FOUR OTHER ITEMS SUCH
AS DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND SOME
OF AND HOUSING AND SOME OF THE
OTHER ITEMS THAT WE ARE STILL
GOING TO CONTINUE. TO COST LATER
IN THE END OF. AND OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. HAVE OF THE DOOR GOALS
OF FLY LEARNING AND TRANSFER
BILL. WHICH IS REALLY THE CENTER
OF THE OF THE STUDENT CENTERED
FUNDING FORMULA IN MANY WAYS AND
BY TAKING AWAY REPEATABILITY.
HAND SORT OF WEAKENING THE
LIFELONG LEARNING PART OF THE
DEAL WILL GOALS. THE LOCAL
SUPPORT FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
IS DROPPED SO I WAS THE CO CHAIR%
OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN THIRTY YEARS FOR A BOND
MEASURE. AND WHEN WE WENT IN THE
LAST YEAR REQUIRED TWO THIRDS
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT WE GOT 74%
OF THE VOTE. AND ONCE
REPEATABILITY WAS TAKEN AWAY AND
LOCAL SUPPORT STARTED TO A TOLD
LANE FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TWICE THEY COULD NOT GET 55% AND
YEP WHEN WE GO FURTHER IN THIS
AGENDA ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE SAID TO
BE CONSIDERED DIFFERENTLY THAN
YOU SEE AND CSU. IS THE LOCAL
ABILITY TO GO TO TAXES WHICH HAS
BEEN WEAKENED BY THE CHANGE IN
THE OVERALL WAY WE LOOK AT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AND THE
TIRED STORY I KEEP TELLING THEY
SET IN THAT BALLOT MEASURE. WAS
A STE A CENTER IN WATSONVILLE
THAT WAS EIGHT MILES FROM THE
CAMPUS BUT WE KNOW ARM ROMAN
WENT UP DRAMATICALLY FROM
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS AT ONE
TRAVEL EIGHT MILES TO THE CAMPUS
BECAUSE WE DID THAT CENTER. AND
IF THERE IS A- A COMPACTION
BECAUSE OF THE STUDENT CENTERED
FUNDING FORMULA AND NO HOLD
HARMLESS. THAT'S LIKELY ONE OF
THE THINGS TO GO BECAUSE YOUR
CORE CAMPUSES WHAT'S GOING TO BE
PROTECTED. AND THE
COUNTERINTUITIVE THING ABOUT
THIS. SAN THE FORMULA ON
STUDENTS IN A WAR MANY OF WHOM
ARE DISADVANTAGED WHAT WILL HAVE
A- A COUNTERINTUITIVE OUTCOME
AND SO- THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS I'VE NOT BEEN A TOTAL
FAN. AND I HAVE TO SUBSCRIBE TO
SOME OF THE COMMENTS THAT THE L.
A. O. MADE. IN THE SENSE THAT
THIS CREATES. A PERMANENT FLOOR
THAT REMOVES INCENTIVES AND I
THINK IT IS GREAT TO HAVE THE
HOLD HARMLESS EXTENDED IN SOME
FORM. BUT IT WOULD BE NICE TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY IF THE BASE
ACUALLY TRULY HOLD PEOPLE
HARMLESS AT THEIR EXISTING LEVEL
AND REWARDS AT A HIGHER LEVEL
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE DOING WELL
ON THE STUDENT CENTERED. FUNDING
FORMULA THAT CRUDE DOESN'T
CREATE WINNERS AND LOSERS THAT
CREATES WINNERS AND WINNERS SO
THE QUESTION IS. IS IN OUR
DISCUSSION OF THIS GOING FORWARD
AND OF COURSE IF WE APPROVE THE
HOLD HARMLESS. AS PROPOSED BY
THE GOVERNOR WE STRIVE FOR YEAR
TWO TWO ADJUSTED BUT I HATE KEEP
KICKING THE CAN DOWN THE ROAD I
THINK IT IS REALLY ABOUT.
FINDING SOME SWEET SPOT OF THAT
DOES THIS AND FACTORING IN THE
REGIONAL COST OF LIVING. IS
SEEMS TO BE ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT ACTUALLY IS AN ISSUE WITH A
SOME OF THE VERY DISTRICTS THAT
WERE NAMED AS BEING IN THE HOLD
HARMLESS. AND I KNOW WE HAD THIS
PROBLEM WHEN I WAS A COULD BRIO
AND I'VE. NOT BEEN ON THE BOARD
IN TWENTY YEARS. WHERE WE WERE
HAVE TROUBLE. RECRUITING FACULTY
BECAUSE OF THE COST OF LIVING
AND SO EVERY TIME WE HAD A NEW
FULL TIME FACULTY MEMBER
ANNOUNCED UC SANTA CRUZ. WE
SEARCH TO SEE IF THEY HAD A
SPOUSE WAS GOING TO BE LOOKING
FOR A JOB TO TRY TO RECRUIT THEM
INTO THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE AS A
WAY TO GET AROUND THE HOUSING-ISSUE. AND SO I AM JUST HOPING.
THAT THERE ARE WAYS TO ADDRESS
THIS GOING FORWARD AND I THINK
THIS BUDGET. HAS SOMEREALLY
POSITIVE A STEPS TOWARD IT. BUT
IT DOESN'T FULLY GET THE IRAN
AND WHEN I WAS BUDGET CHAIR IN
THE ASSEMBLY FROM 200-042-2000
EIGHT. WE HAD TO DEAL WITH WHAT
WAS KNOWN AS THE EQUALIZATION
ISSUE. AND WHAT HAPPENED IS THAT
MANY K. THROUGH TWELVE DISTRICTS
WERE LOCKED INTO THEIR FUNDING
AT THE TIME OF PROP NINETY EIGHT
BASED ON THE FACTORS THAT WENT
THERE. AND A LOT OF THE CHANGING
FACTORS WERE NOT. ARE TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT BECAUSE IT WAS LOCKED IN
AND THEN IS DISTRICTS CHANGE
PARTICULARLY IN SUBURBAN AREAS
THEY WERE DISADVANTAGED IN THE
FORMULA. BECAUSE OF WHAT IT BEEN
LOCKED IN BASED ON CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT NO LONGER EXISTED. AND IF
WE DON'T FIGURE OUT A LONG TERM
SOLUTION. FOR THE STUDENT
CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA WE WILL
BE DOING THE SAME THING WILL BE
LOCKING IN. A CIRCUMSTANCES FROM
THE PAST IN A WAY THAT SOME
FUTURE LEGISLATURE IN SOME
FUTURE CHANCELLOR. ALTHOUGH DAM
LOOKS YOUNG ENOUGH THAT HE'LL BE
THE PERSON IT'LL BE HERE TRYING
TO FIX IT FOR FINANCE. ARE WE
WOULD THEN HAVE TO DEAL WITH
THAT ARE GOING FORWARD SO. I
JUST FEEL OBLIGATED TO OFFER
THAT IS CONVERSATION AS WE HEAD
TOWARD THE MAY REVISE AND TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO CONTINUE TO
ADDRESS. SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
WE'VE ALL BEEN TALKING HERE.
THANK YOU. ARE TERM BY ONE
COMMITTEE MEMBER THAT'S HERE AND
EVERYBODY THAT'S LISTENING FOR
BEARING WITH ME ON THAT BUT- BUT
THIS IS A BIG DEAL AND WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES. AND SOME BY ME YES. SIR
A MAN IF ANYTHING LEFT ON THE-
POSSIBLY FOR YOU TO. HER TO
ABOUT HERE. I JUST WANT TO MAKE
A BRIEF COMMENT AND THAT IS TO
SAY I THINK CAROLERS YOU
ELOQUENTLY DESCRIBED THE
TENSIONS BETWEEN. THE SCF I'LL
STOP USING ACRONYM- AND- THE
HOLD HARMLESS AND- I WANT TO
JUST. REITERATE THE COMMENTS I
MADE EARLIER AND ISSUE ONE.
WHICH IS I HINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR US TO DRILL DOWN
AND FIGURE OUT WHAT ENROLLMENT
IS GONNA LOOK LIKE AND TO WHAT
DEGREE. ENROLLMENT CHANGES ARE
DRIVEN BY TEMPORARY COVERT
RELATED ITEMS VIS A VIS LONGER
STRUCTURAL ISSUES. BECAUSE IT
DOES STRIKE ME THAT WE ARE
SEEING PERHAPS SOME MORE THAN
TEMPORARY DECLINES IN ROME AND
THOSE MIGHT BE SIGNIFICANT. AND
IF THAT'S THE CASE THEN THEN WE
IT IS BETTER AS AS CHAIR LEONARD
POINTED OUT. FOR US TO GET AHEAD
OF THIS AND I'M MINDFUL OF THE
FACT THAT. WE HAVE A LOT OF
ISSUES IN OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND WE ARE RESOURCE STARVED AND
WE HAVE DEPRIVED THE CCC'S. FOR
SOME PERIOD OF TIME OF THE
RESOURCES THAT YOU NEED TO
EFFECTIVELY EDUCATE OUR
STUDENTS. AT THE SAME TIME A FOR
FACING MAJOR STRUCTURAL DECLINES
IN ENROLLMENT. THE THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE TO REALLY
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT AS WE DECIDE
HOW TO ALLOCATE SCARCE RESOURCES
SO- YOU KNOW I WOULD JUST
ENCOURAGE. AS PART OF THIS
PROCESS. ARE FROM MY PURCHASE
ONE OF THREE MEMBERS OF THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE. THAT IT WOULD BE
REALLY REALLY HELPFUL FOR US TO
HAVE MORE DATA. ON ON WHAT IS IN
ROOM IT'S GONNA LOOK LIKE
BECAUSE I REALLY DON'T HAVE ANY
SENSE RIGHT NOW- YOU KNOW IN
FIVE YEARS WHAT IS THE TOTAL
AGGREGATE ROOM IN OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM LOOK LIKE. AND
WHAT IS THE APPROPRIATE LEVEL
RESOURCES THAT WE SHOULD BE
PUSHING THEIR- THANK YOU SENATOR
REALLY APPRECIATE THOSE
COMMENTS. IN AND THANKS TO EVERY
PANELIST THERE. OF FOR BEARING
WITH US ON THIS AND OBVIOUSLY WE
HOPE THIS WILL BE A CONTINUED
CONVERSATION IN THE NEXT FOUR
MONTHS. AMAZINGLY AS WE MOVE TO
ISSUE FOR WE HAVE EXACTLY THE
SAME PANEL. AND THE SUBJECT IS
THE PART TIME FACULTY. A HEALTH
INSURANCE PROGRAM. AND WE WILL
GO N THE SAME ORDERS BEFORE
MOST START WITH STANDOUT. HANNAH
WERE FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- ALTHOUGH BY THE TIME WE
GET DONE WITH THIS HEARING YOU
MAY BE AS OLD AS I WAS
DESCRIBING AND THE LAST I. BUT
THEN I WILL I WILL TRY TO KEEP
MY COMMENTS BRIEF- AGAIN DAN HAD
OUR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- IN
THE GOVERNOR'S VETO MESSAGE FOR
EIGHTY THREE SEVENTY FIVE. HE
COMMITTED TO CONSIDERING OPTIONS
TO BETTER SUPPORT PART TIME
FACULTY WITHIN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. MINISTRATION PROPOSES TO
FULFILL THAT COMMITMENT WITH THE
INVESTMENT OF TWO HUNDRED
MILLION ONGOING PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND. INTO
THE PART TIME FACULTY HEALTH
INSURANCE PROGRAM. THE
ADMINISTRATION EXPECTS THAT THIS
INVESTMENT PROVIDED STRONG
FISCAL INCENTIVES. FOR DISTRICTS
OFFER HEALTH INSURANCE TO MORE
OF THE PART TIME FACULTY. FOSTER
PROVIDING LOCAL CONTROL AND
FLEXIBILITY ON THE PETITION.
WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE ABOUT
THIS INVESTMENT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH LMAO. THANK YOU CARE
LAYERED. THIS IS REALLY AN ISSUE
WE THINK THE LEGISLATURE NEEDS
MORE INFORMATION ON TO MAKE A
DECISION AS YOUR AGENDA NOTES
THE GOVERNOR WOULD LIKE TO
EXPAND HEALTH CARE COVERAGE TO
PART TIME FACULTY IN PART TIME
FACULTY ARE CRITICAL PART OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND STATE CERTAINLY HAS AN
INTEREST IN MAKING SURE YOU'RE
TAKING CARE OF. YET THE
LEGISLATURE DOES NOT HAVE SOME
BASIC INFORMATION IT REALLY
NEEDS LEGISLATURE DOESN'T KNOW
HOW MANY PART TIME FACULTY
ALREADY HAVE HEALTH INSURANCE
AND WHERE THEY GET THAT COVERAGE
FROM THE LEGISLATURE ALSO
DOESN'T KNOW HOW MANY LACK.
HEALTH CARE INSURANCE DESPITE
THE STATE'S REQUIREMENTS FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO HAVE ADEQUATE
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE SO WITHOUT
THIS INFORMATION IT'S REALLY NOT
POSSIBLE FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
DETERMINE IF THERE'S A PROBLEM
AND HOW WIDESPREAD THAT PROBLEM
MIGHT BE. THE LEGISLATURE DOES
NOTE THAT A NUMBER OF DISTRICTS
DO OFFER HEALTH CARE TO PART
TIME FACULTY BUT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS LIMITED INFORMATION ON THE
EXTENT OF THAT COVERAGE AND THE
COST THAT EMPLOYEES MUST BEAR
AND WHETHER SOME PART TIME
FACULTY MIGHT HAVE BEEN BETTER
OFF GETTING COVERAGE THROUGH
COVERED CALIFORNIA INSTEAD WHICH
PROVIDE SUBSIDIES FOR MONEY
CALIFORNIANS. SO THE GOVERNOR'S
APPROACH TO PROVIDE HEALTH CARE
TO PART TIME FACULTY THROUGH
DISTRICT. SPONSORED COVERAGE- I
CAN UNDERSTAND WHERE HE'S COMING
FROM THERE BUT YET THE THERE'S
AN ISSUE ABOUT PART TIME FACULTY
THEY'RE CONSIDERED TEMPORARY
EMPLOYEES OF THE DISTRICT. AND
THEY MAY NOT BE RETAIN FROM ONE
YEAR TO THE NEXT OR EVEN ONE
SEMESTER TO THE NEXT SO EVEN IF
THE DISTRICT. WERE TO OFFER A
ROBUST COVERAGE TO PART TIME
FACULTY THE LEGISLATURE FACES AS
PART OF A LARGER POLICY QUESTION
ABOUT WHETHER A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PROGRAM IS THE BEST WAY
TO PROVIDE THEM WITH HEALTH
INSURANCE. I WOULD MANY
INSTRUCTORS POTENTIALLY GETTING
ON THE DISTRICT COVERED ALL
HEALTH INSURANCE WHEN THEY'RE
WORKING ON THEIR TEACHING AND
THEN OFF WHEN THEY ARE NOT
OFFERED. OF COURSE TO TEACH. AND
OF COURSE THERE'S THIS ISSUE
ABOUT WHAT ABOUT OTHER PART TIME
EMPLOYEES WORKING IN THE STATE
BEYOND JUST CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE A PART TIME FACULTY. SO
WE RECOMMEND THE DIRECTIVE MEANT
WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
DIRECT ADMINISTRATION TO GET
MORE INFORMATION ON THE
INSURANCE STATUS OF PART TIME
FACULTY AND ON ART TIME FACULTY
HEALTH CARE PLANS THAT ARE
OFFERED BY DISTRICTS CURRENTLY.
I KNOW THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS HAS DONE SOME WORK
IN THAT AREA- ALREADY- WE ALSO
RECOMMENDS THE LEGISLATURE
DIRECT ADMINISTRATION TO WORK
WITH OTHER STATE AGENCIES- TO
GATHER INFORMATION. ON PART TIME
WORKERS IN THE STATE. THAT WILL
GIVE A- MORE FOR. LEGISLATURE
GAS THE SHOULD BACK IN THE FALL
FALL TWO TO SUBMIT THE- AND THAT
WILL GIVE INFORMATION. TO THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE AN INFORMED
DECISION ABOUT THIS ISSUE. FOR
NEXT YEAR POTENTIAL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND WILL MOVE TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
ARE VERY GLAD TO SEE IN A ROBUST
INVESTMENT IN PART TIME FACULTY
HEALTH. IF YOU MAY RECALL THIS
PROGRAM WAS FUNDED AT FOUR
HUNDRED AND NINETY THOUSAND
DOLLARS- BOTH WOEFULLY
UNDERFUNDED GIVEN THE NEED FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS HAVE ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE AND THE IMPORTANCE
OF HEALTH CARE DURING THE TIME
OF ENDEMIC. WE DO SUPPORT THIS
PROPOSAL WE DO THINK THERE ARE
OPTIONS TO PROVIDE A HIGHER
REIMBURSEMENT RATE FOR DISTRICTS
SO THAT THERE IS A GREATER
INCENTIVE TO PROVIDE HEALTH CARE
. WE HAVE THIRTY ONE DISTRICTS
ARE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THAT
SMALL FOUR HUNDRED NINETY
THOUSAND PROGRAM BUT WITH ADDED
RESOURCES WE THINK THAT MANY
OTHERS CAN POTENTIALLY
PARTICIPATE AND THEN CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THEIR PART TIME
FACULTY TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO
QUALITY CARE. THANK YOU HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
AN ARMY SAY BEFORE I ANSWER
QUESTIONS I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS AND I THINK THAT THE- THE
QUESTIONS ARE ABOUT TO ASK ARE
REALLY DESIGNED MORE TO FIND
OUT. IF THERE'S A WAY TO GET TO
THE BEST ADVANTAGE OF THE
COLLEGE DISTRICTS AND THE PART
TIME FACULTY AND WHAT THEIR
COMPENSATION IS AND HOW TO GET
THERE AND SO. I WAS GONNA S.
FINANCE FIRST FROM WHAT THE
ANALYTICAL BASIS WAS FOR THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS- A
NUMBER THAT'S IN THE BUDGET TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE. SURE SO THE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION I THINK I
THINK REFLECTS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S- INTEREST IN
AND REALLY PROVIDING A STRONG
FISCAL INCENTIVES FOR DISTRICTS
TO PROVIDE. RATED LEVELS O
HEALTH INSURANCE TO THEIR PART
TIME FACULTY- WHILE ALSO
BALANCING THAT NEED WITHIN OF
THE AVAILABLE RESOURCES
UNDERNEATH THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GUARANTEE SO I
THINK IN TEN TERMS OF WHY
SPECIFICALLY TWO HUNDRED NINE
IT'S- IT'S REALLY THOSE TWO
FACTORS BALANCED OF. AVAILABLE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE ON GOING
RESOURCES UNDER THE NINETY
GUARANTEE- BOUNCED AGAINST I
GUESS WHAT I WAS CONCERNED ABOUT
IS DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY PART
TIME FACULTY DON'T HAVE HEALTH
INSURANCE HOW MUCH IT'LL COST
AND WHETHER THIS IS AN ADEQUATE
NUMBER- I WOULD HAVE TO DEFER TO
MY COLLEAGUES. FROM THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IN TERMS OF
MORE INFORMATION ON THE SPECIFIC
NUMBER OF PART TIME FACULTY WHO
WHO CURRENTLY DO NOT HAVE HEALTH
INSURANCE- AGAIN I MEAN I THINK
THIS PROPOSAL IS REALLY DESIGNED
TO SIGNAL THE- ADMINISTRATION'S
STRONG. INTEREST IN PROVIDING
GREATER LEVELS OF PART TIME
FACULTY HEALTH INSURANCE- THE TO
THE- ENTER ENTER IS A PROGRAM
DESIGNED IN IMPACTED THIS
PROPOSAL I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE- CONTINUING
TO- TRY TO LEARN MORE ABOUT IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH STAKEHOLDERS-
AS WELL AS OUR ARE PARTNERS IN
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. AND.
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT NEW
INVESTMENTS- IN THIS PROGRAM
THAT'S CURRENTLY FUNDED AT ABOUT
FOUR HUNDRED NINETY THOUSAND.
DOLLARS AN ONGOING BASIS AND SO
I THINK THERE'S GOING TO BE- A
LOT MORE THAT WE'RE LEARNING
ABOUT THIS- BASED BASED ON THIS
THAT THE LEVEL OF BUSINESS
INVESTMENT AND THEN LET ME ASK
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IF SHE COULD
REFLECT ON THE QUESTION. YES
HAPPY TO REFLECT ON THAT
QUESTION BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
ALL DISTRICTS PARTICIPATING IN
THE PROGRAM GIVEN THAT ON
AVERAGE THEY GET CENTS ON THE
DOLLAR FOR PARTICIPATION BECAUSE
THE PROGRAM IS SO LOW FUNDED- WE
KNOW THAT THREE THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED NINETY FIVE FACULTY
PARTICIPATE IN THE CURRENT
PROGRAM WHAT WE DON'T KNOW. IS
HOW MANY INDIVIDUALS PARTICIPATE
AND OTHER HEALTH- RECEIVE
HEALTHCARE THROUGH OTHER MEANS
EITHER THROUGH HEALTH PROGRAM
THAT IS PROVIDED BY THE DISTRICT
BUT THEY JUST DON'T APPLY FOR
REIMBURSEMENT. OR AS THE SHARED
THROUGH THE EXCHANGE WE KNOW
THAT- MANY OF OUR FACULTY
COLLEAGUES- GROUPS ARE SEEKING
MISINFORMATION TO TRY TO GET
THAT INFORMATION AND WE'LL LOOK
TO- GAINING THAT WE ALSO THINK
THAT GREATER PARTICIPATION IN
THIS PROGRAM. WOULD GIVE US THAT
DATA POINTS. K. TWELVE. BECAUSE
I THINK OUR BOTH OF YOU VERY.
SAID DON'T KNOW. THIS SIR IT
BECAUSE YOU REALLY DON'T KNOW
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE OUT THERE
THAT NEED THIS AND WHAT THE COST
IS. ONE ME ASK THERE'S THE
THERE'S BEEN A DISCUSSION OF THE
CURRENT PROGRAM AND HOW MUCH
COAST THERE. WHAT WOULD THE
OVERLAY OF THIS NEW AMOUNT TO
THAT. WOULD THIS BE AN EXTENSION
OF WHAT GOES TO THOSE COLLEGES
TO EVERY OTHER COLLEGE WOULD IT
BE MORE TO THOSE THAT ARE
ALREADY PARTICIPATING AND THOSE
THAT HAVEN'T. WHAT WOULD BE THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE CURRENT
PROGRAM AND WHAT IS CREATED BY
THIS ALLOCATION. BUT A JUMP IN
SENATOR LAYERED. SO AS I
MENTIONED WE ONLY ABOUT THIRTY
ONE DISTRICTS AND ON THIS YEAR
BUT THAT FLUCTUATES YEAR TO YEAR
SO THIS YEAR WE ONLY ABOUT
THIRTY ONE DISTRICTS
PARTICIPATING. THE TOTAL PREMIUM
COSTS WERE ON THIRTY ONE- POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS- AND THAT
AGAIN IS- UP WITH ABOUT. LESS
THAN A THIRD OF DISTRICTS
PARTICIPATING AND SO WE DO THINK
THAT WITH GREATER IN NUMBER OF
DISTRICTS- ACTUALLY TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THIS ARE THEY TOTAL
COSTS WOULD INCREASE WE ALSO.
WOULD HOPING THAT THIS WOULD
LEAD TO HIGHER QUALITY HEALTH
BENEFITS- AND THEY WOULD BE-
AGAIN THIS PROGRAM WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE TO ANY DISTRICT THAT
SEEKS REIMBURSEMENT. SO IT WOULD
SUPPORT THOSE THAT ARE ALREADY
PARTICIPATING AS WELL AS ANY
NEW. DISTRICT I GET THAT BUT I
CAN'T TELL IF IT SUPPORTS IN THE
SAME WAY WOULD THEY BE GETTING
MORE THE EXISTING DISTRICTS
BECAUSE THERE'S ALLOCATION AND
THEN THE LEVEL WOULD BE HIGHER
FOR ALL DISTRICTS. IT IS THE
PROPOSAL DETECTIVE PROGRAM THAT
EXISTS FOR THE CURRENT DISTRICTS
AND EXTENDED TO THE OTHER
COLLEGE DISTRICTS. HOW IS THIS
GOING TO WORK. SO THE PRO WILL.
EXTEND TO- IT WOULD BE PROVIDED-
GREATER RESOURCES TO ALL
DISTRICTS THAT PARTICIPATE THOSE
THAT ARE CURRENTLY ENACT SO THEY
WOULD HAVE ACCESS TO GREATER
RESOURCES. AS WELL AS ANY NEW
DISTRICTS THAT DECIDE TO JOIN-
WITH A INVESTMENT THAT IS BEFORE
YOU. DISTRICTS COULD ALSO HAVE
LOCAL CONVERSATIONS THAT HAPPEN
AS PART OF THEIR LOCAL
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING IN THEIR
LOCAL CONTROL- IT TO LOOK AT
BETTER QUALITY HEALTH PROGRAMS.
SO THERE ARE MANY IMPROVEMENTS
THAT COULD HAPPEN AS PART OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS PROGRAM
THEN OF WHAT ME JUST MAKE
STATEMENT BECAUSE- EIGHT I
REALLY THINK THAT THE BOTTOM
LINE OF QUESTIONING IS WE REALLY
DON'T KNOW. WE DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY PEOPLE NEEDED WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE LEVEL WOULD BE. WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE ON GOING
COST WOULD BE WE DON'T KNOW IF
IT'S ADEQUATE FOR MEETING THE
NEED FOR THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE OUT THERE AND I THINK.
AS WE HAD TO THE MAY REVISED WE
WOULD LIKE TO KNOW THE ANSWERS
TO ALL THOSE QUESTIONS BECAUSE
IF THERE'S A QUESTION ABOUT
PROVIDING AN ENTITLEMENT THAT AT
SOME POINT WE CAN'T FIND. A HOME
I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE SURE WE
COULD FIND IT SO I WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION AS AS WE GO INTO
THIS. AND SO I THINK THAT THE
WAY I INTERPRET. THE GOVERNOR'S
RECOMMENDATION IT'S TO THROW A
NUMBER ON THE TABLE TO START THE
DISCUSSION AND SO I'M JUST
HOPING THERE'S A DISCUSSION THAT
GETS US TO SOME DEFINITIVE
ANSWERS TO THESE QUESTIONS BY
THE TIME WE- GET TO THE MAKE
REFUNDS SO LET ME JUST- ASK MY
COLLEAGUES WE'VE BEEN JOINED BY
SENATOR CHOI BOGUE LET ME ASK MY
COLLEAGUES AND IT WAS. OUR QUICK
COM FROM SAN MAN. I ALSO WANT TO
ECHO- CENTER LETTERS COMMENTS
WHILE I CERTAINLY RESPECT AND
APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY FROM-
ALEJO OUT WE DO NEED MORE DATA
ON EXACTLY WHAT THE COST OF THIS
IS GOING TO BE I THINK AS A AS A
MATTER OF PRINCIPLE- I THINK
WE'VE TREATED OUR PART TIME
INSTRUCTORS- INCREDIBLY POORLY
AND- IT'S ABOUT TIME WE PROVIDED
THEM WITH. HEALTHCARE WHICH AND
I THINK IT'S A BASIC HUMAN RIGHT
AND AS WE ALL AGREE ON IN
CALIFORNIA SO- AS A MATTER OF
PRINCIPLE I SUPPORT THIS
OBVIOUSLY IT'S IMPORTANT
UNDERSTAND WHAT THIS WILL COST
US BUT- I HOPE WE GET TO THAT
POINT SOONER RATHER THAN LATER.
THANK YOU THE CENTER OF TROUBLES
NO COMMENTS. OKAY THEN. LET ME-
THANK THE PANEL. WHO AMAZINGLY
IS NOT GOING VERY FAR AWAY.
BECAUSE WE'RE MOVING TO ISSUE
FIVE THE LOWER DIVISION A
TRANSFER RELATED ISSUES. OF WE
HAVE THE SAME- PANEL AND WE'LL
START WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. BANDANNA WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR THIS
PANEL WILL DISCUSS THREE
PROPOSALS THAT UTILIZE ONE TIME
RESOURCES TO SIMPLIFY THE
COLLEGE GOING AND TRANSFER
EXPERIENCE FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES ONE HUNDRED AND FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT COME COURSE NUMBER. THIS
INVESTMENT IS RELATED TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN ELEVEN AND BUILT ON THE
INVESTMENT OF TEN MILLION
INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET. FOR THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A COMMON COURSE
NUMBERING SYSTEM ACROSS THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES
SIXTY FIVE MILLION ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND. FOR COLLEGES TO IMPLEMENT
THE TRANSFER FORM PROVISIONS OF
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE TWENTY EIGHT.
AND FINALLY THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES TWENTY FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND. TO
ASSIST COMMUNITY COLLEGES FOR
THE PROCUREMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF SOFTWARE THAT
CLEARLY MAPS OUT INTERSEGMENT-
CURRICULAR PATHWAYS. TO HELP
STUDENTS CHOOSE THEIR PATHWAY
WITH SO IT'D STREAMLINED
TRANSFER BETWEEN SEGMENTS. AND
REDUCE ACCESS UNITS TAKEN ON THE
PATH 2 DEGREES OR PROGRAM
COMPLETION. THESE THREE
PROPOSALS WILL BUILD UPON
ONGOING EFFORTS BY THE COLLEGES
TO IMPLEMENT THE GUIDED PATHWAYS
FRAMEWORK- HAPPILY ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE ABOUT
THESE INVESTMENTS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS WILL GO
TO THE- L. A. L. IF THE
LEGISLATURE IS PROBABLY. PLEASED
TO SEE. OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- THAT HAS FUNDING. TO
IMPLEMENT LEGISLATION OF THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED LAST YEAR.
HAVING SAID THAT ONE OF OUR
OFFICE HAS. SOME OF THE SAME
QUESTIONS FOR THE MINISTRATION
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. AS
WHAT'S IN YOUR AGENDA ON PAGES
TWENTY SIX AND TWENTY SEVEN.
WITH REGARD TO THE COMMON COURSE
NUMBER RANGE. ISSUE THE PROPOSED
AMOUNT IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
HUNDRED FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ONE
TIME. IT'S MUCH HIGHER THAN THE
COST ESTIMATE IDENTIFIED BY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. FOR
THAT LEGISLATION. REQUIRING
COMMON COURSE NUMBER AND I WAS
ASSEMBLY BILL. ELEVEN ELEVEN-
ALSO THAT LEGISLATION THAT SAME
LEGISLATION REQUIRES. THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF COMMON COURSE
NUMBER A TO BE BASED ON THE
WORK. OF THE COMMON COURSE
NUMBERING WITH. ADULTS FUNDED IN
THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET
IN MR HANNAH OR MENTION THAT
WORKGROUP- THE. WORKGROUP- IS TO
RECOMMEND. HOW TO GO ABOUT
IMPLEMENTING COMMON COURSE
NUMBER IF THE WORKERS ACTUALLY
HASN'T MET YET OF OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS IT'LL MEET
SOMETIME IN THE NEXT MONTH OR SO
THE MEETING FOR THE FIRST TIME.
ALSO THAT THAT MAKES-
IDENTIFYING A COST ESTIMATE EVEN
MORE DIFFICULT ALSO LEGISLATURE
MAY WANT TO ASK YOU MINISTRATION
AND JOSH'S OFFICE OR HOW THEY
WENT ABOUT DETERMINING. THAT THE
COST OF THE FUNDING AMOUNTING
PROPOSED FUNDING AMOUNT OF FOR
THIS- CONCOURSE NUMBER
INITIATIVE AND THEY DON'T AS
WELL AS TO GET A STATUS UPDATE
ON THE WORKGROUP AND WHEN IT'S-
GOING TO START. AS WE UNDERSTAND
IT THE- PROGRAM PATHWAYS MAPPING
TECHNOLOGY THE MISTER HANOVER
MENTIONS OF THAT WOULD BE A USER
FRIENDLY WAY IT SOUNDS LIKE FOR
JUST PRAYER STUDENTS TO SEE WHAT
HUMANITY COLLEGE COURSES THEY
SHOULD TAKE AND WHICH WATER. ARE
THEY SHOULD TAKE IT. TO GET A
DEGREE OR CERTIFICATE. YOU SUCH
TECHNOLOGY MAY HAVE MERIT- BUT
THAT YOU COLLEGES WILL SOON
CHANGE THEIR COURSE NUMBER IN.
THROUGH THE CONCOURSE NUMBER
INITIATIVE I JUST MENTIONED- IT
MIGHT BE PREMATURE TO- CREATE
AND ROLL OUT THIS NEW TECHNOLOGY
GIVEN THE NUMBER'S GONNA CHANGE
WITHIN A YEAR OR TWO. LASTLY THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET A PROVIDE
SIXTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ONE
TIME EMPLOYMENT ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE TWENTY EIGHT I TRANSFER
PATHWAYS MR HANNAH WERE
MENTIONED. AS YOU GENDER DENOTES
THE CHANCES OFFICE. ESTIMATES
HAD ESTIMATED IMPLEMENTATION
COSTS MORE THAN TWICE THAT
AMOUNT WELL THEY HAD DONE
IDENTIFIED ABOUT A HUNDRED
THIRTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THAT LEGISLATION WHEN I WAS
GOING THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS A LEGISLATURE. MAY WANT
THE ADMINISTRATION CHAO'S OFFICE
TO EXPLAIN THAT DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE COST ESTIMATE WHAT'S
PROVIDED. YOU CAN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE YOU SENATOR
LAYERED WANTED REITERATE OUR
SUPPORT FOR- THESE PROPOSALS I
STAY ON HEALTHCARE COLLEGES
IMPLEMENT EXISTING- STATUTORY
PROVISIONS THAT THIS LEGISLATURE
HAS PRIORITIZED THEY ALSO- FOCUS
OUR EFFORTS ON MANY OF THE
STRATEGIES THAT BOTH ARE
INCORPORATED IN FUNDING WHICH
ARE- ADVANCING STUDENT SUCCESS
IN ADVANCING TRANSFER. ALL NOTE-
A FEW UPDATES WITH REGARDS TO
COMMON COURSE NUMBER RANGE OUR
FOCUS- IN THE INITIAL MONTHS- OF
THIS LEGISLATION SINCE WHAT WAS
SIGNED- AND JUST IN THE FALL HAS
BEEN TO REALLY GAIN AN
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT CURRENTLY
EXISTS WHICH COLLEGES HAVE
CONGRESS NUMBERING SYSTEMS WHAT
PROCESS DID THEY UNDERTAKE HOW
DID THEY ENGAGE FACULTY THAT DO
HAVE PURVIEW OVER THE
CLASSROOMS. AND ALSO GAIN AN
UNDERSTANDING OF OTHER STATES
THAT HAVE COMPLETED AND DONE
THIS WORK SO THAT WE CAN LEARN
AND PREVENT ANY PITFALLS THAT
MAY HAVE THEY THEY MAY HAVE
UNDERGONE SO THOSE ARE THE FIRST
STEPS AS WE SHARED- THE WORKER
WILL CONVENE AND THIS SPRING-
AND- WILL BEGIN ITS PROCESS TO
INTEGRATE THE CONCOURSE
NUMBERING ADOPTION AND MAY USE
SOME OF THE- PREVIOUS EFFORTS
THAT HAVE. OCCURRED UNDER THE I
SEE IDEA EFFORT THEY- COMMENT
IDENTIFICATION- SO THOSE ARE
SOME OF THE KEY UPDATES WITH
REGARDS TO TRANSFER REFORM OUT
WE ARE LOOKING- TO ENGAGE IN
THAT EFFORT IN THE FIRST YEAR
THAT THEY CAN BE COLLEGES WILL
CHAIR THAT STRATEGY IT IS BEING
OVERSEEN BY THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE RESEARCH AND PLANNING AND
SO WE'RE WAITING FOR THAT. GROUP
TO BE CONVENE AND WE WILL BE
HAPPY TO PARTICIPATE I'M HAPPY.
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK
YOU THANK YOU'RE VERY MUCH MY
ME ASK CAR. FIRST THIS TIME THEY
HAVE BEEN A QUEST. NONE FROM SAN
MAN AND IF CENTER- TROUBLE.
NUMBER FIVE. YES A- I'M IT ISN'T
CLEAR THE ADDITIONAL MONEY THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS PROPOSING
WILL ADDRESS HIM THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CONFIRM THE NEED FOR
THE ADDITIONAL MONEY AND DO WE
KNOW WHAT THE TOTAL SCOPE OF THE
NEED IS. THANK YOU SENATOR HOW
DO YOU ADDRESS ME FIRST TALK
ABOUT TRAINS WERE REFORM. WHEN
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE PROVIDED
AN ESTIMATED TALKED ABOUT THE-
IMPORTANT- BUT LARGE UNDERTAKING
THAT THIS WOULD ENTAIL. AND SO-
RESOURCES WERE NOT INITIALLY
PROVIDED FOUR TRANSFER REFORM
WHEN THE LEGISLATION WHICH WAS
PASSED SO WE DO BELIEVE. THAT
THIS INVESTMENT PROVIDES SOME OF
THOSE RESOURCES RECOGNIZING THAT
IT REQUIRES SOME STATE LEVEL
WORK TO CONVENE GROUPS TO
CONVENE OUR COLLEAGUES AT UC AND
CSU WHO ULTIMATELY HAVE TO
ACCEPT THEIR DEGREES. IT ALSO AT
THE STATE LEVEL ALLOWS US TO
START THINKING ABOUT AND-
IDENTIFYING WAYS TO COLLECT
DATA. THAT WE DO NOT HAVE THAT
WILL HELP- ADDRESS SOME OF THE
DELIVERABLES IN THE LEGISLATION
AT THE STATE LEVEL ARE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL IT ALLOWS AND
DISTRICTS TO ADAPT TO THEIR
SYSTEMS. TO CHANGES- AND
TRANSFER- TO MODIFY ANY EXISTING
EMILY HUGHES WITH PUBLIC
TRANSPARENCY TRADITIONS AS WELL
AS CONVENE FACULTY GROUPS. AND
PROVIDE PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT. SO DO WE HAVE- DO WE HAVE AN
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT WE KNOW OR
WE CAN ESTIMATE THERE WILL BE
NEEDING FOR THIS. COVER THE
SCOPE OF WORK. OR TRAINS FOR WE
INITIALLY AND- ESTIMATED- THAT
IT WOULD COST ABOUT- JUST AROUND
A HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION- WE
DO THINK THAT THIS WORK WOULD
HAPPEN IN TANDEM WITH THE
INVESTMENT IN COMMON COURSE
NUMBER RING IN OUR INITIAL
ESTIMATE AROUND THAT HAD BEEN-
JUST OVER FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PER CAMPUS AND WE HAVE A HUNDRED
AND SIXTEEN CAMPUSES. THAT WOULD
MARK ON THIS WORK. THAT'S BEEN
OUR OUR OUR ESTIMATE- FROM THE
CONVERSATIONS FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE FRONT WHEN IT WAS
BEING CONSIDERED. SO THAT'S FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PER CAMPUS. IS
THAT CORRECT THAT'S CORRECT.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THEN
LET ME CLOSE WITH A QUESTION. TO
FOLLOW UP ON OUR IT'S FOR
FINANCE AND THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE MAY WISH TO COMMENT
FOLLOWS UP ON OUR AGENDA AND
COMMENTS OF THE OHIO THAT ON THE
A. B. ELEVEN ELEVEN
IMPLEMENTATION THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES A HUNDRED AND
FIVE MILLION BUT ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS TAGGED IT WHEN IT
WENT BY IT SIXTY MILLION. AND ON
THAT A. B. NINE TWENTY EIGHT
THERE WAS A SIMILAR. DISCREPANCY
WHERE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSED SIXTY FIVE MILLION BUT
THE- COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN
FINANCE ON ANALYSIS CITED THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES- ACCOSTED
HUNDRED THIRTY THREE MILLION.
AND SO- FOR FINANCE CAN YOU TALK
ABOUT BY BOTH OF THOSE ESTIMATES
ARE DIFFERENT- HAPPY TO- DANNY
IN ORDER APARTMENT OF FINANCE-
THE FIRST FOR AB ELEVEN ELEVEN
D. MINISTRATION WORK FOR THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO DEVELOP
ITS OWN COST ESTIMATE FOR AB
ELEVEN ELEVEN- OUR ANALYSIS
ARRIVED AT AN ESTIMATE OF
ROUGHLY ONE MILLION PER CAMPUS
AND SO. WHEN YOU TAKE THAT TOTAL
AMOUNT OF ONE HUNDRED FIFTEEN IN
AND SUBTRACT OUT TEN MILLION-
THAT WAS RIGHT IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT- THAT
THAT'S SORT OF HOW WE ARRIVED AT
OUR- AT OUR BUDGET DOES A STICK
FIGURE. MOVING TO EIGHTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT- D. R. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. REFLECTS THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INVESTMENT
REFLECTS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
INTENT THAT. EXISTING RESOURCES
IN THE- COUNSELING AND
MARKETING- SIDE OF CAMPUS IS BE
USED TO COVER COSTS RELATED TO
THAT AND- AND ESPECIALLY THOSE
ACTIVITIES ARE NOT SPECIFICALLY
REQUESTED BY OR REQUIRED BY
STATUTE. AND SO ONCE THOSE
SPECIFIC COMPONENTS OF THE
ECOSYSTEM IN A REMOVED YOU
ARRIVED AT OUR OUR COST ESTIMATE
SIXTY FIVE MILLION- AND OF
COURSE WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
YOUR STAFF TO PROVIDE MORE
DETAIL IN THIS. THANK YOU
DISEASE BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO
ZERO THE L. A. O. OR- CANCERS
OFFICE HAVE A COMMENT ON THAT.
LOOKING TO ADD CHAIRMAN LAYERED
OKAY. I THINK THE L. ELSE
SHAKING HIS HEAD BUT HE COULD BE
LOOKING BACK AND FORTH TO TWO
COMPUTER SCREENS. YEAH A COUPLE
COUPLE COMMENTS- FIRST I THINK
THAT'S THE FIRST OUR OFFICE
HEARD ON THE SIXTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR REVISED ESTIMATE FOR THE
TRANSFER REFORM BILL THAT AB
NINE TWENTY EIGHT SO THAT WOULD
BE INTERESTING- AND WE COULD-
TAKE A LOOK AND SHARE WITH
STAFF- ON ON THAT COST ESTIMATE
THIS REVISED COST ESTIMATE FROM
A HUNDRED THIRTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS ORIGINALLY DOWN TO SIXTY
FIVE MILLION. OF WITH REGARD TO
COMMON COURSE NUMBER IN THAT
COST. STILL I DON'T THINK THE
LEGISLATURE NEEDS MORE
INFORMATION ON. BY THE- THE
AMOUNT WAS ESTIMATED AT ABOUT
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER COLLEGE WILL BILLS GOING
THROUGH LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND
NOW THAT AMOUNT IS JUMPED TO A
MILLION DOLLARS FOR COLLEGE- BUT
YOU THAT SAID THAT THE WORKGROUP
BUT IN THIS NAVARETTE MENTIONED
THERE ARE SOUNDS LIKE THEY'RE
GOING TO BE STARTING TO WORK
SOON SO THAT MIGHT. SHED SOME
LIGHT ON ON WHAT THE COSTS WILL
BE YOU KNOW BASED ON WHAT THE
WORKGROUP RECOMMENDS WHAT THEY
SEE AS AS THE BEST WAY FORWARD
TO IMPLEMENT THIS LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU N. N. AS A CLOSING
COMMENT I WOULD JUST SAY I HOPE
YOU ALL WILL WORK TOGETHER. ON
THOSE NUMBERS AND JUST INFORM US
AS WE HEAD TO THE MADE REVISED
AND- IN WHAT YOU THINK SO THANK
YOU FOR THIS DISCUSSION. WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER SIX
STUDENT SUPPORT PROGRAMS
INTERESTINGLY IT'S THE SAME
PANEL. SO WHAT OF WILL BEGIN
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AND OUR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THE ADMINISTRATION RECOGNIZES
THAT THE PANDEMIC IN ANSWERING
RECESSION HAVE NOT IMPACTED ALL
GROUPS EQUALLY. EVEN BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC THREATS PERSISTENT LONG
TERM EQUITY GAPS THAT EXISTED
AND MOST IF NOT ALL OF OUR STATE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AS SUCH THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES A
SLATE OF NEW INVESTMENTS
DESIGNED TO SUPPORT OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS AND
WORK TOWARDS MEETING THE MULTI
YEAR ROADMAP GOAL OF ELIMINATING
EQUITY GAPS ACROSS THE SYSTEM.
IN PARTICULAR THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES TEN MILLION ON
GOING TO EXPAND THE NEXT UP
PROGRAM. TEN MILLION ONGOING TO
SUPPORT THE STABLE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE EO PAST
PRACTICES OR EQUAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY SORRY BUT THE
ACRONYM BEST PRACTICES TO
DIVERSIFY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACULTY STAFF AND
ADMINISTRATORS. TWENTY MILLION
ONE TIME TO SUPPORT EMERGENCY
STUDENT FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
GRANTS TO ELIGIBLE AB FIVE FORTY
STUDENTS- ONE POINT ONE MILLION
ONGOING SUPPORT THE EXPANSION
OF. AMEND STUDENT CHARTERS TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS. AND ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE THOUSAND
ONE TIME TO SUPPORT A STUDY OF
THE MUCH OF PROGRAM PRACTICES
THAT PROMOTE STUDENT SUCCESS FOR
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS. THE
BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES THE COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENTS OR INCLUDES
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENTS TO
PROGRAMS THAT EITHER STATUTORILY
OR TYPICALLY RECEIVE ONE AND-
WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER.
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE ABOUT
THESE INVESTMENTS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MOVE TO THE L. A. L.
SO THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
PROPOSALS IN THIS. AGENDA ITEM
SO JUST A COUPLE COMMENTS NOW
MAKE FIRST THE LEGISLATURE DOES
NOT HAVE MUCH INFORMATION SO FAR
ON THAT AMEND. PROPOSAL WHICH
WOULD BE A NEW A STATE FUNDED
PROGRAM. LEGISLATURE WILL LIKELY
WANT TO GET SOME BASIC
INFORMATION ABOUT THE PROPOSAL
WHAT WOULD BE THE ALLOWABLE USE
OF THIS FUNDING FOR EXAMPLE. HOW
THE PROPOSED AMOUNT OF ONE POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING WAS
DETERMINED. HOW THE FUNDS WOULD
BE ALLOCATED. TO OUR CAMPUSES.
AND HOW THE PROPOSAL WOULD
MEASURE SUCCESS ALSO HOW THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD INTERACT WITH
ANOTHER STATE FUNDED. PROGRAM
FOCUSED ON AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENT SUCCESS EMOJI WHICH
WHICH MR HANNAH OR- MENTIONED.
SO LEGISLATURE MAY WANT MY WANT
TO DIRECT THE MINISTRATION AND
JESS'S OFFICE TO PROVIDE THIS
INFORMATION. AND USE IT TO HELP
MAKE A. DECISION ON THE FINAL
BUDGET- REGARD TO NEXT UP OF
PROGRAM THAT THAT PROPOSE
AUGMENTATION. THERE ARE DATA
THAT SUGGESTS THE PROGRAM IS
EFFECTIVE AT SUPPORTING ON
FOSTER USE FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
WHO ARE IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WE DO UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE ARE THAT YOU KNOW YOU
ACTUALLY YOU ARE CHAIRED LAYERED
AND IN CENTER MAN- AND OTHERS I
HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE GOVERNOR
PLACING A STATUTORY CAP. ON THE
NUMBER OF PROGRAMS AND HAVING
DISTRICTS SUPPLY AND SO WE'D BE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOUR STAFF-
TO ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS IN THE
COMING MONTHS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND WILL MOVE TO THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN LETTER TO MEMBERS OF
THE ON BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE WHEN
WE CAN BY HIGHLIGHTING ONE OF
THE PROGRAMS- THAT'S NEW- HERE
IN THE GOVERNOR'S INVESTMENTS
AND THAT'S THE AND THEN- GRAHAM
FOLLOWING THE MURDER OF GEORGE
FLOYD- MANY OF OUR STATE LEADERS
COLLEGE CAMPUSES STUDENTS
JOINED. IN THE CALL TO ACTION TO
REALLY FOCUS ON BLACK STUDENT
SUCCESS ONE OF TWO GROUPS IN
PARTICULAR HAVE REALLY UP IN THE
MIDDLE AND LOCAL STRATEGIES TO
HELP STUDENTS THE AMEND PROGRAM
IS DESIGNED TO SUPPORT BLACK
MALE STUDENTS THAT HAVE A
DISPROPORTIONATELY NORMALLY FACE
IMPACTS- PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC
BUT CONTINUE TO FACE AN EVEN NOW
ISN'T SENIOR LOWER- RE
ENROLLMENT FIVE BLACK STUDENTS.
THE THIS PROGRAM WOULD REALLY
PROVIDE GUIDANCE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND NETWORKS OF
SUPPORTERS STUDENTS TO BACK
LOCAL CAMPUS STRATEGIES CAN
REALLY FOCUS ON SUPPORTING BLACK
STUDENT SUCCESS- AND THEN- THAT
ACADEMIC PROGRAMS COULD ALSO A
SUPPORT THEIR ENGAGEMENT AND
LEARNING. CURRENTLY THERE ARE
TWENTY FOUR PROGRAMS ACROSS THE
SYSTEM THIS WOULD ENABLE- MORE
PROGRAMS TO BE ESTABLISHED WITH
THE GOAL OF ESTABLISHING AT
LEAST FIFTY. AND THEN- OF GRANTS
WILL BE PROVIDED- ANYWHERE FROM
THIRTY THOUSAND ARE ESTIMATED
THIRTY THOUSAND CAR ON CAMPUS- I
ALSO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE
ALIGNMENT WITH THE MOTION MOTION
WORKS BROADLY WITH A BLACK
STUDENT SUCCESS HAS A
LONGSTANDING HISTORY AND SUCCESS
AND ALSO HELPING DEVELOP.
ACADEMIC CULTURES THAT SUPPORT
BLACK STUDENTS SO WE'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF BOTH OF THESE
INVESTMENTS I BELIEVE IT'S THE
RIGHT APPROACH WITH REGARDS TO
NEXT UP WE'RE VERY GLAD TO SEE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW WE CAN
EXPAND THESE EFFORTS WERE ALSO-
GLAD TO BE WORKING WITH- AS
CHAIRMAN YOUR- YOUR T. AS WELL.
ON HOW CAN SO OF THE GRAY. IDEAS
THAT HAVE BEEN HIGH- IN THE THAT
IT. EITHER WAY WE THINK THAT
CONVERSATION ON HOW WE SERVE OUR
STUDENTS KEY AS WE PROJECT- OVER
FOUR THOUSAND- STUDENTS ARE
CURRENTLY SIR BUT THERE ARE MORE
THAN TEN THOUSAND STUDENTS THAT
ARE NOT BEING SERVED- BELIEVE
THAT IT'S THE RIGHT APPROACH TO
IDENTIFY WAYS TO EXPAND SERVICES
TO THEM. HAPPY ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO THE PANELISTS AND-
LAWMAKER. AND THEN ASK A
QUESTION AND A COMMENT IS THAT.
I'M SURE SOME PEOPLEHERE THE
REFERENCES THAT SEEM SOMEWHAT
CRYPTIC TO THE NEXT STEP PROGRAM
AND MY EFFORTS AND- FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO DON'T KNOW THE NEXT A
PROGRAM REALLY DELIVER SERVICES
TO FOSTER KIDS. THE IT IN
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BUT IT HAS
BEEN LIMITED TO TWENTY CAMPUSES
AND SURVIVE INTRODUCED. SENATE
BILL EIGHT EIGHT FIVE WHICH
WOULD REMOVE THE TWENTY CAMPUS
LIMIT AND SO I SALUTE THE TEN
MILLION EXTRA DOLLARS THAT'S PUT
HERE. I THINK THE NEED IS
PROBABLY WILL GREATER. AND
WOULDN'T BE UNHAPPY TO SEE A
LARGER NUMBER IN THE MAY REVISED
TO DEAL WITH THIS BECAUSE I
THINK OF IT THIS PROGRAM'S BEEN
UNIVERSALLY ACCLAIMED AND IT'S
REALLY. ADDRESSING SOMETHING
THAT WE ALL SUPPORT. MY
QUESTION. A IS A QUESTION FROM
LAST YEAR AND THAT IS IT I
NOTICED A LITTLE OBLIQUE
REFERENCE BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO. THE FACT THAT IN THE
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS THEY GET A
CALL IF THEY HAVE HISTORICALLY
GOTTEN A CO WELL TO PROGRAMS
HAVE HISTORICALLY NOT GOT A
COURT. ONE WHICH IS THE POINT
DAY PROGRAM. OUR AND MATH ENGINE
. AND SCIENCE ACHIEVEMENT MESSA
AND SO HERE WE ARE AGAIN WHERE
THEY'RE NOT GETTING CALL WAS AND
IT'S LIKE I THINK WE'VE LAST
YEAR EXPRESSED OUR INTEREST. IN
THEM GETTING COLE WAS AND IT
JUST SEEMS NOT FAIR THAT THEY BE
SINGLED OUT TO NOT GET COURSES
AT THE ANSWER IS IT'S BECAUSE
IT'S HISTORIC THE HISTORIC WE'VE
BEEN STARVED BY THE COST OF
LIVING EVERY YEAR AND THEY
PROVIDE REALLY VALUABLE
SERVICES. M. WE WOULD LOVE TO
SEE IT AND I GUESS I WAS GONNA
MAKE THAT A QUESTION BUT I'LL
JUST MAKE THAT A STATEMENT SO I
HOPE. WHEN YOU HAVE THE
EXTENSIVE DELIBERATIONS IN THE
MAY REVISED YEAH I HAD THE CALL
WAS IT FOR EVERYBODY NOT JUST.
OF THE OTHER ONES SO M. S. MY
COLLEAGUES IF THEY HAVE
QUESTIONS NON FROM SENATOR MEN
NON FROM SENATOR TROUBLES. SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARM WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN. OF FACILITIES AND
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE- AND AS I
KEEP SAYING AMAZINGLY IT'S THE
SAME PANEL SO ARE WE WILL BEGIN
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
ISSUE. SEVEN FACILITIES AND
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE. AT THE END
APARTMENT FINANCE AGAIN- TO GO
BUDGET INCLUDES OBLIGATION BOND
FUNDING OF THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THREE MILLION ONE TIME
FOR THE CONSTRUCTION PHASE THE
SEVENTEEN PROJECTS AND
DISSIPATED TO COMPLETE THE
SIGNED BY SPRING TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. AND THE WORKING DRAWINGS
PHASE ONE PROJECT. THIS
ALLOCATION REPRESENTS THE NEXT
INSTALLMENT OF THE TWO BILLION
AVAILABLE TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES
UNDER PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES
THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SEVEN
POINT SIX MILLION ONETIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND. TO SUPPORT DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROJECTS AT THE
CAMPUSES. THIS FUNDING WILL
BUILD ON THE FIVE HUNDRED ELEVEN
MILLION INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT. THE
FURTHER ADDRESS THAT DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. WITH AN AVID
ANSWER QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE
ABOUT THIS INVESTMENT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL MOVE TO THE L. L.
BRIEFLY IT IS CURRY GENE TO SEE
THE- DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
BACKLOG GO DOWN- AS THE YEAR
GENDER NOTES. NO THAT'S AS A
RESULT OF THAT INVESTMENT IN THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET
OFFICE MISTER HANOVER. I JUST
MENTIONED- WE THINK DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE IS A GOOD USE OF ONE
TIME MONEY. AND WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDE AT LEAST.
THAT AMOUNT IN THE TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE BUDGET AND IF THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT MINIMUM
GUARANTEE COMES IN HIGHER THAN A
REVISION LEGISLATURE COULD.
CONSIDER PROVIDING EVEN MORE
FUNDING. SO WE ALL ENCOURAGE
RELIGIOUS TO DEVELOP A LONGER
TERM STRATEGY FOR BOTH RETIRING.
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG AS WELL AS
ENSURING THAT THE STATE AND
DISTRICTS ARE SPENDING ENOUGH.
TO PREVENT THE BACKLOG FROM
GROWING BACK YOU BECAUSE EVERY
YEAR YOU HAVE BUILDING SYSTEMS
REACH THE END OF THEIR USEFUL
LIFE SO THEY MIGHT NOT BE
CONSIDERED DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
RIGHT NOW BUT THE NEXT YEAR NEXT
FIVE YEARS THE WILL BE. IT'S NOT
ADDRESS SO THAT'S STRATEGY IS-
WILL LIKELY REQUIRE OF PLANNING
BEYOND THE TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE BUDGET CYCLE BUT WE THINK
IT'S A WORTHWHILE ENDEAVOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL MOVE TO
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. QUIPU
AND SENATOR LARRY I'LL BE BRIEF
AND JUST REITERATE THAT- OUR
WERE ADDED CAN YOU COLLEGES TO-
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE NEEDS- AND
BACKLOG IS ONE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS RIGHT NOW WOULD YOU
THANK THE LEGISLATURE FOR MAKING
AN INVESTMENT LAST YEAR THAT
REALLY HELPED BRING THIS COST
DOWN- COLLEGES CONTINUE TO
INVEST ABOUT- 71% OF THEIR- THE
FUNDS DISTRIBUTED WENT DIRECTLY
TO IMMEDIATE- PHYSICAL PLANT-
PROJECTS TO HELP BRING THIS
DOWN. INSURE THE SAFETY OF
FACILITIES- THIS WAS CRITICAL.
SINCE THE YEAR BEFORE. DIFFER
MAINTENANCE RESOURCES HAVE NOT
BEEN PROVIDED AND CREATED AN
ADDITIONAL BACKLOG WE DO THINK
THAT THIS IS A GREAT USE OF ONE
TIME FUNDS ARE AND APPRECIATE
THIS DISCUSSION HAPPY ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
LET ME ASK MY COLLEAGUES IF THEY
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. I DID. WAS
GO CENTER OTRO BOGAN THEN
SENATOR MEANT. SO I'M ACTUALLY
IMPRESSED WITH HOW YOU THE
DIFFERENT MAJORS HOUSING GROWN
EXPONENTIALLY AS WE'VE SEEN AND-
AND AT OTHER UNIVERSITIES I'M
CURIOUS TO KNOW HOW THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES- PROVIDE OR
PRIORITIZE FUNDING TO ADDRESS
THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE- I
THINK YOU FOLKS HAVE A-
OBVIOUSLY A DIFFERENT MODEL THAN
ARE YOU SEASON RCS USE SOME KIND
OF CURIOUS HOW IT IS. HOW IT'S
POSSIBLE TO BE ABLE TO MAINTAIN
THAT LEVEL. OF DEPARTMENT IS NOT
HAVE IT GROW. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I ONE HIGHLIGHT OF THE
METHODOLOGY THAT WAS UTILIZED
FOR RELEASING DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FUNDS THIS HERE- IN
PRIOR YEARS WE RELEASED
RESOURCES BASED ON THAT FTS OF
THE DISTRICT THIS YEAR BECAUSE
OUR IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
FISCALYEAR. OR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO FISCAL YEAR
APOLOGIES BECAUSE THE OF THE
ROBUST INVESTMENT WE WERE ABLE
TO PROVIDE- A ONE MILLION DOLLAR
BASE TO EACH DISTRICT ON THIS
HELD- THOSE IN OUR RURAL. OR
SMALLER DISTRICTS SOME SMALLER
DISTRICTS IN COASTAL AREAS AS
WELL THEY DON'T TYPICALLY HAVE
THAT PURCHASING POWER THAT
ALLOWS THEM TO KEEP THOSE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE COSTS DOWN
INTO THAT METHODOLOGY REALLY
ENABLED US. TO THEN- HAVE THAT
TARGETED APPROACH WE ALSO HAVE A
ROBUST- FACILITIES CONDITION
INDEX THAT WE MAINTAIN FOR OUR
FACILITIES THAT HELPS US
UNDERSTAND WHERE THE NEEDS ARE-
AND HOW TO PRIORITIZE THOSE.
WITH SAFETY AT THE FOREFRONT.
HELP THAT INTO YOUR QUESTION
THANK YOU. VENTURA I'M I'M
THINKING ACTUALLY IN PROCESSING
THE INFORMATION SHE JUST SHARED
BANKING ON PROCESS AND
INFORMATION BECAUSE THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN IN OTHER COMMITTEES WE
HAVE TO ANNOUNCE IT HERE. WELL
I'M NOT I'M PROCESSING HER
ANSWER. OKAY WELL WE'LL GO TO
SENATOR MEN AND IF YOU'RE
PROCESSING RESULTS IN ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS YOU LET ME KNOW
SENATOR BEN- I APPRECIATE THE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE- AND I. I
WOULD NOTE- THE GAP BETWEEN.
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE THIS
PROVIDED IN THE NEEDS WE CAN
CUTS RIGHT RIGHT I THINK YOU
JUST SAID WITH ONE POINT TWO
BILLION IN OUR HAND OUT IT'S AT
ONE POINT SIX BUT EITHER WAY
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY A GAP BETWEEN
THAT AND THE THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY SEVEN. BILLION I'M SORRY
THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN
MILLION THAT IS PROVIDED I IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- MY
QUESTION IS KIND OF TWO FOLD ONE
WHY NOT PROVIDE MORE IN A YEAR
WHEN- IT LOOKS TO BE A GOOD TIME
TO INVEST IN DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND INFRASTRUCTURE
AND THIS IS A POINT I. HAD MADE
OUR EARLIER UC AND CSU HEARINGS
AS WELL- YOU KNOW WE WE'VE GOT A
BUDGET SURPLUS- WE HAVE WE KNOW
SIGNIFICANT BACKLOGS WHEN IT
COMES TO DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
AND INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT.
AND THESE TYPES OF INVESTMENTS
DO NOT COUNT AGAINST AGAIN
LIMIT. SO WHY NOT MORE AND THEN
SECONDARILY- WHY ARE WE TAKING
PROP NINETY EIGHT FUNDING TO DO
THIS WHITE WHY NOT DROP FROM NON
PROP NINETY EIGHT FUNDING WHICH
IS NOT SUBJECT TO BEGAN LIMIT
AND INSTEAD APPLY PROP NINETY
FUNDING WHICH- IS EXAMPLE AGAIN
LIMIT- IS THAT I GUESS THAT'S MY
QUESTION- DID DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE YOU KNOW WHY DO WE
STRUCTURE THIS IS PROP NINETY
EIGHT FUNDING. AND WHY NOT DO
MORE. I'M THIRTEEN HAMMERED
APARTMENT OF FINANCE SO LOCAL
ASSISTANCE FUNDING THAT IS
PROVIDED TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS. FALLS INTO THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE- SO THAT'S WHY THIS
INVESTMENT IS CODED AS IS
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT- AND
AGAIN THAT THAT THAT'S ALSO
GOING TO AFFECT THE FIRST PART
YOUR QUESTION IN THAT- THIS
INVESTMENT IS. UTILIZING
AVAILABLE RESOURCES INTO THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE BUT- IS ALSO BOUNCE
OUT AGAINST SOMEBODY OTHER
INVESTMENTS INCLUDED IN THE- THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- TODAY AND FIT
WITHIN THE PROPOSITION ID
KESSENICH TRAINERS ARE YOU
SAYING YOU CANNOT. USE NONPROFIT
ANY FUNDING FOR THIS. AS IN THE
- BIGLEY THESE SORT OF LIKE
ASSISTANCE DOLLARS THAT ARE
PROVIDED TO DISTRICTS FALL UNDER
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE I DON'T SO IT'S
RESPONSIVE THOUGH THANK YOU AND
HAVE BEEN JUST COMMUNITY TO
ANSWER ARE YOU SAYING YOU CANNOT
USE NON PROP NINETY FUNDING. I'M
I'M SAYING THAT THIS PROPOSAL
UTILIZES PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT FUNDING TO INVEST. IN
THAT'S MY QUESTION WHICH IS WHY
IT WHY REASON PROP NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING INSTEAD OF NONPROFIT AND
YOU FUNDING. BECAUSE WE KNOW THE
PROP NINETY FUNDING IS EXEMPTION
AGAIN LIMIT. NONPROFIT NINETY
FINING GENERAL FUND. IS SUBJECT
TO THE GAMUT AND SO GENERALLY
SPEAKING IT'S IT WOULD SEEM LIKE
A GOOD YEAR TO USE. GENERAL FUND
NONPROFIT NDA FUNDING FOR ALL
SORTS OF INFRASTRUCTURE. NEEDS
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE NEEDS SO
WHY DRAW DOWN FROM THE PROP
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING HERE WHICH
COULD BE UTILIZED FOR A WHOLE
BUNCH OF DIFFERENT PURPOSES
INCLUDING I WOULD SAY THAT THE
HEALTH INSURANCE THAT WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT EARLIER. I INSTEAD
USE PROP NINETY FUNDING EIGHT
THAT WAS A CHOICE THAT WAS MADE
IT SOUNDS LIKE AND I I'M CURIOUS
WHAT MOTIVATED THAT DECISION.
I'M AGAIN I FEEL LIKE- I CAN I
CAN DEFER TO MY COLLEAGUE-
MICHELIN. YEAH MISHANI WHEN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO
QUALIFIED CAPITAL OUTLAY
EXPENDITURES UNDER PROF NINETY
EIGHT ARE CONSIDERED- YOU KNOW.
SELL EXCLUDABLE UNDER THE GAS
LIMIT- SO. YOU KNOW REGARDLESS
OF WHETHER. AND SALAS NOT CELLS
NOT THE FORMER DAHLE AT THE
PLAGUE LAND TO THE STATE
ALLOCATION LIMIT CORRECT YES MY
- NO I DON'T I'M JUST CHECKING
THE FIRST TIME YOU CAN GO SELL
NOW. A DID YOU COMPLETE YOUR
COMMENTS YOU STILL GOING. YET
I'LL JUST FINISH UP QUICKLY
WHICH IS JUST THAT DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE WHETHER OR NOT IT'S
APPROPRIATED UNDER PROP NINETY
EIGHT OR UNDER NON NAY NEED
EXPENDITURES OR CAN BE EXCLUDED
UNDER THE STATE APPROPRIATIONS
LIMIT SO YOU KNOW THAT THE FACT
THAT IT'S PROBABLY NEED DOESN'T
HAVE ANY BEARING ON WHETHER OR
NOT IT'S EXCLUDED OR NOT
EXCLUDING. NO BUT I THINK I FIVE
MY POINT IS THAT OKAY YOU'VE GOT
A PROBLEM A BIG SILO PRIME
NINETY FUNDING THAT CAN BE USED
IT'S NOT NONE OF THAT SUBJECT
AGAIN WHEN IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING RIGHT AND SO THAT
COULD ALL BE USED FOR ANY
PURPOSE RELATED TO CAPE ROUTE
FOURTEEN. IF I CAN RESCUE OF
FINANCE FOR SECOND- THE L. A.
ALWAYS HAD HIS HAND UP FOR
AWHILE AND I FEEL LIKE HE WANTS
TO WADE INTO THIS QUESTION AND
THEN A FINANCE WISHES. TO PASS
ED THEY COULD. WELL IT'S JUST-
CENTER MENU YOU MIGHT. HAVE A-
FOLLOW UP ON THIS BUT- JUST TO
REITERATE WHAT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SAID THAT. UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE IS THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
THAT IS PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND AND IT WOULD BE
EXCLUDED IT'S EXCLUDED EXCLUDED
SPENDING UNDER THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS I MET YEP WORKS
OUT NOW YOU CAN ABSOLUTELY
LEGISLATURE HAS THE ABILITY IF
IT WANTS TO USE NON PROPOSITION
NINETY GENERAL FUND. FOR THESE
KINDS OF PURPOSES AS WELL CAN BE
REMAIN IN STORE FOR OUR FOR
CONSTRUCTION SO YOU ACTUALLY DO
HAVE THAT ABILITY AND I THINK MY
THANK YOU FOR THAT HELPFUL
EXPLANATION MR STENHOUSE AND I
THINK MY POINT IS YOU'VE GOT
PROP NINETY EIGHT FUNDING WHICH
IS EXCLUDED UNDER THE GALLON IT
BUT YOU ALSO HAVE GENERAL. FUND
NONPROFIT NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND THAT COULD BE USED FOR THIS
PURPOSE AND ALSO EXCLUDED- AND
SO ANY IN A YEAR WHEN WE HAVE A
BUNCH OF EDUCATION NEEDS.
DRAWING FROM THE PROP NINETY
EIGHT BUCKET MEANS THAT WE'RE
NOT USING THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
SOME ODD MILLION DOLLARS FOR
pMIGHT DEEM APPROPRIATE- AND SO
THAT SEEMS TO HAVE BEEN A
CONSCIOUS CHOICE TO SAY WE'RE
GONNA DROP THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS FROM PROP
NINETY EIGHT. WHEN WE COULD ALSO
DRAW FROM THE GENERAL FUND AND
THAT WOULD ALSO BE EXCLUDED FROM
DOWN SO THAT THAT'S MY QUESTION
BACK TO DEPARTMENT FINANCES WHAT
WAS THE MOTIVATION- IF THERE WAS
ANY- FOR CHOOSING TO USE PROP
NINETY EIGHT FUNDS AS. OPPOSED
TO NON PROP NINETY EIGHT FUNDS
FOR THIS. SHANI AND APARTMENT
FINANCE SO I'M NOT A AN EXPERT
THE ON THE GAMBLING BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT. PROP
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT IS NOT
AUTOMATICALLY EXCLUDED FROM FROM
THE GET LIMIT. RATHER YOU KNOW
CERTAIN STATE SUBVENTIONS LIKE
THE APPORTIONMENT I BELIEVE ARE
EXCLUDED FROM AGAIN LIMIT AND-
AND- QUALIFIED CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS SUCH AS- DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE ARE EXCLUDED FROM
THE GALLAGHER BUT THERE'S NOT A-
RULE OF THUMB THAT PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT EXPENDITURES ARE
EXCLUDED. FROM THE GALLON AT
LEAST ONCE THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING. AND I THINK YOU
KNOW TO YOUR OTHER POINT-
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE HAS
TRADITIONALLY BEEN. APPROPRIATED
TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES UNDER YET
USING. PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FUNDS AS MY- AS MY COLLEAGUE.
YOU KNOW THERE IS A RATHER
LARGE- INVESTMENT LAST YEAR
UNDER PROPOSITION NINETY DOLLARS
AND I THINK. YOU KNOW IT-
ANOTHER CONSIDERATION IS THAT IF
THERE ARE NON NINETY DOLLARS
THAT ARE APPROPRIATED TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES- YOU KNOW
OUTSIDE OF THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GUARANTEE AND THEN
THERE IS A RISK OF POTENTIALLY
OVER APPROPRIATING. PROPOSITION
AND EAKER T. I'D BE INTERESTED
LA- THOUGHT ON THAT THOUGHTS ON
THAT BUT I TAKE IT THAT THE
ANSWER TO MY QUESTION IS THAT
THIS. WEEK WITH THE QUESTION WAS
WHY DO WE CHOOSE TO USE PROP
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING AS OPPOSED
TO NONPROFIT INDIAN FUNDING. AND
I THINK THE ANSWER HEARD WAS.
BECAUSE THAT'S TRADITIONALLY THE
WAY WE'VE DONE IT- BUT I WOULD
ALSO POINT OUT THE TRADITIONALLY
WE'VE NOT RUN OVER THE GANN
LIMIT. AND SO WE HAVE A AN
INTERESTING. SITUATION AN
OPPORTUNITY HERE. TO INVEST NINE
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING IN A WAY
THAT I THINK WOULD- ALLOWS HAVE
A BIGGER POT FOR EDUCATIONAL
NEEDS IN AND SINCE WE'RE SITTING
IN BUDGET SUB ONE. I WOULD JUST
EMPHASIZE THAT THERE ARE A LOT
OF NEEDS THAT AS WE DISCUSS
BEFORE UNLIKE OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE. ARE K. THROUGH
TWELVE. AND SO YOU KNOW I
PERHAPS IT'S WISE TO USE PROP
NINETY FUNDING FOR THIS BUT BUT
I HAVEN'T FELT LIKE THERE'S BEEN
ANY KIND OF. RATIONALE GIVEN
OTHER THAN THIS IS THE WAY WE'VE
DONE THINGS AND THAT MAYBE THAT
MIGHT WELL BE TRUE BUT BUT WE'RE
WE ARE IN AN UNUSUAL TIME AD I
JUST WANT TO KNOWLEDGE THAT.
YEAH WE HAVE WE WAY OVER AGAIN
LIMIT AND SO WE CAN TAKE THOSE
DOLLARS FROM THE NONPROFIT
NINETY FUNDING AND USES FOR THIS
PURPOSE. AND I THINK HAVE UNLESS
ELLIE- TELLS ME I'M WRONG HERE.
I HAD WHAT WAS EXPLAINED TO ME
IS THAT WE WOULD HAVE A BIGGER
PART OF FUNDING UPFRONT NINETY
EIGHT FOR SOME OF THE OTHER
NEEDS. THAT WE'RE DISCUSSING
INCLUDING THE HEALTH INSURANCE
FOR PART TIME FACULTY AS WELL AS
SOME OF THE OTHER- PRIORITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN EMPHASIZED IN THE
PREVIOUS ISSUE SO. I'LL JUST
MAKE A GENERAL POINT- AND I
ASKED EARLIER. IF YOU HAVE ANY.
FURTHER COMMENTS ON THIS. YOU'RE
JUST TO POINTS FIRST- OF. I
THINK WHAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND SAY IS THAT. THESE
PROJECTS DEFERRED MAINTENANCE OR
FIND IT WOULD PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE.
THAT'S HOW K. FOURTEEN EDUCATION
IS PRIMARILY FUNDED A AND B. THE
GUARANTEE IS GROWN A GREAT DEAL
AND SO THERE IS MONEY- A LOT OF
DETAIL ON A ONE TIME BASIS FOR
THESE KINDS OF PROJECTS. THAT
SAID I THINK CENTER REMEMBER
WHAT YOUR THE FACT THAT. YOU'RE
HAVING THESE CONVERSATIONS NOW
IS REALLY IMPORTANT. BECAUSE
THERE IS AN ISSUE OF EXCESS
REVENUES- IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO- IT'S
IT IT'S IN THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN EXCESS REVENUES. AND
WE DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS NOW AND NOT WAIT
UNTIL MAY REVISED TO START THOSE
CONVERSATIONS HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS NOW DISCUSS WHAT
OUR OPTIONS ARE WHAT'S THE BEST.
WAY FORWARD TO TRY TO- ADDRESSES
ISSUE OF- EXCESS REVENUES THANK
YOU MISTER SHE HAS AN AND I JUST
CLOSE BY SAYING- I'M NOT OPPOSE
THE USE OF PROP NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING FOR THIS PURPOSE- BUT
I'D LIKE TO SEE MORE RATIONALE.
AND EXPLANATION FOR WHY WE'RE
MAKING THIS CHOICE BECAUSE IT IS
A CHOICE WE'RE MAKING. AND WE
ARE IN A UNIQUE POSITION WE HAVE
A LARGE SURPLUS THIS YEAR AND
WE'RE TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
DIVIDE THAT INTO DIFFERENT
PRIORITIES- BY. CHOOSING TO BE
USED AS PART NINETY FUNDING
MEANS THAT WE'RE NECESSARILY
TAKING AWAY PROP NINETY FUNDING
FOR OTHER PURPOSES SO I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO SEE MORE
EXPLANATION FOR WHY WE HAVE MADE
BY THE GOVERNMENT THAT CHOICE.
AND WHY THE LEGISLATURE TO GO
ALONG WITH THAT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND LET ME JUST SAY IN
CLOSING ON THE SIDE OF MY
APPRECIATE QUESTIONS OF BOTH MY
COLLEAGUES I THINK THEY REALLY.
A HIGHLIGHTED IT AND I AGREE
WITH THE SUGGESTION THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE CONVERSATIONS OUT OF
THIS BECAUSE- OF THERE'S A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT WAYS TO GO
AND I WOULD JUST RENEW. MY
COMMENT FROM A PREVIOUS ITEMS
THAT I THINK HISTORICALLY PEOPLE
THOUGHT COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
DIFFERENT THAN CSU AND UC
BECAUSE THEY HAVE LOCAL BONDING
AUTHORITY BUT I THINK. OUR
CHANGES TO MAKE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES LESS COMMUNITY HAS LED
TO LESS. APPROVAL OF THOSE BOND
MEASURES AND SO I HOPE THAT THE
DISCUSSION WE JUST HAD WILL LEAD
TO SOME ADDITIONAL RESOURCES. ON
THIS AS WE HEAD TOWARD THE MAY
REVISE. OR WITH THAT WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE. A TWO THE GLASS OF OUR
AGE ISSUES AND WE- ARE. GOING TO
MISS AND GET TO EXCUSE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND- THE
L. A. OVER WHO'VE. WHO'VE BEEN
VALUABLE IN OUR- OF FOR SEVEN
ITEMS. AND OUR PANELIST IS
DRESSED DR NAVARETTE FROM THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE SO WELCOME OF THIS IS.
ISSUE EIGHT THE STUDENT HOUSING
UP TO. THANK YOU SENATOR
LEARNING THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF WHERE CALIFORNIA WE
COLLEGES ARE IN STUDENT HOUSING.
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC
APPROXIMATELY 60% OF COLLEGE
STUDENTS FACE HOUSING INSECURITY
19% FACED HOMELESSNESS AMENDED
PANDEMIC SURVEY ADMINISTERED BY
OUR STUDENTS SENATE INDICATED
THAT THE PANDEMIC EXACERBATED-
BASIC NEEDS WITH 40% REPORTED
INCOME LOSS LEADING TO AN
INABILITY TO PAY FOR HOUSING
EXPENSES. I SHARE THIS IS
IMPORTANT CONTEXT IN THE WAY
THAT COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
APPROACHING HOUSING WHICH IS
VERY DISTINCT FROM- AND IN SOME
WAYS DISTINCT FROM OUR FOUR YEAR
PUBLIC PARTNERS THE KEY FOCUS OF
EFFORTS AROUND HOUSING YOUR- FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES REALLY A
BROWN FORD ABILITY. IN BEING
ABLE TO OFFER LOW COST
AFFORDABLE RENTS TO STUDENTS WHO
ALREADY HAVE LIMITED ACCESS TO
FINANCIAL AID AND OTHER KEY
SUPPORTS- ON THIS WITH THE GOAL.
THAT IT SUPPORTS THEIR OVERALL
EDUCATIONAL JOURNEY AND THEIR
ABILITY TO SUCCEED WE ARE
GRATEFUL TO SEE THIS HISTORIC
INVESTMENTS THAT WAS INCLUDED IN
TRAILER BILL SB ONE SIX NINE FOR
CALTRAIN COLLEGES AS WELL. AS
FOR YOUR PARTNERS WITH ONE
BILLION OF THOSE FUNDS
IDENTIFIED IN COMMITTED FOR
COMING COLLEGES. AS A FORMER
TRUSTEE CENTER WHERE YOU CAN
LIKELY ATTEST THAT CALIFORNIA TO
ME BECAUSE CHANCES OFFICE DOES
NOT HAVE A CENTRAL ROLE IN
STUDENT HOUSING. AND SO- AS THE
LEGISLATURE PREPARES TO BEGIN
REVIEWING APPLICATIONS THAT WERE
SUBMITTED IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT THESE APPLICATIONS WERE
SUBMITTED INDIVIDUALLY BY
DISTRICTS- WHO ARE INTERESTED IN
HOUSING- FOR MANY OF THEM THIS
IS THE FIRST TIME THEY'RE
ENGAGING IN THESE CONVERSATIONS.
NINETY FIVE APPLE ASIANS WERE
SUBMITTED BY JUST RISK RE. FROM
THE GRAMM PRO THAT THAT OF
FINANCE IN THE LEGISLATURE WILL
BE OVERSEEING. OF THOSE TWENTY
FIVE APPLIED FOR CONSTRUCTION
GRANTS FOR A TOTAL OF ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS ALREADY
EXCEEDING THE COMMITMENT- THAT
IS MADE SB ONE SIX NINE FOR
AFFORDABLE STUDENT HOUSING. LET
ME GIVE YOU SOME BRIEF CONTEXT
OF WHAT CURRENTLY EXISTS ON
BASED ON A GUN WE DON'T HAVE- WE
DON'T COLLECT DATA SYSTEMICALLY
ON THIS THAT WE DO HAVE AN
INTEREST IN ESTABLISHING THAT
ROLE. AS A SYSTEM ARE CURRENTLY
HAVE IS CURRENTLY SYSTEM
CURRENTLY HAS TWO THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED- AND- FIFTY STUDENT
CAPACITY FOR HOUSING ONLY TWELVE
ARE DISTRICTS. OFFER STUDENT
HOUSING SOME MORE TRADITIONAL-
RESIDENTIAL HALLS IS YOU MAY BE
USED TO. OTHERS ARE- THROUGH
PARTNERSHIPS FOR FAMILY HOUSING-
GIVEN THE POST TRADITIONAL.
COMPOSITION OF OUR STUDENTS.
EIGHT OF THE STUDENT HOUSING
COMPLEXES THAT WORK AND THAT ARE
AT OUR COLLEGES WERE CONSTRUCTED
OVER FORTY YEARS AGO AND THEY'RE
LARGELY IN RURAL AREAS OR-
BORDER AREAS OF THE STATE AND
MAY BE ATTRACTING OTHER STUDENTS
FROM. OTHER STATES. FRIEDMAN
CALLING. DO NOT HAVE TO. STUDENT
DATA THE WAY THAT THEY SUBMITTED
AS PART OF CAPITAL OUTLAY- WHERE
THEY INTEGRATE ON STUDENT
HOUSING AS PART OF THEIR-
EDUCATION PLAN FOR THEIR
FACILITIES MASTER PLAN WE
BELIEVE THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO DEVELOP. A CRITICAL ROLE BOTH
FOR THE LONG TERM AND SHORT TERM
SUPPORT BETTER COLLEGES WILL BE
NEEDING AS THEY ENGAGE IN
HOUSING- WE ALSO IDENTIFIED A
COUPLE OF AREAS- OF
OPPORTUNITIES WANT TO MAXIMIZE
THE RESOURCES IN THE HIGHER
EDUCATION STUDENT HOUSING GRANT.
I TO IDENTIFY ANY NECESSARY
STATEWIDE STANDARDS AND
REGULATIONS THAT CAN HELP. OUR
COLLEGES DEAL WITH THE
COMPLEXITIES THAT COME WITH-
HAVING HOUSING ON THEIR CAMPUSES
INCLUDING EMERGENCY RESPONSE-
AMONGST OTHERS WE WANT TO
MAXIMIZE FLEXIBILITY FOR LOCAL
PLANNING AND DECISION MAKING
BECAUSE LOCAL CONTEXT MATTERS IN
MANY DISTRICTS WILL WANT TO
SPECIALIZE THEIR HOUSING. TO
TARGET KEY POPULATIONS THAT ARE
AT GREATER RISK. WE ALSO WANT TO
CREATE THE CONDITIONS THAT
ENABLE- THE RECONDITIONING OF
STUDENT CENTERED SUPPORTS IT
ECOSYSTEM SO THAT WE'RE NOT JUST
BUILDING HOUSING FOR THE SAKE OF
HOUSING BUT IT'S TRULY CONNECTED
WITH ACADEMIC PATHWAYS OR OTHER
G. SUPPORT SUCH AS MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORTS. THAT STUDENTS MAY BE
NEEDING. OUR ROLE IN THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IS TO HAVE A
DISCUSSION AROUND S. OR BOARD OF
GOVERNORS HAS ESTABLISHED AND
AFFORDABLE STUDENT HOUSING COSTS
WORST- BY RESOLUTION AT ITS
NOVEMBER MEETING. THEY'VE HELD
ITS FIRST MEETING TO TRY TO
UNDERSTAND HOW WE CAN BEST
SUPPORT DISTRICTS THAT WANT TO
ENGAGE IN HOUSING INCLUDING- THE
CONSIDERING THE TOTAL COST OF
OWNERSHIP. AND WHAT OTHER
SUPPORTS THEY NEED. AS THEY
APPLY FOR THESE GRANTS SO I HOPE
THIS HELPS- OVERVIEW IS HELPFUL
WEEK FROM I PROVIDED SOME FOLLOW
UP MATERIALS AND TO- DR FRANCIS
THAT CAN BE SHARED WITH THE
COMMITTEE. THAT SHOWS- SOME OF
THE DATA THAT WE COLLECT FOR
CAPITAL OUTLAYS WERE FACILITIES-
THAT IS NOT COLLECTED WITH THE
DIRECTION THAT WE REALLY WANT TO
MOVE AND SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT OUR DISTRICTS. ARE
AND WE'VE ALSO PROVIDED AN
EXAMPLE OF A. COLLEGE THAT DOES
HAVE HOUSING SO YOU CAN GET A
CONTACT OF THE ROLE. THAT IS
PLAYING AGAIN I WANT TO AND-
THAT OUR HOPE IS THAT- THIS
SPRING AFFORDABILITY AT THE
FOREFRONT TO OUR STUDENTS AND
CONNECTION TO STUDENT SUCCESS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
ARMINA S. MY COLLEAGUES IF THEY
HAVE QUESTIONS FIRST. JUST TO
CHECK. ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES. I JUST HAVE
TO THAT SENATOR MAN- I
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL HERE AND WE JUST SAY
YOU KNOW I REPRESENT AN AREA
WITH A NUMBER OF COME A
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND- WHEN I
FIRST LEARNED ABOUT THE HOUSING
AND FOOD INSECURITY THAT WAS
PREVALENT IN THESE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN ORANGE COUNTY OF ALL
PLACES. I WAS REALLY SHOCKED.
THIS IS A CRISIS- YEAH OBVIOUSLY
IT IS VERY DIFFICULT TO STUDY-
TO ATTEND CLASSES IF YOU'RE
WORRIED ABOUT WHERE YOU CAN
SLEEP ON A GIVEN NIGHT SO I KNOW
IN THE PAST WE'VE ALLOWED. WE'VE
HAD PROPOSALS SOME OF WHICH ARE
PASSED TO ALLOW FOR- PEOPLE TO
SLEEP IN THEIR CARS ON A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PARKING LOTS
AND THINGS OF THAT ATURE BUT
BUT WE NEED TO ADDRESS THE CORE
ISSUE HERE WHICH IS PROVIDING
HOUSING FOR ME COLLEGE STUDENTS
SO I THINK THIS IS A GOOD FIRST
STEP BUT I WOULD EMPHASIZE IS
JUST THE FIRST STEP AND WE
REALLY NEED TO CARRY THROUGH
HERE BECAUSE- THIS IS AN
EXPRESSION OF OUR VALUES AS A
STATE. ARE IN A DEFECTIVE WE
HAVE STUDENTS IN COLLEGES- THAT
ARE ESSENTIALLY HOMELESS IS IT'S
JUST SHOCKING AND UNACCEPTABLE
TO ME. THANK YOU ARM. CENTER
OCHO ABOVE. YES I MY QUESTION IS
THE FOLLOWING. WHAT ARE THE
CHALLENGES IF ANY HAVE THE CCC
ENCOUNTERED SO FAR IN DEVELOPING
ADDITIONAL STUDENT HOUSING WHAT
IS YOUR BIGGEST OBSTACLE. OUR
OBSTACLES. YEAH THANK YOU FOR
RAISING THAT ISSUE THAT IT THAT
IS ONE KEY AREA THAT- WE ARE
FOCUSING ON- SO HOUSING IS NEW
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES AGAIN
ONLY TWELVE- OF OUR IT DISTRICTS
ACTUALLY HAVE IT. SO WHAT THEY
ARE ENGAGING NOW IS IN INITIAL
PLANNING THAT CONSIDERS- YOU
KNOW WHAT ARE SOME OF THAT THE
RISKS THAT ARE INVOLVED- AND
HAVING STUDENTS ON THEIR
CAMPUSES TWENTY FOUR SEVEN- HOW
DO YOU PAY FOR. THE CONSTRUCTION
AND THE LONG TERM MAINTENANCE OF
HOUSING AND THEN WHAT SUPPORTS
DO YOU PROVIDE STUDENTS SO THAT.
THEY CAN BE SUCCESSFUL IN THAT
HOUSING- AND THEN IN IN THEIR
ACADEMICS THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
CONSIDERATIONS THAT- ARE UNDER
WAY INNER SENSUALLY NEW FOR MANY
OF OUR DISTRICTS. AT THE
STATEWIDE LEVEL AND SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES BUT OPPORTUNITIES AS
WELL- AND- TO CONNECT- HOUSING-
AND PROVIDE A STATE WIDE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR IT- WE WOULD
FIRST BEGAN BY COLLECTING DATA
ON FOR STUDENTS. AND STUDENT
HOUSING AS PART OF OUR CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROCESS BEFORE I DISTRICT
CONSIDERS A NEW PROJECT THEY
HAVE AN INITIAL PLAN PROPOSAL
WHERE THEY THINK OF ALL THE
CLASS RACE- HOW IT CONNECTS TO
AN AD PLAN AND THEIR OVERALL
FACILITIES. AND THEN THAT'S IT
THAT IS- THERE'S TECHNICAL
SUPPORT PROVIDED TO DISTRICTS
ALONG THE WAY- BEFORE- BEFORE
ANY OF THAT- INFORMATION AND
THOSE PROPOSALS GO TO THE
LEGISLATURE. THAT DOESN'T EXIST
FOR HOUSING AND WE'RE LOOKING TO
CREATE THAT SO THAT. ON WHO
WOULD BE SERVED HOW THE WOULD BE
SERVED THE COST PRO DAD- AND
OTHER HE SUPPORTS THAT WOULD BE
PROVIDED ALONG SIDE WITH THAT
HOUSING THOSE ARE JUST SOME OF
THE INITIAL AREAS THAT WE
OBSERVE. OKAY SERVE I AM I GONNA
INTERESTING I THINK YOU'RE
ANYTHING ABOUT ONE. LAND OF
PURCHASES OR CONSTRUCTION COSTS
SO IT'S INTERESTING- THE COMMENT
YOU JUST MADE THANK YOU THERE
FOR I FOUND VERY HELPFUL. THANK
YOU. SENATOR AND THEN LET ME
JUST MAY BE CLOSE WITH OUR
COMMON BECAUSE I THINK. A CENTER
MEN OUTLINED THE ISSUE VERY WELL
AND I APPRECIATED CENTRO CHAU
BOOKS QUESTION AND I. I ALSO
HEARD TO COMMENT DURING THE
PRESENTATION ABOUT THAT I WOULD
WELL KNOW THAT THEY BURKE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE DOESN'T PROVIDE THE
INDIVIDUAL HOUSING BUT I ALSO
WELL NO YOU COMPILE THE
INFORMATION AND DIRECTED TO US
FROM ALL THE DECENTRALIZED.
CAMPUSES AND THAT IS AN
IMPORTANT ROLE IN THIS IN AND
AGREEING WITH SENATOR MAN.
THAT'S MY EIGHT YEARS ON A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BOARD WHICH
ENDED WHEN I CAME INTO THE
LEGISLATURE TWENTY YEARS AGO. IT
NEVER OCCURRED TO US THAT PEOPLE
WOULD BE HOMELESS THIS WAS WHERE
PEOPLE WERE LIVING WITH THEIR
FAMILIES AND THE COMMUNITIES
GENERALLY WHERE THEY WERE
RAISED. HIM THE WHOLE NOTION
THAT NOW I GO TO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT'S. CAMPUSES IN
MY DISTRICT AND AMEND TOLD THE
325% OR HOMELESS AND THERE'S A
MUCH HIGHER PERCENT OF HOUSING
IN SECURITY. IS SOMETHING THAT
IS A CHANGE THAT IS DEVELOPED
AND IT IT FITS WITH THE EARLIER
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE FACT THAT
WE CAN'T HAVE A THING IN THE
FUNDING FORMULA ABOUT THE COST
OF LIVING BECAUSE THE COST OF
LIVING IS LEADING TO THAT IN
SOME OF THESE. ARE AREAS AND AS
A RESULT THIS IS NOT A USUAL
THING FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
DO THE- ONE CENTER ROAD SHOW
ABOVE MENTIONED LAND AND
CONSTRUCTION COSTS- I THINK
THERE ARE MANY COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THAT HAVE LAND I.
VISITED QUEST NORTHERN ST LOUIS
OBISPO COUNTY JUST TEN DAYS AGO.
THEY HAD LAND THAT THAT THAT
THEY COULD DO BUT THIS IS JUST
NOT ANYTHING THAT HISTORICALLY
HAS EVER BEEN DONE. OUT WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF A FEW COLLEGES THAT
I THINK ARE LARGELY RURAL AND
HAVE PEOPLE COMING FROM WAY FAR
AWAY AT THE TRIED. TO
ACCOMMODATE IT AND SO. THIS IS
NO. AND THIS IS NOT WHAT A LOT
OF CA COLLEGES WAS OF THEIR- AND
YET. I APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE SAID
THEY WANT SUPPORTS. BUT THE
BASIC NEED FOR HOUSING IS THE
IMPORTANT THING AND I HOPE THE
SUPPORTS DOESN'T TURN OUT TO BE
A LIMITER IN SOME WAYS BECAUSE-
EVEN THOUGH I WOULD LOVE TO SEE
IT FOR EVERY STUDENT IS HOUSED.
THE PRIORITY IS TO MAKE SURE THE
HOUSING HAPPENED AND THIS IS.
OUR THIRD HEARING FOR THE
BRANCHES OF HIGHER EDUCATION WE
HAVE HEARD FROM CSU. WE HAVE
HEARD UC AND TODAY WE'RE HEARING
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ALL THREE.
ARE COMING- WERE APPROPRIATED
OUT OF MONEY FROM THIS RIGHT
FIRST ROUND OF. OF HOUSING MONEY
THAT WAS IN THE BUDGET LAST YEAR
MOST TO BE SPREAD OVER THREE
YEARS. AND EVERY SINGLE SYSTEM
IS HOPELESSLY OVER SUBSCRIBED IN
WHAT THE DEMAND IS AGAINST WHAT
WAS APPROPRIATED LAST YEAR SO I
THINK THAT. EVEN THOUGH WE ARE-
WHAT ARE THE L. A- WENT. AND
FINANCE GO I JUST HOPE FINANCE
HERE'S- THAT THIS IS STILL VERY
MUCH A NEED AND WE ARE LOOKING
FOR PLACES. WHERE THERE ARE ONE
TIME EXPENDITURES THAT ARE
RECURRING AND THIS WOULD BE ONE
SO IF THERE IS AN ISSUE. OF FOR
ADDING AND TRYING TO PICK IT UP
. A AND AS I SAID BEFORE THIS IS
THE SAME THING AS DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE OF THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT A LOCAL BOND
SHOULD BE REQUIRED TO DO SO. I
JUST HOPE THAT THIS IS A GREAT
START AND THEIR CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE NEED
THAT IS NOT BEING ADDRESSED AT
THE THREE BRANCHES AS WE HEAD TO
THE MAY REVERSE. ANY FINAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
OTHER CENTERS. R. I. C. THE HAND
UP FROM THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. WELL AS A
SENATOR LARRY JUST WANTED TO
PROVIDE ONE CLARIFICATION THAT-
DAY GRANT PROGRAMS THAT- WAS
ALLOCATED IN THE STATE BUDGET
LAST YEAR. EACH DISTRICT HOW TO
APPLY ON THEIR OWN THOSE
APPLICATIONS DID NOT GO TO THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE THEY WENT
DIRECTLY. TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND THE LEGISLATURE WILL
ULTIMATELY BE- AND IN
COLLABORATION WITH AND THE
CURRENT FINANCE WILL DECIDE WHO
RECEIVES THESE GRANTS ARE THE
LEGISLATURE WILL ENGAGE IN THIS
CONVERSATION. BEGINNING MARCH IS
OUR UNDERSTANDING. AND WE WERE
ABLE TO. ACCESS TO SOME OF THESE
APPLICATIONS THANKS TO OUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE LEGISLATURE SO
WE APPRECIATE THAT GRAHAM. BUT
WE DO WANT YOU TO BE PART OF THE
CONVERSATION SO THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE THIS. END WE ARE NOW
GOING TO MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT
AND WE HAVE TWENTY FIVE MINUTES
LEFT IN THIS HEARING. AND SO-
ANYBODY THAT WANTS TO
PARTICIPATE BY PHONE- IT'S AT.
877-226-8163 THE ACCESS CODE IS
SEVEN THREE SIX. TWO EIGHT THREE
THREE. AND I ASSUME THAT SOME
POOR MODERATORS BEEN STANDING BY
FOR SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF THIS
HEARING WAITING ON I AM AWARE
THAT WE HAVE AT LEAST. TWO
PEOPLE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM BUT
I AM TRYING TO ASSESS HOW MANY
PEOPLE WANT TO SPEAK. TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE A SENSE OF. OF WHETHER
WE HAVE TO LIMIT OF THE TIMES
THE MODERATOR WELCOME TO THE-
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU AND MISTER
CHAIR WE CURRENTLY HAVE TWENTY
FOUR IN OUR COMMENT QUEUE OKAY
AND THAT USUALLY DOUBLES SO.
WHAT THATMEANS IS THAT I AM
GOING TO HAVE TO SEVERELY LIMIT
THE TESTIMONY. AND WE HAD TO DO
THIS FOR THE UC HEARING. SO I
THINK WHAT I'M GONNA HAVE TO DO.
IS ASK PEOPLE TO SAY THEIR NAME
THEIR ORGANIZATIONAL AFFILIATION
AND ONE OR TWO SENTENCES ABOUT
WHAT THEY SUPPORT WHETHER THEY
SUPPORT. REFORMING THE SKIFF
WHETHER THEY SUPPORT. OF
STUDENTS SUPPORTS SUCH AS- ARE
WE HEARD IN THE ONE ITEM WHETHER
THEY SUPPORT THE ENROLLMENT
GROWTH AND THEN ANYTHING ELSE
THAT THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY
ARE WE KNOW THEY CAN WRITE US
AND WE WILL INCLUDED IN THE
RECORD SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO BE
REALLY BRIEF- IN THE TESTIMONY
TODAY. AND SO LET ME FIRST
MODERATOR BEFORE I GO BACK TO
YOU LET ME GO TO THE ROOM AND
ASK IF THERE'S ANYBODY IN THE
ROOM THAT WISHES TO TESTIFY. AND
I APOLOGIZE FOR THE BREVITY SO
IF YOU JUST YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION AND WHAT YOU
SUPPORT. SURE ENTER MARTINEZ
WITH A COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BUT WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE INVESTMENT AND A COST
OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT FOR THE NON
ALLOCATE INCREASE JAPAN'S BECOME
MORE AVAILABLE USUALLY RECOGNIZE
THE PENSION OBLIGATIONS ARE
SIGNIFICANT PART ACROSS THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I'M
NEXT. MISTER SENATORS MIKE YOUNG
WITH CAL BETTER OF THE SUPPRESS
SUPPORTER OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO INCREASE THE FUNDING
FOR THE PART TIME FACULTY HEALTH
INSURANCE PROGRAM BY TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. WE THINK THIS
IS A SOUND INVESTMENT THIS TIME
IN JUSTIFIABLE WERE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE MORE DETAILS IN WRITING
APPROPRIATE NK YOU
AND THANKS BOTH OF YOU FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE- IN OUR LIMITS.
SAYING NO ONE ELSE MOVING TO THE
PODIUM AND- COMMITTEE ROOM. A
MODERATOR LET ME MOVE TO YOU AND
WE'RE GONNA. TRY TO DO THE SAME
THING WHICH IS B. AS BRIEF AS
POSSIBLE AFTER NAME AND
AFFILIATION AND WHAT YOU SUPPORT
AND I JUST. WANNA HATE TO DO
THIS BUT IF PEOPLE GO ON AND ON
I'M GONNA JUST TEST THE
MODERATOR TO MOVE TO THE NEXT
CALL. SO MODERATOR OF WHAT'S HOT
WIRE UP THE COLORS FOR.
PRESENTATION TO THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LINE
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIRTY FIVE PART TIME
INSTRUCTOR AT FULLERTON COLLEGE
LONG BEACH CITY COLLEGE IN EL
CAMINO COLLEGE HIRED THE
LEGISLATURE TO SUPPORT THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONGOING FUNDING FOR PART TIME
FACULTY. HEALTHCARE IN
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. NINE
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINDA CHEN CST
PART TIME FACULTY COMMITTEE
CHAIR PRESIDENT OF CITY COLLEGE
ADJUNCT FACULTY FEDERATION AND A
FORTY YEAR PLUS PART TIMER ARE
YOU TO SUPPORT THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR ONGOING CLINICAL
PART TIME FACULTY HERE BECAUSE
HEALTHCARE SO THAT OUR FACULTY
TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE PROVIDE
THE QUALITY EDUCATION THAT OUR
STUDENTS IN THERE THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR COMMENTS MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. NINE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS LAURA SWEENEY AND I'M
PART TIME HISTORY INSTRUCTOR AT
THREE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CHECKS FOR EIGHT YEARS.
THANK THAT INSTRUCTS THE
RELIGION MEDICAL COVERAGE TO THE
CLASS CANCELLATION IMPACTS MY
ABILITY TO FOCUS ON THE NEEDS OF
MY STUDENTS AND THEIR EDUCATION.
I'M HERE TODAY TO URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FOR THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ARE GOING FUNDING FOR
HEALTH CARE FOR A PART TIME
FACULTY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT COLD. NINE
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU TO
OPEN TELLER LOCAL AREA KEEP
FORTY FOUR HUNDRED I'M A FULL
TIME FACULTY AND THE PRESIDENT
OF THE CABRILLO COLLEGE
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS A WALL TO
WALL UNION I'M HERE TODAY TO
SUPPORT MY PART TIME COLLEAGUES
AND URGE YOU INTERNET SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR THE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION NOT GOING
FUNDING. FOR HEALTH CARE
PREFERRED PART TIME COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THANK YOU THANK YOU
TAVEN UNCHARACTERISTICALLY BRIEF
FOR SOMEBODY FROM SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY SO THANK YOU OUR
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. NINE TWENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI I'M DO WE WILL GRAHAM
AND I AM THE SECOND VICE
PRESIDENT FOR TWO DIFFERENT
SKILLS THAT EL CAMINO AND
GLENDALE COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
I'M HERE TODAY TO URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FOR TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
IN ONGOING FUNDING FOR HEALTH
CARE DEPARTMENT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FACULTY. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS-
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. NINE
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS STILL WHO I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF A OF T.
SIX ONE FIVE SEVEN YOU SHALL BE
A BROKERAGE IN THE PICTURES. I
ALSO HAPPEN TO BE A FORMER FULL
TIME FACULTY MEMBER AT SURREAL
COLLEGE- MY PART TIME COLLEAGUES
DO THE SAME WORK WE DO SERVE THE
SAME STUDENTS WE DO AND THEY GET
SICK LIKE WE DO. SO I'M HERE TO
URGE YOU TO PLEASE SUPPORT THE
BILL THIS RECALLS WHAT YOU ARE
GOING ONGOING FINANCIAL PART
TIME TO COLLEGE FACULTY
HEALTHCARE THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MODERATOR NEXT CALLER
. NINE TWO. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. J. I. M. HI MY
NAME IS NATASHA SHORO. A PART
TIME ART INSTRUCTED COAST
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT I AM
HERE WITH OTHERS CFT MEMBERS
TODAY TO URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TWO HUNDRED
MILLION AN ONGOING FUNDING FOR
HEALTH CARE FOR PART TIME
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN ON ONE OF THE
MANY PART TIME FACULTY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WHO HAD
GONE TO A SUDDEN HEALTH CARE I'M
SO VERY GRATEFUL TO COAST-COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT. BUT
THE PORTING ME WITH MY HEALTH
BENEFITS THIS GAVE ME THE
INSPIRATION ENERGY AND DESIRE TO
BE. MY VERY BEST. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS WE REALLY
APPRECIATE COME A MODERATOR
NETBANKING WITH. NINE TEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME'S BETH JOHNSON AND I AM THE
PART TIME REPRESENTATIVE FOR SAN
DIEGO MAYES IN SOUTHWESTERN
COLLEGES AND I'M CALLING TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF GOVERNOR NUISANCE
PROPOSAL FOR TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING FOR PARKS AND
HEALTHCARE THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR CALLING IN.
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. NINE THIRTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE THIRTY SEVEN YOU
MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
ALREADY BEEN MANY PERCENT I'M A
TENURED FACULTY MEMBER IAN YES
I'LL AND THE FACULTY UNION
PRESIDENT FOR AMERICAN RIVER
COLLEGE. I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THEM BREAK FALL OUT OF FOR. A
SURELY IT THE COMMITTEES FOR
COMMUNITY FACULTY AND STUDENTS.
AND I RESPECT. URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE FUNDING FOR PART
TIME FACULTY HELP HERE- THEY
WORK AND HOW MY PART TIME
FACULTY COLLEAGUES TO WORK AT
HARD AS A FULL TIME FACULTY. AND
THEY NEED. TO HAVE THANK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR- HI UP.
FOR HAVING TO WHICH TO GET TO
EVERYBODY BEFORE NEW. A
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. NINE THIRTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JOHN
HOPKINS I PART OF THE PART TIME
FACULTY MEMBER AT HEATING A MESA
COLLEGE FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS
I'M WITH THE S. P. AND I AM
CALLING TO URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
GOVERNOR REASONS PROPOSED. FOR
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
ONGOING CLINICAL PART TIME
FACULTY HEALTHCARE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR CALLING
IN MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. NINE
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
DR MINDY SALON AND I'M A PART
TIME INSTRUCTOR IN THE BRAIN
FITNESS PROGRAM FOR OLDER ADULTS
AT SANDY HOOK COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. I'M ONE OF THE MANY
PEOPLE WHO WALKED THE FULL TIME
POSITION DUE TO COPE IT IS ONE
OF THE MANY USING OUR YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE. LEARNERS OF
DIVERSITY INCLUDING OUR AGING
POPULATION THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR
TWO HUNDRED MILLION AN ONGOING
HEALTH CARE FUNDING FOR PART
TIME. COMMUNITY FACULTY LIKE ME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS THE MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. NINE FORTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS SHARP PROBLEM A PART
TIME POLITICAL SCIENCE
INSTRUCTOR AT THREE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT IN
THE BACK OF AN ERA MARKED ON THE
EXECUTIVE BOARD Y. C. A. S. T.
IN THE NEXT THE PRESIDENT OF
LIKE THE F. T. OF CLASHING MANY
I'M HERE TO. TODAY TO URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR TWO HUNDRED MILLION
IN ONGOING FUNDING FOR HEALTH.
CARE PART TIME TO MAKE COLLEGE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY. FOR
AND- NEXT CALL. NINE FORTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BARNEY SCHOENBERG PART
TIME ANTHROPOLOGY PROFESSOR IN
SAN DIEGO FOR THE LAST TWENTY
TWO YEARS BUT LOSING MY COVERAGE
THIS MONTH AND ASKING FOR
SUPPORT FOR THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION IN ONGOING FUNDING FOR
PART TIME FACULTY HEALTHCARE IN
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE APPRECIATE YOUR
CALL MODERATOR NEXT A CAR. NINE
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS VALERIE
MORALIS I'M A PART TIME
COUNSELOR AT BIG ABOUT COLLEGE
I'M HERE TODAY TO URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
TO TWO HUNDRED MILLION AND
ONGOING FUNDING FOR HEALTH CARE
FOR PART TIME COMMUNITY FACULTY
MEMBER THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MODERATOR NEXT
CALL. NINE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEY
THIS IS LAUREN BOULDER ON A PART
TIME FACULTY MEMBER AT THE
CANNELLA COLLEGE IN SANTA MONICA
COLLEGE AND I'M CALLING IN TO
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR ONGOING
FUNDING FOR HEALTH CARE FOR PART
TIME FACULTY THAT COULD BE LIFE
CHANGING FOR MY COLLEAGUES AND I
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR CALL. MODERATOR
NEXT CALL. NINE FIFTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JENNIFER
SHOULD NOT BE ON A FULL TIME
FACULTY MEMBER AND MERRITT
COLLEGE IN OAKLAND AND PRESIDENT
OF THE CAUCUS OTHERS SPEAKERS AT
THE LOCAL SIXTEEN OH THREE. I'M
CALLING AND DATA IN FAVOR OF
PRIORITIZING REPURPOSE SUPPORT
PART TIMERS WITH HEALTHCARE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF. A MODERATOR NEXT CALL. FIND
FOR THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
GREETINGS SENATOR LADO AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ANGELA HOW BILL CONDON- I'M AN
ADJUNCT PHILOSOPHY AND
HUMANITIES PROFESSOR AT
SOUTHWESTERN COLLEGE CITY
COLLEGE AND MIRAMAR COLLEGE AND
ON THE SELECTING COMMITTEE OF
THE ARAB FILM FESTIVAL I'M HERE
TODAY TO URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
GOVERNOR NORTHAM. PROPOSAL FOR
TWO HUNDRED MILLION FUNDING FOR
HEALTH CARE FOR PART TIME
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY I WANT
TO SERVE MY STUDENTS IF I AM AND
I CANNOT SAID OF THAT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. NINE
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS. OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS MIKE BRADBURY I'M A JUNK BOND
INSTRUCTOR KRISTEN IN THE CITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT I CALLED TODAY
TO ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
ONGOING FUNDING FOR PART TIME
FACULTY HEALTH INSURANCE THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. NINE
FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BERMAN A FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH AND CALLING ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA YOUTH
CONNECTION WE LIKE TO SUPPORT
FOR A TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
FUNDING DOCUMENTATION FOR THAT
NEXT STEP PROGRAM TO ALLOW
POLICY ACROSS THE WHOLE STATE
CHAPTER OPPORTUNITY TO SUCCEED
IN COLLEGE WE ARE ALSO
SUPPORTERS BUT SENATE BILL EIGHT
EIGHT FIVE WHICH WILL REMOVE THE
EXISTING CAP ON THE NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. SECOND RICH THE NEXT
UP BUT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE. YOUR CALL
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. NINE SIXTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS APRIL ALLEN
PRESIDENT OF ASG SIX TWO EIGHT
SIX ENTERED THE VALLEY COLLEGE
I'M HERE TODAY TO URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FOR TWO HUNDRED MILLION IN
ONGOING FUNDING FOR HEALTHCARE
FOR PART TIME COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACULTY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR CALLING IN. MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. NINE SIXTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING JESSICA FALCO ON
BEHALF OF CHILDREN NOW UNDER
ISSUE SIX CALLING TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING FOR THE NEXT
UP PROGRAM UNDER ISSUES BY
SUPPORTING THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
TRANSIT REFORM AS PROPOSED BY
THE GOVERNOR UNDER ISSUE THREE
PROPOSED CHANGES TO THE HOLD
HARMLESS PROVISION AND ADDING A
FIRST GENERATION METRIC TO THE
STUDENTS- FUNDING FORMULA. OR TO
THE ITEMS THAT WE SUPPORT AS
WELL AS UNDER ISSUE ONE THE-
SUPPORT RETENTION AND ENROLLMENT
STRATEGIES THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR CALL. A
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. NINE FIFTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS TERRA
POTTER AND I AM A FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH WITH JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES
FOR YOU. WE WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE
TWENTY MILLION FUNDING
AUGMENTATION CONNECT THAT
PROGRAM FOR FOSTER YOUTH AND
REMOVAL ON THE CAP ON THE NUMBER
OF DISTRICTS ACCURACY FUNDING
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. NINE THIRTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING STEPHANIE
GOLDMAN ON BEHALF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE SUPPORT
PART TIME HEALTHCARE. FIFTEEN
MILLION PER YEAR PS FOR STUDENT
RECRUITMENT OR ATTAINMENT
FIFTEEN MILLION PER MAKE THE
PROGRAMS TO EXPAND ALL COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BUT WE ARE CONCERNED
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S FUNDING
FORMULA PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR CALL MODERATOR
NEXT CALL. NINE SIXTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS DARLA DONALD FROM
COLLEGE OF THE CANYONS AND I'M
CALLING TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR
TWENTY MILLION. DOLLAR FUNDING
AUGMENTATION FOR THE NEXT A
PROGRAM FOR FOSTER YOUTH AND
REMOVAL OF THE CAP ON THE NUMBER
DISTRICTS THAT CAN RECEIVE
FUNDING THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MODERATOR NEXT CALL. NINE
SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
MICHELLE UNDERWOOD ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ADMINISTRATORS
WE BELIEVE THAT SKETCH SHOULD
RECEIVE BOTH THE STATUTORY FORM
AS WELL AS AN INCREASE TO BASE
FUNDING WELCOME BACK WE REQUEST
ASSISTANCE FROM THE STATE FOR
CONCERTS CALPERS EMPLOYER
PENSION COST INCREASES. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MODERATOR MEXICO. NINE THIRTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE MORNING CANDIDATES
GAINING SANTIAGO WITH CALVARY
COLLEGE WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. A MODERATOR NEXT CALL
. NINE SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
LIN **** AND I'M A FULL TIME
COUNSELOR AT ST OF COLLEGE AND A
LOCAL FACULTY UNION PRESIDENT
WHO REPRESENTS SEVEN HUNDRED
ADAM FACULTY I'M HERE TODAY TO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FOR TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
FUNDING FOR HEALTH CARE FOR A
PART TIME COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACULTY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR NEXT CALL.
OUR FINAL COMMENT IN Q. IS MINE
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS JANE THE MEDIC KERR AND
I'M AN ADJUNCT FACULTY
INSTRUCTOR IN DANCE AT ORANGE
COAST COLLEGE I'M HERE TO URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TWO HUNDRED MILLION IN
ONGOING FUNDING FOR HEALTH CARE
FOR PART TIME COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACULTY. ALL OF THAT THAT SOME
POINT IN OUR LIFE WILL REQUIRE
CARE FOR SERIOUS SITUATION
WITHOUT THAT CARE WE CANNOT
CONTINUE TO DO OUR JOB THAT WE
LOVE EDUCATING. SO PLEASE I URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL FOR TWO HUNDRED MILLION
ON GOING FUNDING HEALTHCARE FOR
PART TIME COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACULTY THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU. AND MODERATOR THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- WORK I KNOW HANDLING THE
ABBREVIATED TO. THE ABBREVIATED
TESTIMONY WAS DIFFICULT AND YOU
HAD TO STAY. OF FOR A LONG
HEARING BEFORE WE GOT TO USE SO
I APPRECIATE YOUR SERVICE ARM
LET ME MISTER CHAIR YES. WE HAVE
TIME FOR TWO MORE COMMON. ONE
MAKE TIME BUT THAT'S IT SO LET'S
GO. THANK YOU LINE SEVENTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD- HISTORIC GASPARD I'M A
STUDENT AND MEMBER OF GENERATION
TOP WHICH IS A DIDN'T LET
EDUCATION HAPPENS ORGANIZATION-
I'M HERE TODAY TO VOICE. MY AD
GENERATIONS UP THE FOR THE
GOVERNOR FOLLOW UP TO A MILLION-
FOR PART TIME. FACULTY HEALTH
CARE- THIS WITH A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT STUDENTS JUST ABOUT
TEACHERS. ARE TEACHERS ARE
IMPORTED THAT OUR STUDENTS ARE
IMPORTANT SO. THAT YOU APPROVED
THE MEASURE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. THANK YOU MONTEREY. NINE
SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU FOR MAKING
THE TIME I NAZARIAN JOHNSON
BOARD PRESIDENT OF STATE CENTER
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT AN EXTENSION OF
OUR EMERGENCY CONDITIONS. IT'S
CORRECT BECAUSE THERE IS A LOT
OF NEW ONES IN THE FUNDING SH WE
NEED TO GET IT CORRECTED WE
SHOULD INCREASE. FUNDING FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WHICH IS 30%
LOWER THAN CATER TWELVE AND 70%
LESS THAN ARE YOU SEE COLLEGES
OR COMMUNITY COLLEGES SERVE A
100% OF PEOPLE AND OUR STUDENTS
ARE PART TIME STUDENTS STILL
NEED TO EAT THREE MEALS A DAY-
THE STATE ECONOMY RECEIVED A
CARD. ACT ON. THEIR IMMEDIATE
NEEDS TO EAT THREE MEALS A DAY
AS WELL. SO I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR- THAT YOU WERE THE LAST
CALL. IN SO LET ME GO BACK TO
THANK THEM. AGAIN AND LET ME
THANK EVERYBODY FOR THEIR
PATIENTS AND PARTICULARLY THOSE
TO JUST TESTIFIED AND WANTED TO
HAVE LONGER STATEMENTS. AND
THOSE THAT MAY HAVE WANTED TO
TESTIFY IN INDIA AND DIDN'T GET
THROUGH. SO IF YOU WERE IN THAT
CATEGORY. PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS IN WRITING
TO THE- BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE ONE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL RECORD
SO THANK YOU. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION AND COOPERATION WE
HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA FOR
TODAY'S HEARING. THE SENATE
BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW SAID
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE STANDS
ADJOURNED.